I pledge allegiance to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
Republic for which stands one nation
under God I'm jce John man I'm
oh sorry I soon I wanted thank you
representative s everybody else should
be on
mute good morning everyone I'm Michael
Vose as chair of the house science
technology and energy committee I find
that due to the state of emergency
declared by the governor as a result of
the covid-19 pandemic and in accordance
with house rule 67 and the governor's
emergency order number 12 pursuant to
executive order
2020-4 this public body is authorized to
meet
electronically this is a public hearing
of bills referred to to the science
technology and energy committee
executive session on pending legislation
may be held at any time please note that
there is no physical location for
members of the public to observe and
listen contemporaneously to this
meeting however in accordance with the
emergency order I am confirming that all
members of the committee and select
select legislative staff have the
ability to communicate contemporaneously
during this meeting through the zoom
electronic meeting platform and the
public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate in this meeting by
the zoom platform or by
telephone all necessary access
information has been made available in
the house calendar and through the
electronic calendar on the general court
website the notice for this meeting
complies with house rules and RSA
91a anyone who has a problem accessing
the meeting should call
27136 or email
HCS
l.st
do.
Us in the event the public is unable to
unable to access this meeting the
meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled the staff for this meeting
who is assisting us today is Jennifer
four committee
researcher please note that all votes
that have that are taken during this
meeting shall be done by roll call
vote and we will start the meeting in
just a minute by taking a roll call
attendance when each member states their
presence please also State whether there
is anyone in the room with you during
this
meeting because that's required under
the right to know
law
uh the chair recognizes representative
Thomas thank you
um we we cannot hear representative
Thomas
I was merely stating that uh I do not
see the clerk here in present so we're
asking someone to please uh take notes
until he
arrives representative Platt do you have
a roster of uh members of the
committee representative clet is
searching his
briefcase
sorry for the delay committee members
but um we did not anticipate that
representative mner would not be here
this morning he is our acting clerk for
this
week representative PL will be returning
as our clerk on next
Monday
forgive me um just wanted to mention
there is a list of all the committee
members on the House website the um
committee thank you I appreciate
that can you we actually have a contact
list with all of those
names
me I believe representative McGee
prepared
that he probably doesn't oh there I
couldn't unmute myself I have here uh a
uh roll call for votes but it has all
the members and I'll use that for
attendance uh okay representative flet
would you call the roll call then for
attendance purposes shamman Vose are you
here
I am here Tom Doug of Representative
Thomas are you here I'm here
representative
Harrington representative
n here here representative murer
late uh rep I'm not on the uh I for the
moment I'm not on the
committee um representative
Bary presid
representative
Bernardi hear in
committee representative
camell hear in
committee representative CL how will you
say
it h how do you say it okay are you
here yes president in committee cl cl uh
representative
White pres of
suage yes I'm here in my C Pitts and I'm
alone representative Cali
pittz representative man I know you're
here representative oxenham
here Representative Vincent Vincent yeah
yeah Representative
Vincent representative
McGee
presid representative MC
Williams here representative
Christian you're
muted representative
chrisan yes I'm
here representative
pimel here and alone
representative
Pasion here and
alone and uh a representative
hola I'm hearing in the committee room
okay okay we have attendance we have 1
two 3 four five six seven 8 nine 10 11
12 13 14 15 16
present have pardon
what
say Jackie it's Jackie Cali
pits okay let's
see thank you representative plat with
17 members present we have a quorum to
conduct our business for
today and before we start our first
public hearing the chair recognizes
representative ssuch for a
question uh thank you Mr chair uh I just
wanted to bring up an issue that you and
I have had Communications about um and
that's really regarding a presentation
by De that they didn't get a chance to
do beforehand I know we are short of
time but a lot of the bills coming up
soon uh will be in the area of their
responsibilities and if we could have
maybe next Friday a short 30 minute
presentation maybe using some of our uh
lunch period as well as maybe a 15minute
delay in the other hearings we could
squeeze them in perhaps so I think that
would be advantageous if we could do
that thank you representative ssuch I
will check with the es to find out if
they could do a presentation at
lunchtime the chair recognizes
representative cran for a
question go I'm sorry that was uh from
raising my hand earlier about the list
of uh committee members on the website I
apologize
okay thank you very
much without further Ado then let us
begin the business of the day and I
will
call to order the public hearing on
House Bill
dfn which requires the adoption of
innovative vehicle emission standards
pursuant to section
177 of the the federal Clean Air
Act and I recognize representative MC
Williams the prime sponsor to introduce
this legislation representative
McWilliams thank you uh chair Vose and
thank you members of the committee uh my
name is representative Rebecca
McWilliams I represent the west side of
conquered uh at large um and I am
bringing this bill again um because
we've had a robust discussion uh during
the last session year about what New
Hampshire can do to address air
emissions quality and uh catch up to
some of the surrounding states and
policy that seems to be moving forward
towards air emissions concerns in the
United States so the bill is back um
there are some changes to this bill
since you've last seen it if you were
participating in st& the last go around
um right now the focus on the bill is
really to create an on-ramp for um car
dealers here in New Hampshire uh who
would receive retroactive credit for
having cars on their Lots so for
everyone else who has not yet seen this
bill let me just provide a little bit of
background um the intention of this bill
is to protect Public Health here in New
Hampshire U Motor Vehicles account for
half of the emissions of ground level
ozone which is a contributing factor to
asthma and we certainly have low-lying
areas within the state that are in
valleys um Keen as an example uh where
uh the emissions will sort of settle and
cause issues with human health um and
breathing problems uh in addition uh
motor vehicle emissions contribute to
one-third of New Hampshire's greenhouse
gas emissions which are also
contributing factor to climate change so
considering both of those factors this
is a
proactive um uh in addition this bill
also provides an emission specific
warranty for the vehicles that fall
under this legislation that is a 15-year
150 mile uh warranty specific to
emissions um which is obviously much
greater than what we have right now
under New Hampshire law for any of our
warranty requirements for cars uh
finally this sets percentage
requirements for car dealers here in New
Hampshire to carry zero emissions
Vehicles which we call zevs and low
emissions Vehicles which we call levs so
when I talk about zevs and levs that's
the
acronym um so right now we have limited
choices when someone decides on a
Saturday morning that they want to go
out and buy a car and they'll head to
their local dealership and depending on
where they're located in the state
whether it's a Metro or more rural area
um they'll go to their local dealership
and test drive some vehicles Les um
because New Hampshire is the only
Northeast State right now that's not
participating in section 177 which is
the California air emission standard
there is no requirement that a certain
percentage of vehicles on all dealer
Lots in New Hampshire actually meet the
zeven love requirements so basically
that what that means is when someone
goes out and decides they want to test
drive vehicles depending on what their
local dealership is carrying they may or
may not actually have an opportunity to
test drive that type of vehicle so there
are limited
choices um so knowing that um let me
just give you a little bit of background
about exactly what that means for
credits and uh dealerships carrying
certain types of zevs and lebs so
credits are based on a vehicle's zero
emission ranges so a long range vehicle
like a Tesla or a Chevy bolt could earn
as much as three to four credits plug-in
hybrids like uh the Chevy Volt as
opposed to bolt the volt is more like a
half of a credit so the credits
translate roughly into the automakers
selling a certain percentage in each of
the um increasing requirement years so
less than 5% zevs in 2023 less than 6%
in
2025 and this is based on the total
volume sold of each dealership so the
requirements for having the vehicles on
the lot change depending on the scale of
how many vehicles are sold per
dealership um so if a dealership fails
to meet the credit requirement then they
have another year to comply um or they
will end up paying a fine it really is
flexible and right now nobody in the
Northeast has been required to pay a
fine for missing um or not hitting that
credit requirement this has been um fair
and flexible up to this date um these
rules don't take take any Vehicles off
the road uh these rules do not force
anyone to buy a Zev um and the Zev rule
increases customer Choice meaning there
are more options for that type of
vehicle made by that manufacturer on the
lot the rules do apply primarily to the
automakers not to the dealers because
because it is forcing the automakers to
push out more zevs and levs um and it is
a Statewide rule but it's typically met
through the larger dealerships uh the
goal here is to address the need in the
state and start increasing our overall
State availability starting in 2023 and
moving forward 2025 2027 until it
becomes mainstream this is also not a um
Financial Credit system you may have
received some testimony um from folks
who oppose this bill saying well the
really the way to uh get people to
change behavior and buy Zev and lebs is
to provide some kind of state cash on
the hood program so that they will
actually buy the vehicle and get it a
tax right off or get money back that's
not the way this program has written
this program has written to Simply put
the cars on Lots in New Hampshire make
it available to the public so that
they're able to test drive and the more
they test drive the more they buy um
just a little bit of data about what's
been changing in the automo automotive
industry since I last presented a
similar version of this bill um
Volkswagen group has now committed to go
all electric by
2030 uh GM will phase out combustion
engines worldwide by 2035 and will be
carbon neutral by
2040 Ford is rolling out an all electric
F-150 this year which is their Flagship
vehicle um and they have a goal of
carbon neutrality worldwide by
2050 and Mercedes-Benz will produce
electrified versions of all of their
cars by
2022 so the future is now um certainly
we are seeing more and more of these
vehicles available and the intent of
this goal is to make New Hampshire an
opportunity for everyone who lives here
to test drive and potentially buy a Zev
or a
Lev thank
you thank you representative uh MC
Williams for your bill
introduction uh do we have any questions
for representative Mick Williams I see
there are a few I have a question myself
and I will start representative
McWilliams last year when we heard this
bill we were told that without a buyer's
incentive uh this bill would simply
unnecessarily penalize automotive
dealers does the new version coner
contain a buyer incentive
provision uh thank you for your question
chairman Vose uh just to be clear clear
this is not a cash on the H program and
there are no monies from the state that
are being given to people who purchase
Vehicles as an incentive uh that's
intentional I I have heard from the
opponents that you mentioned uh who say
that this program is not going to work
without the cash on the hood incentive
um and I I would respond to that by
saying we now have the critical momentum
that we did not have last year the
automotive manufacturers are now seeing
the writing on the wall and switching to
producing Zev and LS as a standard and
so the industry has now moved over that
huge hurdle therefore the state does not
need to take on that additional
Financial requirement taking everyone's
tax dollars and incentivizing
individuals purchasing and upgrading to
Zev and Lev um so I think you'll see
that um the market has shifted we're
pasted that
now thank you for that answer follow-up
question would be
if the manufacturers of these vehicles
have already pledged to make more of
them then why do we need to uh penalize
them for not making
enough so to be clear this is not meant
to be a penalty to Automotive
manufacturers this is meant to be a
please take those cars you've made and
deliver them to New Hampshire just like
you're delivering them to Massachusetts
Maine Vermont Rhode Island Connecticut
New York we'd like them too you don't
need to have your truck stop there and
not bring them here to New Hampshire so
it's not a penalty it's an
incentive okay uh well I'm gonna have to
follow up one more time and I apologize
for um that
but if it's not a penalty then why on
page two of the bill line
25 does it state that the Department of
Environmental Services shall impose a
civil penalty not to exceed $37,500
on any manufacturer who sells attempts
to sell or causes to be offered for sale
a new motor vehicle that fails to meet
the applicable emission standards that
sounds like a penalty to
me so just to be clear what you're
talking about is someone who's making a
false
representation which obviously through
law we don't want a false representation
about uh the air emissions quality of a
vehicle so the the intent of that
provision is to prevent manufacturers
from claiming I I know we've already had
a very large lawsuit about this a couple
years back um from claiming that the
tailpipe emissions are a certain
standard uh the Volkswagen lawsuit was
fought about this and then it turns out
that that's not the
case
okay thank you for that the chair now
recognizes representative oxam for a
question thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question
representative McWilliams
um is it not the case that the dealers
themselves are in
in a an inferior position against their
competitors across the state border
because of the fact that this provision
exists in other states am I am I
understanding that correctly or could
you could you help me out
there sure so I mentioned the shift to
Chairman Vose uh we are now experiencing
um a total shift when it comes to
manufacturers and commitments to Zev and
leves uh that means that the states who
are already on board to having a certain
percentage Zev and LS on their dealer
lots are now already receiving the
latest up-to-date latest and greatest
Zev and loves from the manufacturers and
that puts us in New Hampshire at a bit
of a
disadvantage uh because the dealers who
choose and there are some in New
Hampshire who choose to nonetheless
request Zev and LS even though there is
no credit associated with that um they
are often borrowing those cars from
across state lines in order to have an
appointment for a test drive for um
let's just say a a Chevy uh
bolt uh someone has called the dealer
usually um this is in a metro area so
let's just say someone calls a dealer in
Portsmouth and says hey I want to test
drive a Chevy bolt dealer in Portsmouth
says sure no problem come by Saturday
we'll let we'll let you drive one so in
Portsmouth they go to Massachusetts or
Maine and get themselves a bolt shipped
to the Portsmouth dealership they do the
test drive and if the person wants to
purchase the vehicle they can so this a
sort of Shifting and rotating stock but
in terms of actually being able to
schedule an appointment and drive the
vehicle you want there's no guarant
guantee that you'll be able to do that
in New Hampshire as opposed to if you
drive out of state you will be able to
find those cars you're looking for May I
have a followup follow up thank you very
much
uh I I live on the Connecticut River
boundary and when I was trying to buy a
zero emission vehicle I couldn't find
one in in New Hampshire and had to talk
to a manufacturer in Manchester and
drive to Manchester after they brought
car in and I was able to test drive it
whereas I could go 15 minutes away in
Vermont and have bought that car so this
I I what I'm trying to concentrate our
attention on is this is a benefit to New
Hampshire businesses and dealerships and
it gives them Leverage is is isn't
doesn't that also that the case
represented and and then I'll I'll stop
asking questions doesn't it give
leverage to our dealers to be able to
obtain these hot ticket
items have having this on the books yes
representative oxenham this does give
them leverage to have those latest and
greatest zevs and LS on the lot when
when they come out rather than having to
request them for a specific buyer
yes thank you thank you the chair now
recognizes representative Homa for a
question thank you chair and thank you
representative MC Williams for taking my
question uh the question I had is there
anything that currently prohib ibits
these uh manufacturers and dealers from
having these zevs and LS on their
lot great question the answer is
availability uh because we are the only
state in the Northeast that has not
signed on to CH uh section
177 it's very difficult to get these
vehicles because they end up going to
Lots in other states so availability is
the the big hurdle thank you can I have
a follow on chair follow up um the
follow followup I have is that you know
from what I understand car manufacturers
seem to do whatever is financially
advantageous for them and so I don't I'm
not really understanding why they
wouldn't do this if it's costing the
money why they would not want to offer
this product so I I'm just not clear on
how they
can't have this stock uh in place
already should should they
choose uh sure so just to give you a
little bit of background about how it
works at individual dealerships in New
Hampshire uh let's say that you're a
Ford dealership um Ford will require
that you carry a certain percentage of
your stock to be
um pickup trucks right those are the
ones that usually sell hot ticket item
construction vehicles uh they will also
require that you have a certain
percentage be um sedans which are not as
popular and don't sell as much so the
manufacturers are already putting
requirements on the dealers for what
they keep in their lots and their
percentages however the manufacturers
are not shifting down the Zan L
requirements at this time um and that is
something that the 14 States across the
US have adopted in order to provide some
kind of air emissions control because
the manufacturers are not doing that and
I would say that that's probably the
role of the legislature to come up with
what our expectations are for air
emissions not putting that on a
manufacturer
one more followup thank you thank you
for the followup um I understand what
you're uh what you're saying here the
one question I do have is it appropriate
for the legislator the legislation to be
telling the manufacturers what they
should be doing with their
stock so that is what the 14 States
who've adopted section 177 are doing and
I would argue that it has not died in
court so appropriateness from from a
Judicial perspective is yes it's allowed
um and certainly if we're talking about
changing the industry and pushing for
more and more emissions regulation here
in New Hampshire then yes it would be
appropriate for the legislature to be
asking uh manufacturers and dealers to
provide zevs and levs to New Hampshire
residents to test drive and purchase
potentially thank you thank you the
chair now recognizes representative nter
for a question thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for taking the question New
Hampshire already has more Electric
Vehicle registrations than Maine or
Vermont so why do we need a
bill uh representative n our our total
Fleet here in New Hampshire is less than
half a percentage of the entire state
that is electric vehicles so we have a
long way to go for it to become the norm
or the accepted practice and therefore
we need uh to provide more options to
buyers okay thank you uh
representative cam
brills thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative for taking the question
uh is C could you uh tell me if there is
anything prohibiting New Hampshire
dealers if they should get a request for
such vehicles from their customers from
having vehicles transferred from the
other states to their Lots because I
believe that that's a common practice is
there anything prohibiting them from
doing that with these type of vehicles
so representative cells as I stated
earlier in my testimony this has become
fairly common practice that uh a New
Hampshire buyer will request a New
Hampshire dealership to Source a vehicle
from out of state there is no
prohibition to this practice but there
is an availability issue you cannot
always get the vehicle you are looking
for as a dealership requesting from out
of
state okay thank you for that question
the chair now recognizes representative
ssuch for a
question thank you Mr chairman and thank
you uh represent MC Williams for taking
my question uh could you explain a
little bit more about what is the
additional extra warranty that buyers
would have if if the State signed up to
this
program uh sure
um so n Hampshire uh is fairly well
known for being a state where we don't
provide a great warranty especially for
lemons and used vehicles um we don't
currently have a lot of law on the books
that protects buyers from a lemon um
that's certainly something that could be
brought up as a separate pill at another
time um but it's sort of buer Beware
environment here in New Hampshire um so
one of the things that we're very
interested in doing with this bill is
allowing an emissions related warranty
and that is part of the section 177 uh
that will be brought into effect once
this legislation passes um the emission
specific warranty is a 15year 150,000
miles for emissions specific issues so
let's say that your tailpipe starts
getting Smoky um because you're driving
a hybrid low emissions vehicle and
obviously that's emissions related so
it's covered under the warranty it's not
going to cost anything out of pocket for
that specific owner um and I do want to
be super clear that there are um quite a
bit of savings related to emissions um
not just under the warranty program
which of course is an excellent 15E is
almost unheard of for standard vehicles
um you're you probably would pay a
little bit more than
$1,000 above your usual price to
purchase a Lev but your less Fuel and
maintenance net savings is approximately
$3,000 over the life of the vehicle so
you pay a th more you save three grand
so you've actually reduced your cost by
2,000 um for zevs this is where we're
talking about Teslas and um really
vehicles that are focused on zero
emissions approximate upch charge is
going to be 6,000 upfront but you'll
spend much less in fuel and maintenance
so your net savings is approximately
somewhere between 4,000 and
11,000 over the vehicle's life and that
depends on which one you purchased um so
the there is a really big potential for
savings if you're looking that 11,000
for a vehicle that's a Zev and you keep
it for quite a significant amount of
time so when we're talking about people
saving money through warranty we're also
talking about paying a little more
upfront but being able to save over the
duration and long term of owning that
vehicle uh Mr chairman
followup follow
up F represent MC Williams uh can you
can you tell me uh regarding these
credits what what are the benefits of
this program to the dealers and how does
how does that are the credits the
providing any benefit to the
dealer so the dealers are required to uh
achieve a certain number of credits
based on their sales volume credits are
not from sale of a vehicle credits are
from having a Zev or a Lev located on
their lot at their dealership so once
the vehicle is delivered once it arrives
at say this for dealership that we're
talking about once the vehicle arrives
on the lot that dealer gets the credit
for having it on the lot if they then
sell it and have another one delivered
they get the credit as soon as it
arrives on their lot um so the the
benefit to the dealer is really to have
these vehicles available for test
driving and for sales immediately not
having to coordinate with an
out-of-state dealership to bring in a
specific specific vehicle that someone
would like to test drive and being able
to have Cutting Edge topof the line
whatever the manufacturer is is now
pumping out for their latest and
greatest most efficient fuel emission um
emissions reduction vehicle thank you
thank you the chair recognizes
representative PL for a question thank
you don't forget to
unmute yes thank you uh rep
representative MC Williams earlier you
made statements that uh the
manufacturers all have goals to become
100% electric over a period of time and
I think you mentioned Volkswagen by 2
2030 and GM in a similar time frame if
so why do we need this bill if it's
going to happen
anyway that's a great question
representative plattin it's good to see
you um I think the biggest concern
really is making sure that New Hampshire
is right there at the front of the line
along with the rest of the
Northeast uh we want to make sure that
New Hampshire is not going to lose its
Edge or potentially competitive
advantage in receiving these vehicles at
the time that they are being released we
know that those percentage requirements
for credits for dealers outside of the
state will take precedence over dealers
inside the state so once again if there
is an 18-wheeler delivering vehicles to
the Northeast there going to drop off
those vehicles to the states that have
these credit requirements first and then
New Hampshire will be
second okay the chair recognizes U
representative Bernardi for a
question don't
forget I have a question for the chair I
see you're not recognized to speak just
yetes pitz you're next on the
list what representative bernardy
thank you chairman uh uh you you may
have just answered this uh but uh I'm
having great difficulty understanding if
these are the hot ticket
items why uh there's an availability
problem uh if if consumers want these uh
dealerships are going to have them on
their lot if they don't want them
they're not going to be there so please
explain the this
availability issue make it very
clear sure uh so right
now if there are brand new Chevy bolts
available for delivery to the Northeast
region they're coming from the
manufacturer and they're being shipped
up to the
Northeast there is an order of
Precedence based on dealership volume
and the relationship of the dealership
with
Chevy so there's sort of a packing order
already as to who gets the new
cars and they are shipping them to the
states that already have the section 177
requirement so that's all of the
Northeast except for New Hampshire as a
priority because they're required to get
those credits so New Hampshire falls
later in line because there is no credit
for the
manufacturer to deliver that vehicle to
New Hampshire right
now
chair follow up go
ahead okay so I understand that the
dealers in Massachusetts and uh other
surrounding states get some kind of
credit but we have very high volume
dealers in Manchester and other areas
here why are they not getting these
vehicles if they are the hot ticket
items and consumer really want them so
to be clear these dealers in Manchester
and Portsmouth can request the vehicles
and sometimes they do but they can be
turned down in favor of another state
that has the credit requirement they
fall later in
line thank
you uh okay thank you now representative
c p you recognize for a
question my first question is to the
chair as a procedural matter I guess I
had two much Super Bowl last night
because I'm seeing things that I
shouldn't see like gentlemen in your
Mountain uh and the other is that I'm
not seeing all the participants on the
screen so even the ones that are on the
phone don't appear with a phone number
so I'm very confused and I I wish you
could
um explain that to
me then I have a question for the for
Miss MC Williams but I guess I'm a
little lost now there he is again I
again I'm not on drugs but somebody's
appearing in your
Mountain okay can you explain that so
the mountain that you see behind me is
simply a background that I've chosen to
display when I'm on
zoom and uh that particular mountain is
POD Das Mountain if you care about that
the view from Hedgehog
Mountain um the other question you had
is you can't see all the
participants um not even the phone in on
Pardon not even the phone in once and
that gentleman is he sitting next to
you keeps popping up in your
mouth representative mner is sitting
next to me on my left and representative
Thomas is sitting next to me on my right
there was a view of the room here a
minute ago
but there I see the room view of the
room oh okay but apparently somebody
keeps coming into your camera view and
it really it bothers me but let me get
on with Miss McWilliams but I can't I
only see
16 people I don't see 17 and I didn't
see representative nada's phone usually
when somebody phones in you see their
number
representative M I had ask question
don't pop up anywhere please
representative MC Williams I remember
when we did the the conversion to
catalytic conversions and now we have we
try to AV uh to avoid tailpipe testing
in New Hampshire can you tell me what
what happens with tailpipe testing in
New
Hampshire I'm sorry I was muted um this
bill does not address tailpipe testing
in New Hampshire this bill is starting
from a specific date certain January 1st
2023 onward into the future dealerships
in New Hampshire are required to have a
certain percentage based on volume and
their relationship with the manufacturer
and the requirements of section 177
they're required to provide Zev and levs
for test drive and sale to the public
it's not about tailpipe testing at least
not this
legislation uh yes representative C
pittz and I now see what you were
talking about when you said somebody was
popping up in my picture it was
representative mner to my left so I've
adjusted my laptop a little bit so
hopefully he won't pop up in my frame
again but yes please follow up so I
didn't have too much Tom Brady um the
other question I have is when you could
you
clarify a Zev and a Lev I low emissions
I I believe this is my assumption are
hybrids and zero are electric am I
correct in that
assumption so yes the the zero emissions
vehicle is just what it says it it has
no emissions at all it's zero the low
emissions is some but not zero and
that's why the credits for low emissions
can range fairly significantly depending
on how much emissions we're talking
about but it's still a
reduction from a typical Automotive
vehicle thank
you thank you uh represent ative parall
is recognized for a
question thank you Mr chair and as a
side note to uh uh representative of uh
C pittz I'd be glad to spend two minutes
uh during our lunchtime if you'd like to
get your gallery view up I've got a full
view gallery and it that's all I can get
oh okay then maybe I can't help you U
out of my questions uh representative MC
Williams there's an earlier question
about the incentivizing consumers
isn't it less of a factor incentivized
purchase of sevs for those who seek 150
plus miles per gallon equivalent such as
my leaf
provides that sounds accurate but I
don't claim to be an expert on
this okay uh second question followup
yes please thank you this sounds like a
bill that would give our dealers the
same Market access as States that have
adopted the 177
standards would I have had a greater
choice in New Hampshire Market had I
access to the same zevs that are being
Mark made available to our neighboring
states that have already subscribed to
the 177
standards
absolutely thank you without doubt point
of order thank you what is your point of
order um you mentioned that
representative mner is s sitting to your
left has he taken over minutes because
I've been scrivening away here not yet
I'm just getting in not yet maybe he'll
take over at the next public hearing if
you could complete this one we'd
appreciate that representative thank
you okay um representative mgee has a
question you're recognized to
speak thank you Mr chairman uh and thank
you representative MC Williams for
taking my question um I read in a recent
Energy report report that the estimate
for uptaking New Hampshire of electric
vehicles in the next decade would be
around 177,000 vehicles and I'm curious
uh so it's basically you know um uh
forecasting what they think the demand
will be for people buying these new
types of vehicles and then you testified
about how the major car manufacturers
actually have set targets now for when
they will stop creating combustion
vehicles and really convert to all
electric vehicles
so I guess my question is how does this
bill support and I'm a co-sponsor but I
still think you can answer this better
than I could uh how does this bill
support uh those folks who are clearly
seeking these
vehicles uh and as others have said
rather than leaving it the way it
is so that's a really interesting
statistic that you bring up I think you
said
177,000 yes um that's a f fairly low
number um the working numbers that we
have from the last time um we went
through this sort of Bill research and
presentation process with Dees um was
approximately 1.4 million cars in New
Hampshire that's the existing Fleet
numbers that we've been using for annual
registrations of vehicles in New
Hampshire um so 177,000 out of 1.4
million is just a drop in the bucket you
know we only have 1.3 million people in
New Hampshire so obviously we've got
some two three four car households um
but 177,000 is super low um I mentioned
earlier that the industry is now
shifting we we've gotten over that hump
that hurdle that required cash on the
hood to change Behavior because the
manufacturers Ford Volkswagen group GM
and mercedesbenz have all made
commitments to go electric which is
great um so now what we're talking about
is trying to make sure that people can
test drive those vehicles um I I will
pull up the data and send an email to
the committee because I think it's
important that you understand that the
the numbers are super high of people who
actually have an opportunity to test
drive an electric vehicle who actually
do purchase so getting them behind the
wheel to try it out is really important
and that's one of the goals here is to
just increase the supply on dealer Lots
so that that can
happen I think you know I may this may
have been misleading because honestly
representative McGee do you need a
follow up yeah it's a followup to what
the data that I put up there please make
sure it's a question and not a statement
you are a co-sponsor in this bill
typically we don't allow co-sponsors to
to ask questions so make it those rules
at the beginning and you I thought you
had changed that Mr chairman he asked
that question at the beginning and you
said that they would be able to well
time permitting but the problem is we
have four more people who want to speak
on this bill yeah you can on okay thank
you all right so uh everyone who has
their hand raised has already asked
questions so we're going to of this uh
um person who's testifying
representative MC Williams so we're
going to move on and uh I'm going to
recognize now a member of the public
represented himself his name is Gerald
and I apologize if I mispronounced this
uh Gerald
b or
bosel morning belel thank you very much
Mr chair my name is charal belel um
president of Bethlehem New Hampshire and
uh like I said speaking on my behalf um
just from my background I have a uh
master's degree in theoretical physics
and I've been working in a number move a
little closer to your microphone or
sorry yeah I'll try to speak up a little
bit um so I just wanted to speak up for
this I'm not necessarily in favor of
this bill for a number of reasons and I
want to keep it brief um I think
California rules are probably really
good for California uh I do recognize
though that there's a different uh type
of economy a different type of ecology
they have large metropolitan areas that
they have to deal with and I think we
don't have quite as
many um so especially in some of those
areas where I live in Bethlehem we do
have um different needs for cars we
don't need U that many zero emission or
low emission vehicles but Trucks Than
SUVs and I fear that they could get more
expensive down the road um I think
there's also something that concerns me
generally um which is a dependence on
other states Regulators so if California
decides to make changes or um adjust
stuff it feels odds that uh our
regulations would automatically change
by that with little or no oversight from
what we're doing we could obviously opt
out of the program again but that would
introduce a lot of increased uncertainty
I guess um I think there's um some
concern for me about the cost um we
already see some implementation cost
some additional Staffing um there's an
un it's unclear um to what extent
there's U um additional third party
Services um what that cost would look
like uh I think there will be uh likely
secondary costs in the form of
implementation costs for the businesses
um potentially increases in the car
prices uh we may see like a shift from
out of state um um buyers that could ALS
Ely end up not buying quite as much in
New Hampshire because our car prices are
going up and honestly it's like there's
a 15% increase in sticker cost um that
is also already called out in the um in
the um thing as well and I'm just
thinking it's like during the Fairly
tough Economic Times we're in right now
I don't see that this is necessarily the
right time to start going into a regime
where we increase the cost for our
businesses and for our citizens across
the board so I'm worried about that and
then lastly um the benefits seem to me
is like based on what I've been hearing
in readings like really not that uh
instrumental yes we may be some of the
dealers May uh get a little bit higher
on the pecking order for certain
vehicles but generally speaking those
vehicles have been available to uh to
New Hampshire residents across the board
and to the dealers as well like like I
said maybe not quite as much as we would
like them to be but um that's true for
other models as well if I want a certain
specific model of a car then I may have
to get out of state in order to get that
as well as well so it's like it's not
only true for these but it's like a true
across the board and generally speaking
it's like just looking at the kind of
progress we've made based on voluntary
or the federal econ standards I think
over the last 20 30 years uh the
emissions from noxious gases and uh
greenhouse gases have gone down quite
significantly despite us traveling a lot
more when without our cars and having a
lot more traffic on the roads uh final
thing I just want to say is like I'm not
sure that emulating California or
adopting California regulations is uh
particularly good thing to do uh we
seeing that the overregulation that
California has been promoting has led to
uh companies and uh citizens leaving the
state so it's like I'm fearing that
similar things could happen to us if we
just follow that kind of model in
general I think it's best to leave the
decision on what to buy and what to
offer to the citizens to the businesses
and the manufacturers and not interfere
with this because the market seem to be
doing quite well in terms of regulating
as long as there's some broad General
guidelines and uh again it's like I
think California is like not really
great uh to emulate from energy policy
in general it's like they have rolling
uh brownouts they have electricity
shortages and uh like I said companies
leaving I would rather not see emulate
that so I'd ask you to vote against this
bill okay thank you Mr boel for your
testimony are there questions for
representative B I mean for Mr
boel uh representative Bernardi I think
you had a
question uh you made some very
interesting comments and I'm interesting
interested if you have done the analysis
of uh how much the electric rates or the
electric demand would go up if we
implemented this how much more
additional electricity would we need to
have available in New
Hampshire un I have not done that
research but uh I'd be more than happy
to sit down and look hard at that
afterwards if it's of Interest I'll
Circle
back any
followup okay any other questions uh
seeing none we'll move to our next uh
testifier who will
be Nicholas Thomas a member of the
public uh representing himself Mr Thomas
you have the floor
Mr Thomas is not
there okay in that case we'll move on
to um the next speaker who is Joseph
kwasnik a member of the public
representing himself Mr kwasnik you're
recognized to
speak thank you Mr chairman can you hear
me
yes uh today I'm providing oral
testimony in support of House Bill 168
and the reason for my support is that um
as we've heard today okay now we can't
hear you uh at least very very softly
you need to speak up move closer to the
mic or do something to uh make yourself
heard can you hear me better
now
no can you hear me
now that's a little bit better I'm sorry
um not sure what the technical issues
are uh can you hear Let me at least try
to give my testimony and if it doesn't
work I'll it
offline okay um as you've heard today uh
both levs and zevs will uh reduce
tailpipe emissions both in increasing
the health of our citizens in New
Hampshire and also reducing more
traditional tailpipe emissions that
cause
smog recent Studies have shown that um
levs and zevs are are less expensive to
own and operate over the lifetime
relative gas and diesel fueled options
in fact studies indicate that Vehicles
these vehicles save consumers between
$200 and $1,300 just in fuel costs alone
uh in these studies uh as we pointed out
before 14 states have already adopted
these standards and they surround New
Hampshire within New England and
Northeastern United States and finally
uh adoption these standards will improve
the overall health of our citizens of
New Hampshire let's do something to
protect our citizens and ensure that our
environment is cleaner and remains
attractive to our tourist and
recreational industry many of these
tailpipe emissions create smog which
causes visibility issues within the high
peaks of New Hampshire and I know that
um unable to see the high peaks will
certainly divert tourists to other
states that are actually adopt this
legislation I thank you for the time
today and hope you'll um vote in favor
of this legislation thank
you thank you Mr Quik any questions for
Mr
kwasnik before we move on to our next
speaker I have a couple of uh oh I see a
hand up from representative C pitz would
you like to ask a
question don't forget to
unmute yes please um Mr quic one of the
concerns that I have is that electric
vehicles are fine and I have actually
driven one
uh the cost and the
infrastructure um is that a problem in
New Hampshire particularly New Hampshire
because in order to drive these vehicles
we have to charge them somehow so is
this a little bit
premature uh a very good question uh a
couple of things that to points to point
out here is that um electric vehicles uh
their emissions is equivalent to what
the um what the emissions are for our
our system power that's supplied through
the region of iso New England so a point
there is that system gets cleaner then
the emissions associated with
electricity generated to supply for
those Vehicles goes down so they get
cleaner over time but also importantly
electric vehicles are part of the
strategy in electric distribution
companies New Hampshire as part of their
time of use rates in other words what
the utilities like to do is actually
shift the load from these electric
vehicles to the evening or off peak
hours where you actually have um
sufficient Supply in fact more more
Supply than you need so these actually
would be part of the strategy Within
These companies to utilize these to
actually reduce load and in many cases
um some of the more forward-thinking
people in this industry see them as
actually supplying energy uh during
times when there's not enough Supply so
they also could be part of What's called
the spinning Reserve so they actually
will be beneficial for our utility
system going
forward thank you thank you okay before
we move on to our next speaker I have a
couple of uh I neglected to make a
couple of announcements uh earlier the
first announcement is that the members
of the committee who are in the
Legislative Office Building are in a
different room today we're in the
finance committee room which is rooms
210 and 211 we're not in rooms 202 203
where we've been the last two meetings
so if it looks different to you on
screen that's because it is the other
thing that I forgot to mention earlier
is that for this bill in particular
representative uh uh excuse me U
Department of uh air division um leader
Mike Fitzgerald is here today and he's
available to answer questions if anybody
has any uh and I apologize to Mr
fritzgerald for for forgetting to
mention that earlier so with that said
we'll move on to our uh final speaker
for the day this is Dan Bennett who is a
lobbyist representing the New Hampshire
Automobile Dealers Association so Mr
Bennett the floor is
yours thank you Mr chairman can you hear
me
okay uh
yes okay uh thank you Mr chairman and
members of the committee my name is Dan
Bennett from the New Hampshire
Automobile Dealers Association we're a
trade group representing the motor
vehicle industry of car truck snowmobile
ATV construction farm equipment dealers
uh Statewide about 500
businesses in all corners of the state
and every um community so I will be
brief um and I'll also try and answer
some of the questions or comments that
I've heard um we once again uh similar
to as we did last year we oppose HB 168
but as written and our proposal once
again is that uh St committee consider
creating a legislative study Commission
on this bill on this issue to further
explore the possibility of creating a
successful New Hampshire solution for
the adoption of a z vehicle emission
standard we worked with the sponsor last
year as well as Department of
Environmental Services
and nescom and others when the bill was
originally filed however some of our
concerns still remain unresolved which
is why we again request uh that the bill
uh the issue be made into a study
commission so for a successful
program Emerging Markets like this need
to be pulled not pushed incentives work
you have to grow demand some of you all
may remember Cash for Clunkers in New
Hampshire New Hampshire had the highest
take rate per cap
Nationwide in Cash for Clunkers because
there was an incentive program all of
our neighboring states have incentive
programs even Rhode Island which doesn't
really does because they have a state
Fleet mandate for EVS so that is the
incentive there when Georgia repealed
their incentive program sales of their
EVS plummeted
83% when Massachusetts was on the brink
of repealing theirs they had the highest
take rate because
customers car buyers saw that that
demand going away plugin America is the
largest ev Advocate Group in the US last
week they released a report on the top
25 States for EVS
Nationwide New Hampshire was number 15 I
I think that's a great um a great stat
however to quote from the report that
was just published last week an EV
incentive is among the most effective
Ive means of increasing EV adoption and
each of the states in the top 10
featured a purchase
incentive so uh again
our our request for a study commission
is is in the hopes of a successful
program and without some type of Market
incentive this will not be an a
successful
program uh to address he or sell what
customers want
so they do swaps and trades on a daily
basis they can get vehicles um in all
makes models trims uh whatever the power
source happens to be they they they
trade on constantly
um so uh a couple other things I I'll
mention real quick um vehicle credit at
the time of delivery by the manufacturer
really is an unfair uh way of handling
it and it doesn't really help the the
true go emissions reductions if if
that's what this uh the goal of this is
just because they're delivered to the
dealer um and the credit is issued
doesn't mean the vehicle is on the road
and that's where the emissions reduction
comes from so uh this should really be
at the time of registration program not
the time of delivery to reduce emissions
just because it lands in New Hampshire
but it's back lotted doesn't help with
uh emissions reductions in air quality
and health issues so uh I offer that
um as as something to be considered um
if the committee does in fact decide to
do a study commission
um you know something I heard before
just to answer you know this is in fact
a penalty system you know if the
manufacturer doesn't deliver the vehicle
to the state based on a proportion or a
percentage they pay a fine so it is in
fact a penalty system um some of the
things that should be analyzed you know
through this is we have no idea what
this is going to do in the road toll so
our gas tax this have a longterm
analysis and the health of our road tool
should be conducted uh analysis of the
manufacturers production schedules
should be performed um they've stated
electrification goals and long-term
goals but in the short term in 2024
2025 it's unclear whether we can meet
whether those production goals will even
be um will be met we asked last time
when we looked at to to look at some of
the state Fleet numbers um so that we
have a clearer picture of what it is
that we're committing to in 2023 are we
committing to go from 700 vehicles to
1,700 or 700 vehicles to
7,000 and whether the manufacturer can
meet those goals so
um as mentioned a legislative study
commission um really I think would be an
appropriate step it should include the
legislature Dees
do uh the office strategic initiatives
the Public Utilities Commission about
electricity demand uh next time we be on
ourselves um and importantly the vehicle
manufacturers to continue discussion to
explore the potential but to come up
with a successful program and that's
what we're stating here so um with that
I will uh end my test testimony other
than just to answer one other quick
question I heard from representative
Cali pittz regarding tailpipe testing in
New Hampshire we don't tailpipe tests
when we made the uh agreement with the
APA multiple years back in Le of
tailpipe testing in our um more
polluting counties what the state agreed
to was to do OBD2 which is onward
diagnostic testing um
Statewide uh and it's actually a
thorough uh check of the emission system
as a whole it can actually detect
whether you have a loose uh a loose uh
fuel cap as opposed to just testing at
the tailpipe the muffler as well so
that's why we arrived at OBD2 testing
Statewide in New Hampshire so um other
than that thank you for your time I know
I moved through rather
quickly that's our uh our stand on HP
168 and if there are any questions I
will attempt to um to answer them and if
I can't I'll get back to the committee
with those
answers okay thank you for your
testimony the chair recognizes
representative Thomas for a
question uh thank you Mr chair and thank
you Mr Ben for taking my question um I
apologize your testimony came over very
fuzzy here and I really didn't catch a
lot of it so I apologize if I'm asking
something that you may have already said
but my question
is if there was a large demand here in
this state for these
vehicles what is preventing the
manufacturers from offering incentives
like they do with other vehicles to sell
more of of those cars could you explain
that for me
please uh yeah I mean I'll do I'll do my
best the the one thing I'll say is
manufacturers make cars dealers sell
cars so dealers sell what the customers
want and they Source their vehicle Fleet
based on demand New Hampshire has a
higher take rate of pickup trucks so
dealers stock their Lots with more
pickup trucks than say commute or
passenger sedans so uh the dealers sell
and and Market their product based on
what their customer base wants and
desires follow up follow up uh thank you
Mr chair so uh to paraphrase I believe
what you just said are are you to to
clarify are you saying that the dealers
here in the state don't see the demand
for these vehicles and so therefore uh
they're not getting incentives to sell
more of them is that what you're
saying well dealers see the demand and
when they do they go out if they don't
have that vehicle they easily go out and
Swap and obtain that vehicle
from a dealership that does whether it's
in state or whether it's cross state
borders swaps And Trades happen on a
daily basis whether it's for an electric
vehicle or whether it's for uh the
Harley-Davidson Edition for that
150 thank
you the chair recognizes representative
nter for a question thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking the
question I was struggling with the with
the audio quality as well
uh if you haven't done so already could
you please email us your
testimony yes and I apologize for the
audio quality represent I will certainly
get written copy of my testimony to the
committee um again uh emphasizing that
our request for 168 uh be formed into a
study
commission you need a followup okay uh
next up then is representative
cran thank you Mr chair and thank you Mr
Bennett for taking my question um so you
mentioned a few times that you were
eager to have a successful program uh
established can you just tell me a
little bit about what your criteria for
a successful program would look
like yeah well I mean one some of the
things I mentioned and I'm sorry if it
didn't come across the successful
program would have to do with analysis
of the impact on the road toll analysis
of what our vehicle Fleet would look
like and as you know history and other
states have shown a a mandate such as
this that does not have an incentive
does not set up a program for success I
mean we knew it was fa right that's why
we put more panels on rooftops we have
incentive programs emerging like this
they need to be pulled along and the way
that you pull that along is through
incentive programs and that's what
creates Success New Jersey has a very
robust program do you know why they put
$55,000 on the hood of the car to the
customer to incent those Vehicles other
states that do they have HOV lanes and
electric vehicles get access even with
solo drivers to those those HOV lanes so
uh innovative ways uh and it's not just
always as mentioned you know dollars on
the hood but Innovative incentive
programs so that the programs can be
successful so that these vehicles make
it out into the market and and and
they're driven the same way we do with
the example I use is we put more panels
on
roofs
answer so so just to clarify you would
be in favor of an incentive program
where the state of New Hampshire was
providing dollars to customers for adop
these
vehicles the so I don't want to commit
the devil's in the details right but our
belief is that if there is an incentive
program it's got a much much higher
chance of success so if there is a
program the incentive
really definitely should be part of
it uh representative Bernardi is
recognized for a question
yes uh thank you Mr chairman uh um so
and thank you speaker if if new hampire
has more uh EVS than both Vermont and
Maine who already have this program how
do we know it's going to work in New
Hampshire we don't hence the need for or
our request or belief that a study
commission is Justified
to explore the issue to see whether it
will be
successful okay thank you the chair
recognizes representative pimel for a
question thank you Mr chairman uh thank
you Mr benett for being here um I have a
question are you familiar with the uh EV
and
uh uh L vehicle sales in are surrounding
states that uh do have this
program basically the question is do you
know how they're doing with this with
this
program uh in in
effect I mean one statistic that we've
talked about before and I believe maybe
one of the agencies that's listening in
could weigh in on it is is that we
basically have equal to the EV
registration as main does
and Main has this prog in place and we
don't okay thank you
Vermont I don't know about the Vermont
statistics what I do know again I go
back to is that Vermont has an incentive
program to to you know financially
incentivize and get more Vehicles out on
the
road okay thank you the chair now
recognizes representative PL for a
question thank you Mr chair Mr Bennett
you mentioned speak closely to the
mic thank you Mr
Bennett your mic is not
working
thank you and Believe on now thank you
Mr chair thank you Mr you had mentioned
this study
commission here for incentives my
question is should there be a study
incentive how to get
manufacturers to provide vehicles to the
deers or can they handle that themselves
thank so um I apologize the question was
was um very tough to hear but I think
what you're asking is whether the study
committee would look at manufacturers
providing the vehicles to the
dealerships um and if
so if that if that is in fact a question
our belief is that the manufacturers
wholeheartedly should be part of of the
study commission um to offer input and
insight as to what even more production
volume will be um and whether we have
these targeted goals of X percentage of
vehicles on the road whether they can
even make so
many shy bolts Nissan leavs electric
food
F150s uh or rivan for that matter uh
that that Fleet targets could be
obtained so yes just like um some of the
regulatory agencies that I mentioned
Dees nsom do uh the dealers and the
manufacturers should be part of that
study commission
um to to chart that that path
forward okay next up the chair
recognizes representative ssuch for a
question
yes thank you Mr chairman and thank you
Mr Bennett for taking my question um
just to clarify if if you like you
mentioned about the swapping of vehicles
um if I decide to look for a Zev vehicle
in New Hampshire and the local
dealership gets me that vehicle from
another state and I purchased that
vehicle in light of the fact that we're
not part of this California Arrangement
do I still get the extended warranty
that was
mentioned uh thank you for the question
ref of s uh I don't believe you do
because the state of the Hampshire is
not uh has not adopted the California
Zev mandate so that would not
apply so uh follow up follow up go ahead
yes so to clarify I wouldn't get that
extended
warranty uh but it would get credited to
the Massachusetts dealership as far as
having sold that vehicle is that
correct
well so so uh and thank you for the
question two-part question coming there
so one you as the New Hampshire resident
I don't believe um and department
environmental servic maybe this credit
would not get that warranty however the
credit is not issued to the dealership
the credit and the penalty is the state
to the
manufacturer it's at the time of
delivery when that Vehicle Manufacturer
drops that vehicle on the lot of the
they get the the the credit it's a uh
it's a delivery credit it's not a sale
credit okay thank you very much thank
you the chair recognizes representative
PL for a
question don't forget to
unmute thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question Mr Bennett if uh the
Zev and Les are truly competitive why do
we need an
incentive I I I think the the nature of
this of bill is showing that the market
is not quite ready and this is this is
the way to Spur the market this is the
way to grow the the Zev
um know zero Mission or uh battery
hybrid electric vehicle the Beav uh
market so this is acknowledgement that
we're try that the attempt is to try and
grow the market that's what this program
is and so we ain't trying to grow Market
you need to pull it along and that's
what the incentive does same thing with
I take that example that I use Cash for
Clunkers we were trying they were trying
to get dirtier heavier polluted Vehicles
off the road what did they do they gave
an incentive a tradeing credit get the
dirty vehicle a dirtier vehicle off the
road will gave you $3,500 to trade it in
towards the purchase of a newer cleaner
vehicle and that's when New Hampshire
had um
a highly successful highly positive te
rate you need a followup representative
PL apparently representative PL is now
on the phone so we'll move on uh I have
a question for you U Mr
Bennett Charlie Baker the governor of
Massachusetts recently signed into law a
bill that forbids the sale of internal
combust engine cars after the year
2035 although it apparently isn't
binding uh I don't know what kind of a
law that would be but uh in his uh
explanation of the law he suggested that
Massachusetts needs to acquire
750,000 electric vehicles by the year
2035 now that is only 14 years from now
and in order for Massachusetts which
currently has about 30,000 electric
vehicles to get 750,000 Vehicles by 2035
they would need to sell
51,500 electric vehicles per year for 14
years and at an average cost of $50,000
a vehicle that would be about $2.5
billion do that Massachusetts consumers
would have to Fork over to buy these
cars that would generate about about
$155 million in taxes for the state of
Massachusetts my question is doesn't a
policy just as the one Massachusetts
just adopted kind of subvert this
legislation thank you for the question
uh Mr chairman and I to uh concur with
you that I believe that um Governor
Baker's announcement was a uh a policy
statement um I don't believe it was
anything that he had signed into law
however in looking at those
Massachusetts numbers um what I would
say is it's it's detailed analysis to
see the numbers and the rate and um how
quickly and the absorption rate and the
cost at which that would come to both
the state and the citizens uh and that
is something that this proposed
legislation has not not even done so we
don't know what uh that massive number
of volume of cost um or purchase level
by customers to achieve the goals
prescribed in the bill to not have the
manufacturers incur penalties that could
potentially be cost on passed on to the
dealer to raise the cost of vehicles
that type of analysis as the
Massachusetts stuff that you brought up
has not been done for a New Hampshire
model
which is why our suggestion again is to
to slow walk and study it and do that
detailed level of
[Music]
analysis thank you my apologies for
misspeaking it's not legislation it's a
plan according to news reports uh the
chair now recognizes representative Pim
minel for a
question uh I don't have a hand up do I
I'm sorry I miss I I meant to say
representative partial sorry thank you
Mr chair thank you uh
speaker um a
question did I hear right where in the
bill did it State there would be a fine
for not carrying Lev and Zev emission
cars I did not see that in the bill did
I miss
something thank you representative um in
section three Roman numeral one and
Roman numeral two talks about civil
penalties and uh Roman three talks about
the funds received from the penalties
will be deposited into the motor vehicle
air pollution abatement fund established
in RSA 125 so if the manufacturer does
not deliver the prescribed number of
vehicles to the
state then the Department of
Environmental Services is empowered to
find the Manu manufacturers for not
meeting those delivery
targets and that's follow you follow
up yes please
um what would as we are not uh
undertaking commissions at this time
what would your alternative be to
creating a study commission to solve
this
problem uh I I if if what the
legislature wanted to do was convene an
informal ad hoc study commission the way
it happened over the summer related to
uh zero emissions rules I I assume that
might be an opportunity um but a study
commission uh you know and our belief
and our advocacy for a study commission
as we did last year as we do again this
year is the best chance of success to
keep the discussion going and moving
towards potentially um a a positive
result and a successful program so we
continue to believe that a study
commission is the best course of
action thank you thank you
representative Thomas is recognized for
a
question uh thank you Mr chair for
allowing one more question for me thank
you Mr Ben from taking this question uh
this is more of a technical question uh
based on an article I I recently read a
day or two ago
um I seem to recall uh what is your what
is your
um can you verify or clarify for me the
um emissions that we might be saving
from having EVS in our in our in our
field here in in our state my uh my
readings indicated to me that uh the uh
environmental damage that is done in the
manufacturer of EVS because of the
batteries that they use and so forth
that the average EV would have to be
used approximately seven years before um
they'd have a a zero sum can you tell me
what the expected life Capac expectancy
is of an EV and uh here in the state of
what people are driving and and and uh
comment on that statement that that I
just
made yes and thank you for the question
representative Thomas I will uh do my
best I am unfamiliar with
the study that you're
referencing um as far
as uh the emissions reduction um you
know per EV uh however that's something
that the uh the study commission that
we're proposing certainly should review
and look at it's one of the reasons
we're suggesting uh you know folks from
Department of envirment Services and
nescom certainly be involved uh those
are the experts at looking at emissions
reductions maret and goals um however I
do know according to RL pop which is you
know an industry data uh compiler the
average life cycle of a vehicle is just
shy of 12 Years so the average vehicle
on the road I believe is like 11.9 11.10
month old so
um that's the age of the average age of
vehicles on the road so uh to reference
your seven-year number um industry aages
about
11 thank
you thank you we're just about out of
time representative uh oxam do you have
a very quick question I do thank you
very much I I I would ask that that
question was just answered could be
directed to Mike
Fitzgerald he's been waiting to to
provide information on this um related
points about
emissions
Mr Fitzgerald you are now permitted to
speak oh don't tell me get stepped out
of the
room I'm sorry I had to
unmute um go ahead thank you we can hear
you okay thank you um Mr chairman uh
thank you for the opportunity to speak
um uh first I I also would like to send
my uh greetings to representative PL and
best wishes and his continued recovery
um and uh uh in response to the uh
question that was asked um the
department has not run specific current
specific numbers for this legislation we
did provide some
information um last year which could be
updated um there are there are emissions
and environmental benefits
um depending on the number of vehicles
that would be uh that that are uh are
purchased in response to the to the
requirements um uh and uh um but I I
can't quantify those at the uh at the
moment uh thank you Mr fitzgeral before
we go any further I want
to open the public hearing on HB 289
and then recess that hearing for the
time being uh re representative oxam did
you have excuse me did you have another
question don't forget to for not
lowering my hand okay thank you uh
representative PL is recognized for a
question don't forget to
unmute I just wanted to thank Mike
Fitzgerald for a
well wishes I'm off oxygen except for
when I'm acting walking actively
otherwise I'm totally off it so I'm
making rapid
progress okay thank you representative
PL uh representative pantel is
recognized for a
question thank you Mr chairman thank you
uh Mr
Fitzpatrick um I have a question one of
the things that came up is that we're
putting the cart before the horse as far
as uh trying to get more electric
vehicles in the state because we have
nowhere to charge them and I was just
wondering where are we as a state as far
as charging electric
vehicles sure um thank you very much for
that question representative and uh um
the department uh is actively
participating in the uh Volkswagen
funding uh program with the uh um
governor's office of strategic
initiative and um that is part of the uh
uh strategy is to increase the uh number
the amount of EV infrastructure in the
state currently New Hampshire does lag
uh many other um New England states the
governor has recognized this and has uh
authorize that the full
15% that is allowed under the VW
agreement be authorized for use of uh in
and incentivizing additional EV
infrastructure um it's also been
recognized as a tourism issue here in
New Hampshire that many people in the
Metro region south of us um uh may or
may not choose to uh to come here if
they have electric vehicles and they
want to um uh you know be able to to uh
to come to New Hampshire and charge
their vehicle and get back home safely
and get around um many resorts are
starting to adopt uh and hotels are
starting to adopt technology and have
parking spaces for
EVS um and um so uh it is it is coming
along but um we we do uh we do fall
behind other states surrounding
us thank you Mr
Fitzgerald follow go ahead okay thank
you Mr Fitzgerald
so on the on the uh public on on the
public side
um do you know how many charging
stations are actually in installed in
the state whether they're in uh Bank
parking lots or hotels or uh whatever
you know where we are there on the on
that uh I know that we have that
information available I can can send it
to the committee uh following the
hearing I don't have it right with me at
the
moment thank
you okay uh representative ssuch is
recognized for a
question thank you Mr chairman thank you
Mr Fitzgerald uh Mr Fitzgerald um can
you confirm the fact that there are
there there are at least uh some models
out there that are zero emission that
operate on hydrogen and not just
EVs and a second question I have is
regarding the penalties in this bill um
I believe represent McMill has mentioned
that those penalties apply when a
vehicle is
delivered uh and doesn't meet the
emissions requirements not not that this
is a penalty for not delivering such a
vehicle is that
correct um so you had a two-part
question there um I guess the response
to your first part is there are uh Zev
vehicles um that that are hydrogen
they're very advanced technology
vehicles and I believe there's extremely
limited supply of those um again those
would be directed to other other states
if they're available um other states
that have adopted the uh the Zev program
um in um your
uh uh second question I'm sorry could
you ask repeat the uh second question
you wanted me to confirm something yeah
sure the the bill in in this oh the
penalties yes um I I believe although I
haven't had a chance to to to look at it
overly carefully but I I believe one
point to make is that um section 177 of
the Clean Air Act only allows New
Hampshire to adopt the California
program um or or other section 177
States um a state cannot create a third
car program there's either the federal
program or the California program and if
a state wants to adopt the California
program they must adopt it in its
entirety with no changes um and uh in
particular no changes that would so to
speak create a third U third type of
vehicle that the manufacturers would
have to to purchase if it had a
different warranty requirement or say or
something like that so that's one key
Point um so whatever penalty Provisions
are in the California regulation would
be the same as
those um those here um again to the best
of my knowledge no penalties have ever
been levied by a by a uh no pen no pun
intended L State um and uh uh but the
the provisions would be against as I
understand that they would be against
the manufacturer for failure to deliver
the vehicles that were required in a
given model
year to the
state okay thank you Mr Fitzgerald the
chair now recognizes representative Tim
Lang who is substituting today for
representative Nick white representative
langing thank you Mr chair I just want
to let you know I've been on a call for
a while I am alone I'm in my
car oh okay thank you very much chair
recognizes uh representative Bernardi
for a
question yes uh thank you Mr chairman
thank you Mr Fitzgerald uh I'm going to
go back to uh a question I asked one of
the the previous uh speakers is there
been an assessment of what the net
additional Electric Supply would need to
be if we adopted this program and move
to Electric uh Fleet and the second part
of that question given a need for
additional production and that that
production would likely be in the
evening because that's when cars are
being charged not during the day not
when solar is operating but at night
what what does that mean for net change
of
emissions um thank you I I will attempt
to answer that question to the best of
my ability I think also that's a
question perhaps for utilities um that
we have not conducted any particular
assessment I do believe there's an
ongoing conversation in New England and
other parts of the country in terms of
electric supply um ISO New England
certainly recognizes the growth in
electric vehicles um as Mr kwasnik I
believe it was uh mentioned um and um
although he did not state so I believe
Mr kwasnik used to be um a
representative of a a utility used to
work for a utility um one of new one of
New Hampshire's utilities um uh as he
stated there is um certainly there would
be some in increased demand um uh for uh
electricity there is also the
opportunity for electric vehicles to
store electricity and for that
electricity to be drawn upon at at
certain points of time um and I think
that that uh um uh as I say ISO New
England and uh and the utilities are all
studying those opportunities um I I
believe there may be some reports that
uh have been done or studies that uh and
if I can locate any of those I will
forward them on to the
committee thank you representative C
pittz is recognized for a question and
don't forget to
unmute I'd forget my head if it wasn't
attached uh Mr
Fitzgerald yes do you know or can you
tell me where New Hampshire stands right
now as far as emissions go among the 50
states are we in the M you know in the
middle are we on the most missions can
you tell us where we stand and I know
that's apples and oranges because of
populations but where do we stand AB
absolutely it is um you know it would be
impossible for us I think I guess um I I
don't have the information with me right
now but we I certainly could provide you
know where we stand on a per capita
basis um in and I assume you're talking
about emissions of greenhouse gases um
yes okay yeah yeah um I I could
certainly try to um follow up with some
information on a on a per capita basis
that might allow for
comparison and one of the thing may I
follow up yes you may follow
up one of the things that I'm
concerned about because
I is what
happens
to the revenue we now derive from
gasoline
tax if the a major switch is made even
in
2030 does anybody thought of that or
anybody worked that out Yes actually the
legislature has been looking that at
that for a number of years there have
been a number study commissions um uh
and actually um I believe representative
major has uh proposed legislation
several times over the past few years
which I believe he may have introduced
this year as well um that would
uh
um in that is intended to sort of
equalize the playing field to uh um
collect some type of fee from electric
vehicles um we've always looked at this
as um an equity issue and we've wanted
to make make certain that um that any
fee um that is based that is intended
for that purpose um is based on actual
mileage or emissions because um as you
well know there may there are certain um
internal combustion engine vehicles that
actually get better mileage than uh
certain types of electric vehicles the
the vehicles very widely um but we we
certainly um uh have always testified
and encouraged that there be Equitable
representation and that the road toll um
if that's New Hampshire's mechanism for
continuing to uh pay for infrastructure
uh for our for our roads and bridges and
so on um that that road toll is going to
be affected and whether we do this or
not there's going to be um growth in
electric vehicles over the next several
years as evidenced by the announcements
that the major vehicle manufacturers
that was referenced by representative MC
Williams um and that growth is going to
occur in New England New Hamp New
Hampshire and and all across the country
um so this is an issue that is is being
looked at nationally and certainly um uh
it hasn't had a major impact now because
of the relatively low number of vehicles
but though there certainly will be an
impact to to road toll that is based on
gasoline consumption
that that impact is occurring right now
because mileage is going up on almost
all vehicles and um so there certainly
is uh is a trend and an impact on Lower
gasoline usage whether it's electric
vehicles or other uh or or just more
efficient internal combustion vehicles I
hope that addresses your question thank
you thank you and uh seeing that we have
no further question questions for um Mr
Fitzgerald I'm going to close the public
hearing
on I'm sorry to interrupt um but we did
have Mr John Gage who did sign up after
the Sheets Were printed today he did
sign up to speak for two minutes and he
is on the
line okay uh I will call on Mr Gage and
I will hold him to two minutes and we
will not be uh entertaining any question
questions for Mr Gage so Mr Gage you are
on for two minutes and I'm starting my
uh uh stopwatch
so uh be careful thank you very much uh
I'd like to offer my support for HP 168
um I disagree with the statement that
sale dealers are selling what the
customers want from personal experience
I um was looking to buy a car two years
ago and
the I was looking for an electric
vehicle um but dealership after
dealership told me that they didn't have
uh the models that I've been reading
about online and it was because of the
what what this bill addresses um the
states all around us have um have rules
that are getting uh the the newest best
electric vehicles on their Lots in New
Hampshire doesn't and so um I think we
can change consumer Behavior by doing
two things um inform them you know
dealerships could talk about the cost
savings over the life time of the car of
an EV over an internal combustion engine
and by offering the best vehicles on the
Lots instead of customers having to know
that oh if they call Mass if they call a
dealership and ask you know to have a
car brought up from another state then
they can test drive it that's really not
how most people buy cars they they go to
a couple lots and they buy what's there
that meets their um you know
requirements the best um there's unmet
demand for EVS um my own case I was
looking for an EV and there were a
couple that I just couldn't get in the
state and I didn't feel like driving uh
to other states to to test
drive 30 seconds I would say I'd propose
that you we change how we fund um road
work use um miles driven and the weight
of vehicles instead of a gas tax because
gas cars are going away whether we help
consumers get informed and and choose
them early or it happens naturally over
time um and I'd also like to invite any
of the members of this committee to a
meeting um tomorrow morning or Wednesday
afternoon Wednesday evening I sent a
mail um to offer an explanation about
why carbon is such a scientifically
identified pollution um I believe
there's some members of the committee
that may not grasp the the full nature
of why our whole okay Mr Gage thank you
we appreciate your
testimony and with that we're going to
close the um hearing on uh House Bill
168 I will report that 53 people signed
in in support of the bill and 17 people
signed in in
opposition
um including
uh representative Jason
Osborne who signed in in opposition of
the um proposal and representative Josh
yella
um also
representative laa maputi signed in in
favor of it
and representative Raymond Howard signed
in opposed to the
bill are there
more oh we have more so uh
representative Don John um Don Johnson
signed in to oppose the bill
Representative Bob Green representative
Jonathan Smith representative Erica Leon
lean and uh representative Elaine Thomas
signed in in support of the
bill so that's the uh the blue sheet for
House Bill 168 and with that that
hearing public hearing is closed and now
we will uh resume or take out of recess
the public hearing on House Bill
289 which is a bill relative to
including electrical storage facilities
and the definition of energy
facility representative Michael
Harrington is the prime sponsor of that
bill representative Harrington like many
of us
uh had a regularly scheduled dentist
appointment today and has not returned
from that yet so he asked me to
introduce the
bill which I will do at this time this
bill is
basically did someone
speak point of see if I'm point of order
this is representative Fred PL is uh is
representative mner taking over the
clerk role I'm ready I'm G to
take yes representative mner will take
over the clerk role from this point
forward and thank you to representative
PL for doing it for the previous
Bill okay so to introduce uh house Bild
289 this is a uh bill that basically is
a housekeeping bill that
adds an electrical storage
facility to the definition of
uh energy facilities it adds a
electrical storage facility with a peak
storage capacity of 30 megawatts hours
or
greater uh to the existing statutory
definition of uh energy
facility uh it's been supported by
everyone who signed
up um on the blue sheet no one signed up
to speak for or against it um and since
representative Harrington is not here I
don't know if I'll be able to answer any
questions but I'll give it a shot
representative oxum is recognized for a
question uh thank you very much the
definition is in terms of megawatt hours
whereas other facilities in the um the
uh statute are in megaw
one is capacity uh one is usage and I
wonder if we we had problems with this
bill when it was brought up previously
and I wonder if this was not caught by
OS um I I I think we have a problem here
if it's 30 megawatt
hours in terms of megawatts it's a
quarter of that capacity other
facilities in this same statute are 30
Mega Watts I believe this should be 30
megawatts not 30 megawatt hours what
what what you're establishing here would
be a limit of
7.5
megawatts that's a good point and uh I
wish representative Harrington was here
to address it but since he is not uh
we'll have to hold that question for
later representative pel is recognized
for a
question thank you Mr chairman I I went
online looking to see if I could bring
up a picture of a 30 megaw
hour um uh storage facility um and to to
Le Point to represent an ox
oxam point they were usually rated in
megawatts but still I wasn't able to see
anything on size and I guess my question
is because this kind of legislation
makes sense but I I don't know how big
of a facility we are I mean if it's
something as big as uh my car for
instance or even uh a semitruck I'm not
I I question whether or not we need it
but if this is a big
facility uh it makes sense so size is
important if I could get that kind of an
idea thank you okay thank you I um I
just recalled that the RSA that's being
modified here is RSA 162 which is the uh
statute that governs the site evaluation
committee so what this um bill is
actually modifying is the definition of
a facility that would require site
evaluation committee uh jurisdiction uh
if you read the the section H that
follows section g it talks about how a
facility like this uh can
be taken on by the site evaluation
committee so I think that is a a clear
an important distinction about this bill
uh it it it specifically app applies to
the site evaluation committee uh
representative uh
did you have a followup yeah I I I I
understand what the bill is about and
and my followup is whether or not it
should
be uh in a go to a site evaluation
committee if it's really not you
know that honorous of of a I don't know
how big it is you know what are we
talking about for size I I I can
understand a site of value valuation
committee for a a a wind turbine which
takes up a lot of area and I guess so
that's really the question and I think
knowing the size will give me an idea of
how I want to vote on
this okay without so the issue here so
the issue here is if a ail if a a
facility is 30 megawatts or greater it
automatically goes to the site of
evaluation committee if it's 30 megawatt
or less or under 30 megawatt it can go
to the site evaluation committee only by
petition uh of
the I think it's the persons who are uh
in charge of determining whether the
facility should be allowed to be built
or not uh like a planning board or a
zoning board so
some towns don't feel they have the
expertise to deal with facilities like a
u like an in electrical energy storage
facility uh facilities um so they want
the site evaluation committee to take
that over and this legislation will
permit the site evaluation committee to
do that for electrical storage
facilities uh of 30 megawatt hours or
greater so that's the essence of the now
I'm remembering my discussion with
Michael Harrington about this so that's
the essence of the U of the
situation uh representative PL is
recognized for a
question um I was just let's see if I'm
unmuted I am um I just wanted to with
respect to uh represent representative
uh Celly pittz concern I think it was
Cali Pitts about the May what hours
versus megawatts you can discharge this
in one hour than it's 30
megawatts okay uh thank you
representative ssuch you're recognized
for a
question uh thank you Mr chairman uh I
actually uh had actually before you ask
your question I apologize for
interrupting I have to leave um so I'm
not sure who you can direct your
question to I have to step out of the
room for a half hour or so I have
another meeting that I have to conduct
I'm going to turn the meeting over to
representative Thomas and um I won't be
here to answer questions but maybe
somebody else on the committee can so
representative Thomas take over
please okay uh not being familiar uh
with talking with represent Harrington
on this bill I have no further knowledge
on any other questions but you can ask
your questions and if anybody here in
the room can answer that'd be fine uh so
let's proceed okay uh thank you Mr
chairman uh actually I'm following up on
what represent plat just mentioned so I
think we got to be clear about this 30
megawatts is used to identify a energy
generator 30 megawatt hours is an energy
storage device meaning like he said if
you didn't discharge 30 megawatt of
energy within an hour that battery had
30 megawatt hours of storage so they
have to include ours we can't just say
30 megaw that's generation capacity
that's not a storage battery so I think
that is a difference and I think last
year we had a bill that just said 30
megawatt hours with 30 megawatts without
the hours and that is not a
battery bill
says could could I answer that a what I
see here now is I see um I'm not quite
sure who was next but I see repres Kelly
Pit's hands raised for a
question is there anybody in the room uh
from a
utility because these storage facilities
get bigger and bigger and bigger and I'm
I I'm not sure
what representative Harrington had in
mind or of the size this isn't a home
storage
facility it we're talking about large
large
facilities that would come under I
believe SEC control or SSC SEC
permitting so I'm not sure and I I just
wondered everybody's questions could we
postpone that until we actually find out
what representative Harrington was
intending uh thank you representative I
will note I I see that um Donna gamos M
source is on a participant line if she
would care to comment at all on this uh
uh m kamash would you care to comment at
all or uh
refrain hear me this is Donna yes um I I
we don't really have a position on this
bill but um we were taking a look at it
you know our lawyers and they they saw
that you know this clearly is for larger
storage and all we could figure was that
potentially um a community was asking
that somebody else you know take over
the review um we we aren't we aren't
we're still trying to get um smaller
versions through the Public Utilities
Commission so it's not anything that um
you know we would have a concern with
and even if um the SEC took jurisdiction
over that it would just be one other um
layer of approvals which we typically
are used to so um I we're I think that
to everybody's point before us that the
sole purpose of this is to make sure
that if a community doesn't know how to
act on it they want the SEC to do so but
we don't have an actual position on that
we'd have to leave that to the
communities and to you I don't I I know
that was rather vague I hope that was
helpful thank you
m representative Thomas I apologize for
interrupting I just wanted to let you
know that Mr James manahan is on the
line and he did request to testify I'm
not sure if he can speak to this point
necessarily but his hand is raised if
you'd like to recognize him I would like
to follow up yeah yes I'll give a follow
up to representative uh Cy pittz I did
see Mr Monahan's hands raised and I had
the same question you did but I'll go to
represent Cali pits first go
ahead Donna do you have any idea what
the size of a seven megawatt hour
facility would
be or what a 30 megawatt hour would be I
would need somebody to do the math for
me so I'm sorry probably representative
plet would be spoton because he's done
this so much I'm not the expert there
I'm sorry I mean I could have been if I
had thought about if I if I knew I was
gonna get the question I would have been
the expert no I'm kidding what you get
for showing up thank you right Mr chair
I actually have some specifications here
for energy representa you have any
recognized yet to to speak um if you
have I was asking Mr chair I'm asking to
go out of turn because I actually have
some
specifications that would be
useful uh be brief like a few seconds
please sure um for transmission uh
purposes energy storage is often in the
10 megawatt range range for distribution
energy storage is often in the 2
megawatt range it's generally these
batteries discharge for a period of four
hours so the difference between your
megawatt and your megawatt hours is a
factor of four batteries are usually
listed with both they specify the
megawatts and the megawatt hours um I I
think that's probably sufficient for our
purposes thank you so much I'm going to
go to Mr Monahan now because he has been
waiting for a while Mr pan uh if you uh
you're on to
testify great um thank you um so I I um
I think both representatives samitz and
oxen him have address the issue of
whether or not it should be Mega or
megga hours based upon the discharge uh
and let me just start off by saying Jim
an actually supporting the bill on
behalf of the New England power
generators Association
Granite Shore power and revision energy
um and answer the question with regard
to the size um I do believe a 30
megawatt our facility would be sizable
it wouldn't be in your garage for
example I think you could probably look
at it like it's um a a substation that
you might be familiar with on the side
of the road or back of a parking lot um
and obviously the bigger they get um the
larger the substation comparison would
be um part of the reason for our supp of
the bill is twofold first as the
committee has addressed that uh some
communities may be in a position where
they would prefer to have the S
evaluation committee take over what is
essentially a bulk energy facility uh
and the other piece of it is um while we
haven't seen any utility scale storage
come to New Hampshire yet we anticipate
that it will and believe that the option
for developers to use the site
evaluation process is uh predictable uh
um and something that would be built
into the soft cost of developing a
project like this um so we just start
looking about um how we want to make
sure that the capital flows to New
Hampshire for these projects that
predictability and the control of the
soft costes uh is important it just
seems logical to us as well when the
side evaluation um statute
was and updated uh the concept of
utility scale storage was really not
something that was part of the indust
it is now and we think it's uh
reasonable to uh amend the S of
valuation statute but I can answer on
I'll do my best to answer answer any of
the questions youall might
have thank you Mr Moran I see your
representative man has his hand raised
for a while uh representative man do you
have a question uh well I was just GNA
ask whether um whether we need to go
much further it does seem like it's a so
you know it could Poss possibly be a
dangerous object if it can
discharge
um what do I call it um you know a
million or so watts in a short period of
time somebody running a car into it or
something like that by accident and so I
and it's I don't think it's a huge huge
battery it starts small when we can
always change the
specification if if this is this battery
is smaller than we really really need to
worry about um so why don't we just go
ahead with it and Let It Go um the only
um you know the
only reason not to uh pass the bill was
it would be that U uh that it may be
much smaller batteries would also be
dangerous but I don't believe that's the
case I'm thinking of uh 60 watts for 500
hours is equivalent to that so it's a 60
watt bulb for 500
hours you
know
okay thank you uh represent man I see a
a rather shaded pale yellow hand for
representative McGee does that mean your
question is uh uh not as strong as the
others or how come yours is faded and
the others haven't been whatever it is
you're next you're next to have a
question anyway yes thank you Mr Vice
chair uh and thank you for the question
about the color of my hand um you can
actually pick different colors and my
daughter made fun of me because my hand
was was bright orange or some other
color and so I I picked a different
color um so that's that uh I do have a
question for Mr Monahan because I think
he might be able to answer it when we
were going through reviews of the bill I
know a question came up that I jotted
down in pencil because I often make
notes on the bills because I can't
remember everything and the question was
how would uh this added storage
component uh in the uh definitions of
facilities how would it affect uh Power
purchase agreements if at all is there
anything we should understand about how
a power purchase agreement might be
involved or affected by our um adding
the storage facilities here yeah I don't
think that that's uh would be applicable
uh to any amendments to the side
evaluation uh statute when you get into
the issue of uh PPA for power discharge
and whether or not you're going toas
that and if it's a wholesale or retail
um activity that discharging that really
falls into any sort of amendment to the
restructuring act which I think is
374f so I don't think I think this
change here uh would be in would be
indifferent to the types of questions
you're asking okay thank
you okay thank you uh representative C
pittz do you have an urgent question we
need to close this yeah what about
forward capacity payments go
ahead yeah again I think it's
indifferent to that uh other provisions
of state and federal War would detail
whether or not the discharge of a large
battery into the wholesale Market would
qualify for for capacity payment uh it's
a great question I'll try to find out
the answer for that this is a good week
to ask because the uh the auction is
taking place over today the next couple
of days but
I thank you it's currently being
discussed at the Pu I
know okay thank you very much uh with
that we'll close this uh public hearing
I will report that we had PE seven
people sign in supporting the bill zero
people signed in to oppose it two of
those people were were um elected
officials including Elaine
Thomas representative Elaine Thomas and
representative Latha maputi so with that
HB 289 is closed
and yes representative oxam you're
recognized for a question could we make
sure that the issue was brought to the
attention of the sponsor that he might
want to amend this to make it megawatts
and specify megawatt hours the typical
battery
formulation absolutely we will have that
discussion with representative
Harrington with that we will recess uh
until 1:00 enjoy your
lunch thank
you
for
[Applause]
um our public hearings It's One o'clock
And at one o'clock we have a public
hearing scheduled on HB
308 so I will call that public hearing
to
order this uh bill is about is relative
to broadband access to poll
attachments and the prime sponsor of
this bill is representative Marsh
representative Bill Marsh
from Brookfield representative Marsh is
uh present and representative Marsh I
will uh now give
you boy I wish this thing would ah he's
he's already been given permission okay
representative Marsh you have the
floor thank you Mr chairman and and
thank you science committee it's a
pleasure coming before you today uh I
will be very brief for the record I'm
representative William Marsh Carol
County 8 representing seven towns in
southern Carol County I am pleased today
to offer for your consideration House
Bill 308 relative to broadband access to
pole attachments which I found at the
request of the selectman of the town of
Brookfield the issue in Brookfield is
most of the polls are old enough that
they need to be replaced to allow poll
attachments the ex the existing polls
are not to enough per standards adopted
in the
1990s the electric company has been
pushing for the cable people to pay the
full cost of replacing the poles before
allowing cable to be attached the
Brookfield Selectmen feel this is
unreasonable apparently this is the case
in other towns as well I contacted
Christa Sho the consumer advocate of the
Pu she said that the electric company
receives money in their rates to pay for
the periodic replacement of poles she
gave me the language here the suggestion
is to Value the existing polls at their
depreciated cost so the cable people pay
that amount and the pole owner pays the
remainder which they should have already
seen offset in electric rates over the
years the Selectmen of Brookfield tell
me that if the replacement cost for the
polls in Brookfield is the depreciated
value which is of course less than the
full replacement cost then the cable
company Spectrum says they will run
Broadband in Brookfield as the density
is sufficient for them to recover their
costs I thank you and I'll be glad to
take
questions thank you representative Marsh
uh representative Thomas is recognized
for a
question thank you Mr chair thank you uh
representative for taking my question um
just to be clear does the when you when
you refer to the replacement cost of the
polls do you also mean the replacement
cost of the polls plus the costs
associated with transferring the um the
other equipment from the old Pole to the
new pole as
well uh I believe that to be the case
but Christina sh I believe is also
signed up to testify and is far better
qualified than I to answer that question
thank okay representative PL is
recognized for a question
yes thank you uh Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question
representative Marsh I'm going to use a
an example numbers let's say a new poll
costs a thousand bucks and uh it's
written off over 30 years uh so uh in
year 30 it's zero let's say year 29
there uh small amount of money left are
you saying that the the uh cable company
will only pay a portion of that small
amount of money left after 29 years and
the utility has to put in the brand new
poll at ,000 and therefore that thousand
that thousand minus the small
contribution winds up on rate payers
rates uh as as an undepreciated
poll uh representative it's a pleasure
seeing you again and I'm glad that
you're well and before us today my my
understanding is that the electric
company has already received in its
electric rates over the years the
majority of the cost of a poll that old
and therefore for them to be paying uh
the cost of a poll that would then
presumably last for the foreseeable
lifetime of that telephone poll and for
which they would continue to receive a
reimbursement in their electrical rates
is entirely
reasonable thank you are there any
further questions for representative
Marsh uh representative McGee you're
recognized for a question thank you Mr
chairman and thank you representative
Marsh my question is what necessitates a
replacement condition so I guess what
I'm trying to get at is what is the
scale of the operation if we do
Implement a bill that says we're going
to start uh allowing supporting or uh
enforcing replacement of polls which
which polls get replaced it's obviously
not just
Brookfield well clearly there's no
reason to replace the polls uh for toer
polls to allow pole attachments unless
somebody is wanting to attach something
to those poles so I believe this is
something that the cable company
electric company would work out amongst
themselves as they knew now just the
issue now is that there's a question how
to divide the costs okay thank
you uh representative oxenham is Rec
recognized for a
question yes um has the select board
determined that working with the cable
companies is the ideal solution it seems
that around the state uh fiber optic is
being seen as a Superior Solution to
providing universal access to um
Broadband uh that is my understanding
but it's also my understanding that a
member of the board of Selectmen will be
here to testify before you so you would
be better to ask them that directly
thank
you uh thank you uh the chair recognizes
representative Pim Andel for a
question thank you Mr chairman and thank
you representative Marsh um from what I
under do I have this corrected there are
some
normally a Broadband would just attach
poll
their wires to an existing pole but
there's some reason why
they polls are somehow
inadequate uh yes you are correct about
that what happened was back in the 90s
they raised the height requirements for
polls to allow a sufficient margin for
safety to allow for more attachments uh
such as cable and and uh telephones and
various other things that attach to to
poles the existing poles in our town it
is my understanding our grandfather they
don't need to be replaced now unless
somebody chooses to attach something to
them which is what the town wants
because they went Broadband for some
rather important
reasons
followup
followup uh thank you Mr chairman just
what is what is the LIF span of uh
pole you know are you asking me that
question my my understanding from
Christa Sho is that the lifespan May
approximate 40 years but she again has I
believe signed up to testify and can
better answer that question thank
you thank you uh miss Sho is indeed uh
signed up to testify and will testify
shortly uh representative parshall
you're recognized for a question thank
you Mr chair uh good morning or good
afternoon uh representative Marsh full
appreciation
is taken already on some of these polls
won't the cable provider have to take up
the pretty much the full amount of
replacing that
poll uh my understanding is once a poll
is fully depreciated it no longer would
carry value in the books of the electric
company having been fully paid for and
therefore a replacement poll would
become the responsibility of the
electric company of of of the electric
company thank
you thank
you uh any further questions for
representative
Marsh seeing none I will uh call on the
next person to
testify if I can get my sheet
back uh the next person to testify is
Richard zacher an elected official in
the town of Brookfield so
Mr zacher
um apparently he is not online yet is
that
correct no I I I see him oh there he is
okay Mr zacher you're recognized to
speak okay thank you can you hear me yes
we can hi I'm rich zacker a selectman
from the town of Brookfield Brookfield
is a small town of 700 residents in
southern Carol County the town has about
300 homes a 100 of which do not have
internet service we've been working very
hard to bring service into this area and
we finally received an estimate from our
internet provider to service the homes
which do not currently have the internet
most of these homes are within a Four
Mile stretch of roads that comes to
about 25 homes per mile which is more
than adequate for them to make some
money
it would seem to
me when we received the estimate to
provide service to these homes it was
$700,000 or about $7,000 per home we saw
that the cares act funding was provided
to suppliers who could deploy internet
coverage at less than $3,000 per
home we couldn't understand why it was
so much more for the town of Brookfield
the vendor told us the polls were not
sufficient to handle additional service
attachments and had to be replaced at an
estimated cost of $5,000
each many of the polls in this town are
well over 50 years old and in my opinion
are fully depreciated the Pu guidance
received from the state legislature is
that the
requestor pays the full replacement cost
therefore we feel it's unlikely that
Brookfield and many other small rural
communities will ever get high-speed
internet fully deployed we discussed
this dilemma with representative Dr
Marsh and he offered to submit this
legislation to address the issue with
that as background I urge you to support
the bill and change the way the
requesters have to pay for making
utility polls ready for highspeed
internet and there was a question
earlier about fivr and yes we reached
out to Consolidated
Communications and they gave us a quote
of $1.2
million and we had to funded
completely okay does that conclude your
testimony then yes it
does okay thank you do we have any
questions for Mr
zacher anybody in the room have any
questions uh representative oh okay I
guess we don't have any questions
representative plet you have a
question don't forget to
unmute just earlier testimony I've had
spent many years at Public Service New
Hampshire uh for uh transmission polls
are over 40-year life distribution polls
are more like 30 that's
all okay thank you uh seeing no
additional questions for Mr zacher we
will move on to our next presenter who
will be Christa Sho who works for the
Office of the consumer Advocate and
she's uh representing herself I guess
not the consumer advocate's office um
anyway miss Sho you
are uh on to testify go ahead please
thank you chairman V and committee
members um we did submit the testimony
on behalf of the office of the consumer
Advocate um to support the bill
fundamentally um because uh we see
Broadband as a necessity um for economic
health education safety and social needs
um and as a representative of
residential ratee pairs
um we think it's also important to weigh
in from that perspective in
that there is a um
socialization of utility pole
Replacements um that happens throughout
the industry um and there are a number
of reasons that that Poles get uh
replaced um and there are areas where
poles don't get replaced and in those
circumstances where the polls have been
fully depreciated because they're um
many years
old um it is uh
reasonable uh for those pole
Replacements uh to be um paid for um by
the utility and and therefore that um
winds up also being paid for by the rate
pairs
um the way that the commission uh rules
work is essentially that the attaching
entity is required to pay all of the
Make Ready costs
The Proposal before you is to allocate
the cost to the attaching entity for any
of the remaining life of the pole the
pole
life um you know depreciation inside of
a utility is a is not a it's a
complicated issue so it's you know every
poll in and of itself by itself has a
different pole life but there is an
average um pole life that is considered
and it's and it's part of a depreciation
study so if a depreciation study
indicates that the pole life for utility
is 40 years or 30 years um to uh one of
your committing members points I think
rep representative PL um then uh that
effectively becomes the the life of that
poll and uh can be used as a way to
create a rule that is you know
relatively um should be relatively
simple to to to implement
um so uh with that I would I I welcome
your questions and I I think that we
already have a three lined up so
um if you don't mind I would just ask um
I'll address one of them uh the question
one of the questions was whether or
not the cost of
moving um everything uh from one pole to
the other would also uh be
included and I agree with representative
Marsh that that would be appropriate if
the pole had been replaced after its um
generally accepted uh useful life then
the utility would have um moved the
lines from the old Pole to the new pole
um so it seems that sharing a
proportional amount of that cost uh
would also be
reasonable
um and I will leave it to questions uh
because I I'm not sure that I actually
have the other one written down thank
you okay thank you very much chair
recognizes representative Thomas for a
question thank you Mr chairman thank you
uh for taking my question um my
understanding is that uh not all of the
utility pills are owned by the same
entity for instance uh some could be
owned by an electric company some could
be owned by perhaps a telephone company
um and I'm not sure if some could be
owned by the cable company that I'm not
really sure but my my question is this
um
if we if we were to assume that you had
the same customer was taking Broadband
cable and they're paying their electric
bill and perhaps even have a phone bill
um that the costs that were now being
you know shifted from one to the other
really uh that customer is going to pay
the increased rates in the smaller
proportion spread out amongst those
three companies because if they're
paying for cable they'll pay for some of
if they're paying for the electric bill
they'll be paying for some of that and
for people that may not be buying cable
they they they won't share in that cost
so either way the cost is not being
decreased it's just being spread out you
know spread around the various
individual bills that customers May pay
if they're buying all of those Services
is that is is is that a correct
understanding I think that if you look
at it um Statewide that is correct um
the the issue in the most rural parts of
the state is that the when the costs are
so prohibitively high to um gain access
to the pole generally because the old
polls are very short and therefore
there's no um room available uh for the
new fiber line or the new cable line to
be attached because generally what would
what would happen is there might be some
shifting of the lines so that there
could be um space made available um so I
guess as a general um matter the answer
to your question is is yes um as a as a
practical matter without doing something
like this um many of the folks in towns
like that uh don't have access uh to
broadband because there's no uh
economical viable way for such a few
number of residents to um pay the high
cost of replacing the poles that would
facilitate the height that is needed to
put in the required uh
cables thank
you uh the chair recognizes
representative pintel for a
question uh thank you Mr chairman uh
Miss sh hopefully this is something you
can answer um the the the fee that
basically goes on our electric bill
which essentially pays for the upkeep of
the poles and that sort of thing does
that get reduced after the uh poll is
totally
amortized or do we still continue to pay
that
fee
it's a complicated question um that's
sort of part of the a depreciation study
is generally done as part of a rate
case um and that uh depreciation study
um is part of what
identifies the revenue requirement um
and the revenue requirement for the
utility is what helps establish uh the
rates um I don't really have a clearer
answer than that um but I believe that
there is a utility representative
available um that may be able to give
you a clearer or better answer okay I'll
save my question for them then thank
you thank you
um seeing no further questions from uh
committee members I'll call on our next
presenter who is Mark Dean representing
the New Hampshire Electric Co-op so Mr
Dean you're on thank you and uh good
afternoon I have submitted written
testimony so I'll try to just make a few
quick points here uh so the so the co-op
sees this from two perspectives the
co-op owns a lot of polls and the co-op
has to attach to
other polls that are owned by Third
parties and the rule not only in New
Hampshire but uh for all the the states
that are regulated by the FCC for pole
attachments is I think as it has been
described which is if there's a reason
say the the poll is old and it uh Pat
fails the a stress test that is taken
and the the utility the pole owner has
to replace it then the pole owner
replaces that and they'll have to
replace it at a higher height make more
room if there's no other reason to
replace it uh except for a new attacher
coming in said we'd like to add an
attachment and that the only way to do
that is to have a taller pole than the
FCC Rule and the state of New Hampshire
rule is then the attacher the cost
causer pays for that pole replacement
and uh so as I say the co-op sees it
from both sides because sometimes it's
going to be pay because it's a pole
owner and sometimes it's going to be pay
because it's a pole attacher we think
the co the cost
causation uh rule works and is fair I
think a couple of quick points a lot of
you um have been through the uh property
tax for utility legislation that took a
few years to get through and I think if
those who heard the testimony might
remember there really is no such thing
as a fully depreciated poll with the the
poll owners are paying property taxes on
those polls if uh some of them are 60
years old and still if they if they're
structurally sound we keep them in place
because the idea is to provide the
service uh that is safe and reliable and
cost effective and uh if you don't need
to replace it you don't replace it um so
just a a reminder in that sense so from
the the co-ops perspective the cost
causation approach which is what the FCC
still has what the rules uh here have uh
we think is a reasonable approach and we
think a better approach is to look at uh
Senate bills 88 uh part two of that
which is that's another bill that
Senator Bradley is on that's the
OneTouch Make Ready Bill and that's a
bill that actually produces Savings in
costs so that the actual process of
doing poll attachments
uh is more cost effective instead of
just allocating costs differently among
different parties uh so while we're the
co-op itself is working hard to expand
Broadband in the state of New Hampshire
uh that's the type of effort that we
would endorse as opposed to just
shifting some of those costs to uh
whether it's the electric company or
whoever else owns the
poll and that's what I have for uh oral
testimony
okay thank you Mr Dean I have a question
for
you you mentioned the fact that towns
tax
polls if a poll gets replaced does the
tax on that poll typically go
up it's a little more complicated
because of the changes in the the
statute used to be every town basically
tax a poll at whatever value they
assigned to it now it's an average um
but if you replace polls more frequently
the average age of your poll is now
younger it's less depreciated because
they do depreciate so property the
overall property tax value that the
utility is paying would go up I think is
the the long and the
short so as a follow-up question if this
bill were to pass would that be an
incentive for towns to try to get polls
replaced so they could collect more tax
money on
them I can't say whether it it would or
wouldn't under the under the reformed or
revised utility property tax you know
there would be some difference I don't
know that it would be the kind of thing
that would be a motivating factor can't
say
okay thank you uh representative Cali
pittz is recognized for a
question don't forget to unmute yeah uh
question is on the uh who pays for the
pole attachment itself not for for a new
poll but for moving wires perhaps and
rearranging things if an attachment has
to be made
again the general rule is that if let's
say in this case you didn't even need to
replace the pole but the attachments had
to be rearranged to create the proper
spacing then it would be the
entity if there was no other reason to
do that than it was whoever the last
entity was that came and said we'd like
to add an additional attachment again if
that's the sole reason you're T
undertaking the activity then that
entity pays those costs
may I follow up follow up we had uh a
discussion about multiple polls in one
area so if a company
decides I don't need to add you know
take down my old poll could they add a
second poll and could that create a
problem it's very hard for me to
Envision the situation you're
describing I guess if you're
saying adding I mean usually what we try
to avoid at all cost in this state right
is Two Poles six inches from each other
and creating a a wall of Po so as a
general principle what you want to do is
you're only going to have you minimize
the number of polls you require so it's
hard for me to
picture
um that that would be allowed to
essentially just insert a number of
poles in between the existing poles and
that would probably be no more cost
effective than the current
system if I've understood correctly well
apparently in this this particular air
in this particular double pole we have
had a problem with double poles in
certain areas so that's just one of the
things I was thinking about thank
you thank you representative pintel is
recognized for a
question uh thank you Mr chairman
essentially the same question I asked
Miss sh
um do the electric companies base the
the the fee or that they charge their
customers based on the
um the the amortized lifespan of the
polls or the actual
ual costs that the electric companies
are are having to replace poles some of
them being 50 years old as an
example so um I'll be a good witness in
one way and in a bad and in another way
here and the so the co-op isn't rate
regulated by the puc so there will be
some subtle differences but I I
hopefully this answers the question
correctly um
so for example the the co-op when it's
setting its rates it has to look at what
its ongoing costs are and that includes
depreciation and maintenance and the
taxes all all of those things anything
that increases that number is going to
have an upward pressure all other things
being equal on rates so if you think
about um if if we were putting in if we
were turning over polls placing polls
every 5 years instead of every 35 years
uh you know in that extreme example you
would really see a very big cost
difference because you're constantly
putting in new polls it's not the most
economically efficient way to do it it's
like holding on to a car that you've
paid the you know made the payments on
uh or getting a new car every two years
I think you know which one's more
expensive so uh I think accelera pole
Replacements would have an upward
pressure on rates generally speaking and
for a regulated utility I assume that
would mean because of the depreciation
they would have a greater a higher rate
base that's what their revenue
requirements are based
upon uh followup question
followup just because I'm I'm having a
difficulty grasping this so
uh even if a poll has already reached
its uh its
uh estimated lifespan say it's 30 years
um if if it
is replaced at that time as opposed to
replaced 10 years later it will make a
difference
in what you're going to charge your
customers
I I guess I'm not talking about pole
let's say you had to replace all your
poles at 30 years even though they're
totally amortized or 40 years that would
make a
difference it would it would if you
you're if
you're I call it turning over if you're
turning over the stock of your polls
then you're going to start the if you're
in a rate making situation you're going
to have higher rate base because you're
going to there won't be fully
depreciated and again they're never
actually fully
depreciated uh and uh so that is going
to be there'll be an increase in overall
costs and that will cause an increase in
in rates okay thank
you thank you any further questions for
Mr Dean seeing none I'll thank Mr Dean
for his testimony and move on to our
next presenter thank you who is Chris
hodgon representing Comcast Mr hodon the
floor is
yours good afternoon may I
continue you may thank you good
afternoon chairman Vose members of the
committee my name is Chris hodon I'm
Comcast vice president of the government
Affairs here in New Hampshire and we
serve approximately 350 ,000 Broadband
customers uh throughout the 107
communities uh that we serve here in the
state and while we have concerns with
the way the legislation is written I
want to both recognize and applaud the
sponsors uh interest and just recognize
that that we do support uh policies
which reduce the barriers to broadband
deployment and we further agree that
this issue of pole replacement in rural
areas is a a worthy issue and one that
uh needs to be addressed um we we've
long advocated for both here at the
legislature and at the Pu policies that
do reduce the cost and and other
barriers to deployment and most recently
our trade Association at the FCC
advocated for um policies that uh very
are very similar to the intent of this
legislation which is that in areas where
there are not
Broadband it's unjust and unreasonable
for pole owners to shift all pole
replacement cost onto new
attachers uh which would be as other
parties have said the cable companies
companies like
Comcast utility polls truly are
indispensable to the deployment of
broadband their choke points through
which all communication infrastructure
and all communication Services must
travel one point or
another and uh as has previously been
noted these assets are owned either
jointly or solely by Electric utilities
and telephone
utilities who are uh either rate
regulated or in many cases are
competitors to the companies who wish to
access the polls so as a result of that
the uh these assets are are heavily
regulated uh both at the FCC and in
States like New Hampshire who have
certified that they will regulate them
at the state level and that regulated
um interest extends to both the rates
that are paid the terms and the
conditions of access to those
polls and because of their regulated
nature policy changes really implicate a
a complex range of issues from safety
and reliability to the rates customers
pay and uh detachers pay through rent
use of the RightWay and and also the
efficiency and economics of broadband
deployment so it's it really is truly a
complex issue with a lot of interwoven
interests and uh impacts on how we all
um run our networks and deploy our
services in the state and our concerns
with the bill although the bill is brief
I really come down to to two things one
is that we we're worried that the bill
is overly Broad and vague in some of the
terminology that it
uses uh the use of terms like areas uh
Make Ready which is not otherwise used
in the Hampshire statute the use of a
100 by 100 megabit standard uh all um
create we we believe some ambiguity and
vagueness in the Statue which we fear
will lead to unintended consequences uh
in
particular uh as has been described by a
couple of the folks who testified there
are two types of pole Replacements that
typically occur when a Broadband
provider needs to access polls the first
being a situation when the poll is not
adequate to accommodate the additional
attachment it needs to be taller as Mr
Dean said and in that instance the cost
is borne by the company who wants to
access the polls currently in New
Hampshire the second type of pole
replacement which occurs when the pole
is out of compliance either for safety
purposes reliability or damage to the
pole that cost is borne by the pole
owner and not by the company wishing to
access the polls and our concern is that
in the language of the bill is
written because the term Make Ready is
used to Encompass all pole
replacements that last type of pole
replacement which is currently not uh
whose costs are not currently born by a
new attacher will now through a pra
formula uh be borne in part by a
Broadband
provider uh we think that that'll have
the unintended consequence of increasing
the cost of this type of pole
replacement for a Broadband provider
currently doesn't pay for that cost now
it might actually uh create additional
disincentives for Royal Broadband
deployment and not achieve the goals of
the bill sponsor which is to make it
less expensive and accelerate that
deployment so so our hope is that if the
committee chooses to have a subcommittee
or engage in a process to bring the
stakeholders together that we have an
opportunity to participate in that um
and I'd be happy to answer any questions
that the committee may
have
thank you uh representative Thomas is
recognized for a
question thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question Mr hushon um
first I want to clarify something I just
heard you say uh did I hear you say
correctly that the current costs of um
moving other equipment and wires from
the old Pole to the new pole was
currently not being born by the uh cable
providers when they want to put in new
BR B was that what you were saying uh no
uh representative what I was saying is
that in an instance where the poll is in
need of replacement for safety purposes
it's out of compliance with uh
applicable standards the pole
replacement is borne by the pole owner
um
when a pole attacher needs to move its
equipment to accommodate another
provider uh whether
when um the pole is needs to be
replaced um because it's lacking in
sufficient height uh those costs aren't
treated the the same
way follow follow up thank you m um so
my question then is is it your
experience
that is is it the
cost of the pole replacement issue
that is the primary and sometimes the
sole reason why Broadband is not being
put into the rural area or are there
other reasons why you you do not put
broader band into any rural areas
besides the cost of pole
replacement uh thank you representative
so the uh
economic considerations when deploying
Broadband are complex there's no single
reason uh that
uh a project may or may not be
feasible it is certainly true and as the
sponsor noted um and what this
legislation seeks to address is that
pole replacement costs are a part of
that equation and they can be
substantial okay thank you the chair now
recognizes representative Lang for a
question thank you Mr chair it's
actually a question
chair talking at
all sorry I think I
lost Mr chair are we gonna have anybody
from pu speaking at
all nobody from the puc is here I don't
believe I'll ask this gentlemen my
question so my question is who defines
the rules about the wire placement on a
given
poll is that for Mr hon yeah thank you
yeah so um how attachers uh either
attach to or maintain their attachment
to the poll is is found in the 1300
rules of the puc uh those rules um rely
heavily on the National Electric Code uh
for issues of safety and uh as an
industry we look to those standards when
we um either are attaching or
maintaining our attachments to the polls
as a a matter of
tradition uh the lowest attacher on the
poll is the telephone utility uh and
then as you move up the poll you find uh
other Broadband other Communications
providers Broadband providers uh and
then uh
Municipal attachments fire alarm those
sorts of uh attachments and then at the
very typically at the very top uh what
is known as the electric Space Electric
utilities follow up Mr chair yes
followup
please so my my followup question is do
you know if there's any talk at pu about
creating some sort of waiver process to
as long as they can show that whatever
kind of attachment is still safe that
that they would allow uh Broadband
connections again you know we've learned
a lot from the current state of affairs
right now and and the dramatic need for
Broadband so I'm wondering if pu is
creating any kind of waiver requirements
for that if someone could put together a
poll plan that would work especially if
the polls say G to be replaced over the
next 15 years and then they can meet
compliance but those Gap areas where the
poll's not quite old enough to replace
you know for any good reason is there
any kind of conversation happening
around that at the
Pu I don't think I'm the right um person
to answer what what sort of conversation
is going on puc we're not actively
participating one I I would say that the
U the current 1300
rules uh
do
contemplate uh what s what in what
circumstances a poll owner can deny
access to a poll one of them is say
safety and and it all those rules
further um articulate when a poll owner
cannot deny access to an a Broadband
company or another entity that wants to
attach the polls
so you you may referral to those 1300
rules may be appropriate to to answer
the question of that you
asked okay thank you the chair next
recognizes representative Cali pittz for
a question I I
I I think representative oxenham was far
before
me but I'll ask my question Chris uh
when uh a Broadband
company puts up or
replaces and puts up fiber perhaps do
they take down the other
attachments the other wire that other
words
copper so I think that scenario is
probably more appropriately directed to
a company that has utilized that that
copper based technology before I I'll
say that when we um when it is necessary
for us to add infrastructure to our
existing network uh we typically add
that infrastructure by
overlash uh that new infrastructure
whether it be fiber optic cabling or
coaxial cabling to our existing
attachments could may I ask for
clarification yes go ahead could you
explain what lashing is oh sure I
apologize um so over lashing is uh when
um a a company needs to uh secure if you
will infrastructure to the carrying
cable that is attached to to the utility
pole and that uh attachment that over
lashing is accomplished by uh the use of
a wire which is wrapped uh around that
carrying cable and potentially other
wires that are already there so as to
secure them to the uh both the
attachment on the pole and the carrying
cable that supports the uh the
infrastructure Mr chair may I ask a
second
question okay go ahead what is can you
now
share room on fiber with other
companies for a
fee uh
so can companies do it by rule of
Regulation yes absolutely uh it's
relatively uh common for uh companies
that own fiber optic cabling to lease uh
access to uh to
infrastructure thank
you the chair recognizes representative
oxum for a
question yes I'm wondering if there's
been uh do we still have representative
Marsh
available there you are my my question
is whether you're um aware that we have
a Broadband study committee bill before
this committee and I'm wondering if it
would be useful to either roll these two
together or to at least when we have a
this is as a question for the chair
whether it's appropriate to ask that
they be uh considered when we consider
the bills at least consider these two
bills together because they certainly
inter intermerge and I think the
complexities of the discussion have have
been revealed here this is not a the
simple bill that it looked like it has a
lot of the issues that we see L you know
across the board in dealing with
Broadband
deployment representative Marsh you want
a comment uh I think that the chair can
uh address his bills as whatever way he
sees fit and I recognize that it is a
complicated problem or it would have
been solved a long time
ago I guess I would wonder is there any
urgency uh on the part of the selectman
and the residents of the town of
Brookfield to make this happen sooner
rather than later uh yes the answer to
that question is
yes okay thank you uh the chair
recognizes
representative ssuch for a
question thank you Mr chairman and thank
you Mr hson for taking my question um
this is more of kind of a philosophical
question to you um we all recognize the
value of broadband and the need to make
sure that everyone has access to it
because of its value um from from your
Vantage Point uh looking at the problems
of trying to deploy it and make it
accessible to everyone what do you see
as the being the biggest
obstacles besides
poll oh I'm sorry representative oh
besides poll
oh you know
I I think that
um one of the unsatisfactory realities
of trying to tackle this issue is that
there's there's no there is no Silver
Bullet that that is offered or has been
offered um are the the basic
challenge that all of us have in
deploying these networks is the
potential
Market that exists for the products
relative to the cost of deploying the
product so uh efforts like this that
seek to to address that lad element um
is Def is certainly helpful which is why
we we've advocated for you know both an
approach similar to this and uh as other
others have noted you know regulations
that either speed or
uh ease access to these these assets so
it's it's I think it's very difficult to
identify that
single uh issue that that is going to
resolve this issue it's a combination of
uh are there customers there who can
provide the revenue necessary to support
the costs required to build the
network uh that's the a very large
equation to solve
uh followup Mr
CH uh quickly we have one more piece
person who wants to speak on this bill
uh do you see any yeah thank you uh Mr
Hutson do you see any analogy between
providing rural rural
electrification to everyone in this
country uh versus the Broadband I mean
that was certainly a similar
situation you know I truly I I don't see
where we are today with Broadband
deployment in our country or in our
state having a offering a great analog
between where the country was when it
decided to uh go down the path it did
with Rural
electrification and the reason I say
that is that right now uh in this state
there's two reasons really right now in
this state and in this country we have
particularly in the state High 90
percentile uh availability of broadband
depending on what you consider Broadband
in terms of speeds depending on exactly
how uh or what source of information you
use there's still we still fall
somewhere between the low to mid90s and
the mid to high 90s 93 to 96 7% That's
vastly different than where we were as a
country when we embarked on Rural
electrification and the second issue is
that Broadband we now have a variety of
technologies that I think really
indisputably deliver Broadband quality
services we've got uh Wireless Services
wired terrestrial services like the ones
that concast provides you've got uh
really more as an emerging technology
but a proven technology as it relates to
satellite um that's not that was not the
case also uh when we embarked on Rural
electrification you you don't we we have
um just a variety of competing
technologies that we just we didn't have
um when that that first decision was
made so I I think that I think those
comparisons are are fraud um to be
candid okay thank
you okay we have one more person who
wants to speak so please make your
questions uh quick representative McGee
is uh recognized for a question question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you Mr
hodin for taking my question my my
question's on a similar vein I think we
we heard testimony earlier about uh
essential services that are being
delivered to and areas that are blackout
so if they're in that seven four to s%
range of people who are excluded it may
be a very small percentage but it it
still could relate to essential services
so I guess my question is
um is it just about the cost proposition
or is it about us being able to figure
out a way to uh take what is basically
an an essential infrastructure service
and make it available to everyone in the
state regardless of their
location or or to find a way you know
support that I mean I thought that that
was the uh impetus for the bill although
it relates to Brookfield in a specific
situation it is not dissimilar from
other small towns who also can't
make yeah thank you representative I
think that's correct I think that uh the
this idea which found was germinated in
Brookfield uh is uh is because the the
challenge is being experienced in a
number of small towns in the state so uh
you I I think
we while not a necessary solution for
this bill I think we feel like we
believe and we've advocated for
Partnerships between the public sector
and the private sector that where the
public sector um helps the private
sector overcome those economic
barriers um and uh do it in a way that
allows all those different sorts of
technologies that I just described to uh
try to have a seat at the table to solve
the problem that you know we we've we
have the the Technology's proven the
means of doing it the economic model is
uh is proven the challenge is is how do
you apply it in these uh these areas and
uh and I think you know we feel like uh
programs that allow the private sector
and the partner the public sector to
partner would really offer the best
opportunity for Success followup Mr
chairman okay thank you no I'm not going
to allow a followup at this point
because the discussion have strayed from
the subject of the bill the subject of
the bill is pole replacement and now
we're talking about Broad band expansion
across the state that's not the subject
of the bill so let's uh let's move on
and let me call on the final speaker uh
who wants to speak on this bill and that
is Ellen
scarponi and uh Miss scarponi represents
Consolidated Communications Miss garon
you're on good afternoon chairman Vose
and committee members thank you for the
opportunity to talk to you today my name
is Ellen scarponi and I do represent
Consolidated Communications
I don't want to repeat things that have
already been testified to but I do need
to incorporate them in this discussion
if you'll bear with me of course there
is a strong consensus in New Hampshire
among the residents and businesses and
Educators and medical providers those
who legislate and those who regulate and
the providers of service that adequate
Broadband is necessary to sustain and
expand opportunities to every corner of
our state those are the questions that
have been coming up Consolidated
Communications agrees completely and we
with that of the importance of this
expansion and the fact that there are
multiple ways that we need to do it we
are currently working with over 50 towns
counties uh municipalities and the state
on multiple ways to expand the Broadband
including but not limited to Municipal
private Public Partnerships which I will
offer to you that I will reach out to
the representative the selectman from
Brookfield Mr zachar to discuss um how
these public private Partnerships are
working um to fund the Broadband to
unserved people in their communities
without any tax implications for their
town so I know he had mentioned that he
you know that he had a quote from
Consolidated for one .2 million but this
was not and he said that they had to
fund completely so I will reach out I
promise to him to clear that up we also
have participated in the car's funding
for Broadband the connect America Funds
and now the r rural digital opportunity
fund as well as our own investments in
transformational fiber bills when we've
been before you in the last two years um
there were ETS that didn't look like
they would ever get broadband and I can
tell you now that we have we and other
providers now have five or two the home
in many of these very rural communities
so we very much support the rule the
rapid expansion of broadband in New
Hampshire and everything regarding polls
and poll attachments has um you know is
subject as previous speakers our
testifiers have testified to they are
subject to section 224 of the FCC
Telecommunications Act of
1996 that say that it is unreasonable
and inconsistent for utilities to impose
the entire cost of a poll replacement on
a requesting attacher when the attacher
is not the sole cause of the of the pole
replacement and then under RSA 374 34A
the New Hampshire Public Utilities
enforces rates charges terms and itions
as regulated under that same act 47 usc2
Consolidated again we are a
telecommunications company that also
owns polls we have always operated under
this rule but we oppose HB 308 because
this bill does not Advance Broadband
expansion except to benefit one category
of provider and potentially increase
costs for the others the bill seeks to
require that the pole owner absorb the
cost to replace poles for new
attachments even when the only reason
for the pole pole replacement is the new
attachment this is nothing new these are
the rules that have been set out while a
pole may or may not be fully depreciated
if the need to replace it is driven
solely by the new attacher the new
attacher should bear the cost because
but for that attachment the pole would
not need to be
replaced we as I say we have always
operated under the rules from the FCC as
endorsed by the Pu but 308 HB 308 seeds
to shift all poll replacement costs to
the poll owner regardless of the reason
for the replacement so we asked the
committee find HB 308 inexpedient to
legislate now that's my formal testimony
and I will submit this in writing but
I'm happy to answer any of the questions
um or get or provide clarification for
questions that have come up during this
conversation this hearing today thank
you very
much thank you Miss garon before we take
any questions I'm going
to open the public hearing on HB
371 and recess that hearing for the time
being now I will
recognize representative Cali pittz for
a
question hi Ellen it's nice to see you
again this is Jackie hi you too
question I would like you to clarify the
definition of served and access there
was a time when we said people had no
access but what it was was they had in
um inadequate speeds so could you just
clarify those two defin definitions
please um I I I can't I I hope I can yes
when we talked in the past early days of
broadband there were issues in terms of
the unserved people who did not have um
adequate Broadband to or the unserved
they didn't have any Broadband if you
will we did put in definition and it is
in statute now that there is a
speed uh requirement a minimum
requirement um that was established by
the FCC a couple of years ago of what we
call 253 25 megabits uh download F uh 3
megabits uploads and those were speeds
um that the SEC at that point felt were
sufficient uh when we have done
legislation in the last year uh it was
recognized that
253 uh is not future proof and that
there should be some room
for allowing uh expansion of broadband
and the UN and the unserved definition
should be what the FCC would then
currently um have defined so that number
can move um the underserved are people
who might have some level of broadband
but again it does not reach that speed
level and I will tell you that although
when the municip and and this committee
was in involved way back when in the
municipal Broadband bonding uh
legislation and uh it was also in front
of a number of other committees but what
that did a couple of years ago was Ena
towns
to request they they could put out a
request for proposal for networks that
applied what they needed in their
community so let's let's say it is the
rural community of Brookfield and they
have a uh they not even all of their
residents have access to broadband they
could put out a request for information
to all providers to say where are those
areas that are unserved as the FC
current FCC uh definition is and they
could then decide as a community to put
out a request for proposal to all
providers of broadband and they can
tailor made this is local control they
can say in their RFP we don't want it to
just be 25 by3 we want it to be 100
symmetrical we want it to be a gigabit
they could go for anything to uh
representative oxham question before
they can say they only want fiber and
then they get responses back from
providers and all of us who are are on
this call who have testified are those
providers who can respond and then they
can bond for that and work with the
provider on how that bond is paid for so
long answer representative I apologize
but did I answer your
question yes but may I follow
up okay follow up when we did
um and I just like a yes and know did
gasoline we said you know when they put
an octane on a gasoline it means that's
the minimal you can get but it doesn't
mean that you don't get more of an
octane so can you push speeds through
current wires so that you can up the
accents and I know the charge goes up
with that but can you do
that can that be done on existing uh
infrastructure and the existing media um
it it it can be with with electronics
however I will tell you that um I don't
know of any town that has asked for
bigger speeds on our copper
infrastructure that they are all looking
for quotes on fiber for
the okay thank
you thank you representative cran
acknowledged for a
question thank you chairman Bose and
thank you Miss carpon for taking my
question um I just wanted to ask for
clarification on the statement um if but
for the need for a new service a poll
wouldn't need replacing is there
anything at all in the definition for
pole replacement of
um I guess I'm just wondering why not
having space for a new necessary
function is not part of the definition
of a pole meeting replacement does that
make sense I'm trying to trying to
formulate that question well the if you
look at polls as uh uh Mr hodon had said
a pole is and the attachments are
engineered to the nth degree to
determine what the capacity is for the
electric on top and how heavy literally
how heavy those wires are going to be
and then the T usually it's the uh
telephone utility as as Mr hudon said
that on the bottom and then there are
specific safety concerns and electrical
concerns that determine the space
between Communications attachments and
how many of them can be in that space
when that space runs out you know used
to be that there was only it used to be
there was only Power there was telephone
and then there was cable and now we have
all of these other providers needing
attachments well the the engineering of
these poles has to be first and foremost
for safety and so if it is determined
that there is not enough space in there
regardless of what that attacher is who
that attacher is whether it's it's cable
or electric or you know wh whomever it
there are times when poles have to be
replaced because electric is upgrading
but there
that that is part as I say of the FCC
rules and the puc rules um that
attachments themselves are not reason
the
attachment is the reason to upgrade the
pole but it should not be borne by the
pole owner because if they didn't want
to attach then we wouldn't need to
replace the pole does that answer your
question
I think
so okay thank you
um seeing that there are no further
questions I would like to uh close this
public hearing so we can move on to the
next one which is now 10 minutes
overdue and I will close it by
announcing that there were 14 people who
signed in in support of this legislation
there were three who signed in in
opposition
we had elected officials representative
Brody Dees signing in in
support representative Carol Crawford
signing in in support representative
John McDonald signing in in support and
representative laa maputi signing in in
support so with that we will close the
public hearing on HB
308 and we will open or resume the
public hearing
on HB
and once again uh representative
Harrington who is the Prime sponsor of
this legislation has not uh been able to
join us quite yet so
uh the other sponsor of this
legislation who is
myself we'll introduce the
bill soon as I dig it out
here so this legislation was requested
by the consumer
Advocate both he and I have a concern
about uh some text we read in in
a uh proceeding of the Public Utilities
Commission that took place in October
with regard to the Energy Efficiency
resource standard trianium U Energy
Efficiency plan in which the commission
uh said that some of its proceedings are
quazi
legislative and that made me nervous and
it apparently made the consumer Advocate
nervous as well and uh
so he asked representative Harrington
and I if we would file this bill which
basically says that uh all of the
commission's proceedings that affect
rates and
charges uh have to be done as uh
adjudicative proceedings in other words
they're like Court proceedings where
testimonies and findings of fact are um
submitted as evidence
um and the consumer Advocate will
explain in more detail what he means by
that um but it's a fairly simple and
straightforward
change to legislation but an extremely
important
one and so uh I'm not going to say any
further on the subject and I will refer
all questions to the consumer advocate
so if you will hold your questions I
will turn the matter over to the
consumer ad advate Don Cree who will
explain it
in great detail he submitted written
testimony which was voluminous in its
detail and excellent as usual but he
will summarize that for you and
uh give the bill it's due so don CH
please take it away uh thank you uh
chairman Vose first of all thanks to you
and to representative Harrington for
agreeing to introduce this bill and
thank you for this opportunity to
explain to uh everybody on the committee
why I think this bill is important uh as
you all know my job is to represent the
interests of residential utility
customers but but really what's
informing my interest in this bill is as
much about that as it is about my
background as a teacher of
administrative law I've taught that
subject at Vermont law school earlier in
my career and also uh my experience
serving as the general Council of the
public Utilities Commission um the first
point I have to make about this bill is
that in my opinion and this is very
important this bill that representative
Harrington and representative Vose have
introduced clarifies existing law I
believe the Public Utilities Commission
has made a mistake of law that we will
attempt to correct through the Appellate
process if necessary but in the meantime
representative Harrington and
representative Vose graciously agreed to
introduce this bill as a way of making
what I consider to be existing law
absolutely clear to the folks at the
Public Utilities Commission and
everybody else so the Public Utilities
Commission like most if not all
administrative
agencies uh has the responsibility from
time to time to make determinations that
establish the legal rights duties or
privileges of people out in the world
and by people I mean both actual and
virtual people meaning human beings and
entities formed by human beings so the
Pu makes decisions that affect the legal
rights duties or privileges of people
and there are really two flavors that
the commission can use for its
decision-making there's vanilla and
there's chocolate so by Vanilla I mean
the commission can promulgate rules
that's called Rule making and rules are
uh requirements that apply generally to
everybody and then there's chocolate
flavor decision-making and that is
adjudication and as representative Vose
just explained to you adjudication when
the Public Utilities Commission or any
administrative agency is conducting
audification
adjudication it really is uh making
decisions that resemble the way courts
make
decisions and so you have your vanilla
you have your chocolate but then for
some reason the Public Utilities
Commission has decided to attempt to
invent strawberry and by strawberry I
mean what the commission described in
the order the chairman Vose referenced
back in October as a quote unquote
legislative docket well I I'm here to
say that that is not consistent with
established principles of administrative
law uh uh the Public Utilities
Commission and administ ative agencies
do have the right and obligation to
conduct quote unquote legislative
proceedings that is what a rule making
is that's what rule making is a form of
legislating and it is legislative
Authority that has been delegated by you
the general court to the administrative
agency now we all thought and by we I
think pretty much everybody who
practices in front of the Public
Utilities Commission thought that rate
proceedings uh were adjudicative until
uh the Public Utilities Commission
issued this order in October saying that
the proceeding it was ruling in which
has to do with the Energy Efficiency uh
CH part of the system benefits charge
but not just that but any rate
proceeding is really legislative in
nature and as I explained in my uh
written testimony I think that proceeds
from an erroneous application of case
law that's that just talks about the
fact that when an agency acts it is
acting pursuant to delegated legislative
Authority that's informative when it
comes to the nature of the power that an
administrative agency wields but it's
not informative about how the agency has
to make its decisions and as I said
before there's vanilla there's chocolate
there is no such thing as strawberry
there's Ru making there's a judication
period now as I mentioned in my written
testimony not every decision that an
agency makes has to be either rulemaking
or adjudication because agencies make
decisions all the time that don't affect
the legal rights duties or privileges of
people with business in front of the
agency and I gave you a couple of uh
somewhat Whimsical
examples I think that allowing the
Public Utilities Commission to uh
basically adjudicate or determine the
legal rights duties or privileges uh
through this third flavor of
decision-making is bad for both the
customers and the utility shareholders
whose interests the Pu is supposed to uh
serve as the Arbiter between and why do
I say that well in
a quazi legislative or legislative
docket unlike in an adjudicative docket
there's no definitive record and what's
important about an adjudicative
proceeding is that the commission has to
make its decision based on an
established body of evidence that has
been formally admitted into the record
uh now in a legislative proceeding such
as the one we're in right now we don't
base you don't have to base your
decision on a definite record but as I
explained in my written testimony there
there's a different mechanism for
constraining you and that is called
elections right like if you folks make
decisions that are improvident for some
reason you have to answer to your voters
for that but an administrative agency
doesn't have to do that
uh in an adjudicative proceeding there
is a very strict rule against exp parte
contact I can't call up the chair of the
Pu and say chairwoman Martin I don't
want you to decide this case that's
pending before you in a certain way
because I think it's bad for rate payers
not allowed to do that but in a quazi
legislative proceeding uh I suppose I
could do that and again as I explained
in my written testimony in a so-called
legislative docket that isn't a
rulemaking there's really no way for the
state supreme court in an appellate
context meaning if I appeal a decision
that I don't like or one of the
utilities does there's really no
standard for the appell court to apply
to determine whether it's going to
affirm or overturn the pu's decision now
there's another uh Little slice of this
that I did not mention in my uh written
testimony and that has to do with RSA
36317 C so section 17 C of chapter RSA
363 and what that statute says is that
when the Pu conducts adjudication its
deliberations do not have to be
conducted in public and that is an
appropriate way of allowing the
commission to determine its decisions in
adjudicative proceedings because it has
to issue a formal decision based on an
established and defined body of evidence
and it has to explain both in terms of
fact and the law what it's what the
basis of its decision is in another kind
of proceeding you know you really do
need the commission to deliberate in
public as any agency is required to
deliberate in public under the right to
no law so this new flavor of uh uh
decision-making that the Pu has
announced runs smack up against RSA
36317 C and I contend that if the Pu is
going to do that uh and it's going to be
allowed to do that it at the very least
has to conduct its deliberations in
public
so in conclusion I warmly recommend that
you read my fairly lengthy written
testimony about this bill because I
elaborated on these principles to the
maximum extent that any of you could
possibly be interested in learning about
them but in closing I again want to
clarify for for purposes of establishing
a unassailably clear legislative record
that in my opinion this bill clarifies
existing law and I asked for its
introduction as a way of making sure
that existing law cannot be subject to
erroneous interpretation so I think with
that I will conclude again with my
thanks for the opportunity to talk to
you and to uh have this bill come before
you I would be delighted to answer any
questions that the chairman might allow
to be tendered to
me thank you Mr Greece I'm disappointed
that there's no one here from the Pu to
uh testify on on this bill or to answer
questions but that appears to be the
case but we do have uh Representatives
who want to ask questions and the first
one is representative McGee you're
recognized for a
question thank you Mr chairman and thank
you consumer Advocate Cree I actually I
did read your testimony and I have heard
you speak about this in our dealings
over at the Pu on occasion I think
you've done a good job of explaining to
us why um it's important to preserve
chocolate and try and avoid adding
strawberry um I guess the only question
I would have is is there any explanation
for why we were moving towards
strawberry like I don't understand how
we veered away from stuff that was
fairly well established at the Public
Utilities Commission is there any
backstory that that could help us
understand
that thank you representative McGee for
that extremely astute question the the
short answer answer is I don't really
know but the slightly longer answer is
that my speculation is that the
commission did not like a motion that I
had filed that would have resulted if
granted in the designation of certain of
its employees in that uh Energy
Efficiency proceeding as staff Advocates
and that would have uh subjected them to
or it would have prohibited them from
having informal exp parte contact with
the Commissioners the commission never
likes motion like that but the statute
that authorizes those designations only
applies in adjudicative proceedings and
I think the commission thought that that
would be a convenient way of getting rid
of my motion that that's the only thing
I can think of that that's literally how
that decision got made in October I I
think it was uh I think the commission
painted itself into a corner
improvidently but uh that's what they
did that's my best
speculation uh thank you may I have a
followup follow up thank you Mr chair um
so I think you've tried to explain and I
want to understand this it it seems to
me the the agency itself tries to
conduct itself in a way that is as
public as possible and in conformance
with the rsas around an agency of that
type where it's you know it's got a lot
of influence over what's happening with
the utilities and all so
um is there a particular h
you've alluded to a number of different
scenarios where you can see sort of a
slippery slope happening and I guess the
question would be can you point to
particular harms that could occur in
terms of these public proceedings uh
beyond what you've already illuminated
or um or is the idea of having direct
contact and influence with the
Commissioners the main um piece that
would be changed if we were
not uh managing cases within an
adjudicative
procedure I I I think that the uh per uh
first of all thank you for that question
and I I actually think to be candid that
that possibility of ex parte contact is
not my biggest worry because I have uh
having dealt with several generations of
pu Commissioners I have a a high degree
of faith in their personal integrity and
my guess is that they would avoid those
kinds of xparte contacts what I'm more
worried about is the Pu making decisions
and you know we're talking about rate
cases here right rate proceedings and so
that has to do with you know what rates
will eversource or Liberty or Unitil or
any of the water companies be allowed to
charge all of their customers and if you
don't require the rigors of adjudication
then the commission could basically just
pluck numbers out of thin air and say
well you know uh eversource asked for a
15% R increase and the consumer Advocate
favored a 5% rate increase and we're
just going to decide 12% because that's
what we like and I have no way of
knowing how they got to that 12% whether
there was and neither does the utility
whether there was any rational basis for
that kind of decision or whether they
just guessed and you know um my favorite
part of rate cases is what return on
Equity is a utility entitled to meaning
what what is the commission going to
assume its shareholder should be able to
earn uh as a result of its operations
here in New Hampshire and it makes a
difference whether that return on Equity
is assumed to be 20% that would be
ridiculously high in the current economy
or uh 5% which would be so low from a
utility standpoint that it would be a
violation of the taking Clause of the
Fifth Amendment well if you don't
require adjudication neither I nor the
utilities really have any way of
determining what the actual basis of the
commission's decision is and it would be
up to their whim I guess to uh figure
out or determine how precise they would
actually be in terms of explaining
themselves and it would be impossible to
appeal because I wouldn't know what to
say to the Supreme Court about what the
agency did wrong other than gosh I think
they were too generous to the company so
it's accountability as well as
transparency absolutely not show okay
thank you thank you for that excellent
question uh representative man has
recognized for a
question don't forget to unmute yourself
yeah I I finally remember thank you Mr
chairman um I have um I have an example
I would like to ask you about Mr ch um
and that is uh assistance benefit charge
is um can be added for benefits and um
as I guess as determined by
Regulators is is a statement in the
legislation how does what you have
talked about relate to that is that is
that not
um um legislation if you are choosing to
raise the assistance benefits charge to
pay for a certain thing that they decide
is a
benefit well thank you representative
man for that for that question and I I
guess my answer is that it's it's it's a
difficult example to focus on because
obviously the system benefits charge is
itself a matter of uh I guess you would
say controversy or discussion or uh
re-evaluation uh to to my way of
thinking and and this is the way the Pu
chose to treat the subject uh a decision
on what the system benefits charge
should be what cents per kilowatt hour
charge that should be for an electric
utility is a decision pursuant to RSA
chapter 378 about what a rate is that is
the requisite just and reasonable rate
so I would contend that the system
benefits charge is like any other
utility charge at least for purposes of
this conversation meaning it is simply a
just and reasonable rate as determined
by the Pu that is imposed on customers
in exchange for a service that they
receive and all the discussions that
we've been having about the SBC are
about whether that service is really
sufficiently valuable to justify the uh
level of the charge and and again it's
Authority that has been delegated to the
Pu that the legislature can take back
and these other conversations we've been
having are about whether and to what
extent the legislature should reclaim
some of that delegation Authority I I I
hope that was a sufficiently lucid
answer thank you thank you
representative C Pitt's recognized for a
question don't forget to unmute
yourself I thank you I have a very
simplistic mind and in my mind
if deliberations have to take
place in
public isn't that doesn't that make one
more aware I I'm going to assume and
please correct me that information from
both sides have to be
presented in a to be uh to both to to
the Commissioners and then they have to
deliberate it deliberate on it and come
to a conclusion if those deliberations
have to take place in public I would
assume there'd be a record of them
somewhere and again I'm making a lot of
assumptions that sets of information
would be available and why wouldn't that
be more
transparent than having deliberations in
private thank you representative Cali
pittz uh and let me just come out of the
closet as a fellow simple-minded person
so thank you for giving me permission to
be forthright about that uh so a short
and maybe glib answer is that back in
2007 the general court decided that it
would be desirable for deliberations in
adjudicative proceedings at the Pu to be
conducted privately and I I I tried to
explain a little bit about what I think
the justification for that is but as a
general principle what you just laid out
the premise of your question is the same
premise that underlies our right to no
law and particularly the open meeting
provisions of the right to no law
overall the legislature has determined
that we want government bodies like the
Pu to conduct their business in public
so that we know what the basis for their
decisions is and what kinds of uh
influences are being brought to bear on
the decision makers uh the RSA 91a
requires public bodies not just to to
meet in public but to keep minutes and
when the Pu does meet in public for
public deliberations they do uh uh
develop and approve minutes now you know
they don't do a lot of deliberating in
public so there aren't a lot of minutes
to review and you could uh argue I guess
about the extent to which the minutes
adequately reflect the actual
deliberations but that's how it works as
a generic matter with respect to
government agencies they are supposed to
meet in public they're supposed to
discuss things in public and they're
supposed to keep
minutes and may I clarify
yes follow up then then my understanding
and again in this simple-minded view was
that your bill does not want this to
happen this bill wants them to be able
to the the process to be public but
deliberations to be private is that
correct is that what you're
advocating uh thank you for that
question and that followup I I I guess I
disagree or at least maybe I haven't
expressed myself with sufficient clarity
uh the main Public Utilities Commission
just to cite the example that comes
right to my mind does do all of its
deliberations in public whether they
have adjudicated or not and I I I think
there's much to be said for that public
policy that's the way Maine and the
Maine legislature has uh constituted
their Public Utilities Commission here
uh for whatever reason back in 2007 and
that actually does go back to the days
when I was General Counsel so I could
talk about why that happened in 2007 uh
I have a two-word answer it would be
Clift and Belo
just um but in other words former
commissioner Belo thought this was a
really good idea there there are
arguments in favor of allowing
adjudicative deliberations to be
conducted in private and when you think
about it it makes sense because we don't
require judges to deliberate in public
we are uh willing to rely on the written
orders that they issue because they
contain detailed findings of facts and
conclusions of law so I it's not that
I'm trying to drive the Pu into private
deliberations I'd be perfectly happy if
you repealed RSA 36317 C and said all of
the pu's deliberations have to be public
it's more that I think when the legal
rights duties or privileges of anybody
are at issue the Pu either has to
promulgate a rule or conduct an
adjudication thank
you thank you um there are no other
people signed up to speak on this bill
and there are sorry uh no hands raised
so I have a raised
hand uh representative Harrington is
recognized for a question thank you uh
just to as a followup to what Mr Cree
just said um uh there's a lot of uh back
and forth was discussed over the years
on whether the all the deliberation
should be public with the Pu undergoes
uh having been a commissioner I can tell
you that I think there's more open
discourse behind closed doors than there
would be if you thought everything you
said was going to be quoted I mean for
example someone might play The Devil's
Advocate make a statement that you
really don't necessarily believe but you
put it out there in order to stimulate
uh discussion that could then next thing
you know be show up on the Facebook or
the newspaper or something like that and
the other thing that that was the reason
that we sort of lean towards keeping the
deliberations private was because unlike
most other agencies when the Pu issues
an order it comes with pages and pages
of justification the standard procedure
is it gives you the the position of the
staff the position of the let's just say
there was a utility involved position of
somebody who opposed the utility all
that stuff is laid out and then the Pu
gives their justification for why they
ruled as they did I think there's plenty
of information provided in these orders
and that having to do everything in
public would just make it kind of
difficult to have a free and open
exchange of ideas between
Commissioners okay thank you
representative Harrington I see a hand
raised by representative McGee you
recognize for your question
thank you Mr chairman and this is to
representative Harrington does the bill
actually talk about uh public and
private I thought all it did was uh
clarify that adjudicative proceedings
are that's that chocolate form of of how
how uh the Pu conducts its business I
thought that that's what it was asking
for I I believe you're correct I just it
was we were commenting on the on the
discourse thing that's why I brought it
up but uh Mr cre you can correct if I'm
wrong but I believe it doesn't address
it in this particular
Bill uh that's exactly right
representative Harrington uh the reason
this whole sort of uh uh subsidiary
conversation has erupted I guess is that
RSA 36317 C says the commission's
deliberative processes in adjudicatory
proceedings dot dot dot uh are exempt
from public meeting notice and
disclosure requirements so that's how we
got there but the question of whether
rsa3 6317 C is a good idea and
representative Harrington just laid out
a pretty convincing case for why it is
that's not a question covered by this
particular
Bill okay uh well looks like we have
another question um representative
oxenham is uh recognized for a question
thank you very much I was just uh
perusing the at1d list to see if there
was a representative from clean energy
New Hampshire because I believe they put
out a statement that they're opposed to
this bill and I would have I would have
liked to have heard their reasons
why
um can can you can you tell me whether
there's a cost to this change is is it
the case that if there everything is
going to be a contested case that this
is going to be imposing additional costs
on
participants
uh before you answer Mr gree I just want
to point out to representative oxam that
meline manow from clean energy New
Hampshire did sign up uh in support of
this bill according to the sheet I have
go ahead Mr C and answer the question
thank you well first thank you chairman
V because that's my understanding of
clean energy New Hampshire's position as
well and thank you for your question
representative oxum uh I I don't think
that that adopting this bill will
increase the cost of either having the
Pu or appearing before the Pu and here's
why as I said twice and as I will now
say for a third time this bill in my
opinion clarifies existing law so we
will simply tell the Pu that it has to
continue doing or making rate decisions
the same way it has since the commission
was formed in 1911 or whenever it was
back then uh
the other thing is that that from the
standpoint of parties that litigated the
Pu and you know maybe some of the
private interests that have pu matters
could comment on this but it's my
impression that what drives up company
costs of the cost of Regulation is
uncertainty right to the extent that we
can make the puc's decision-making
process and therefore the decisions more
predictable uh investor own companies
like that better because they can plan
for things that are fairly
certain thank you okay thank you
um uh Mr CH and seeing no further
questions and having no further speakers
signed up for this bill I think we can
close the public hearing on HB 371 we
had 25 people uh sign in to support the
bill and seven people signed in to
oppose it
we had for elected officials we had
representative Elaine Thomas signing in
in support and a representative laa
maputi signing in in support of the bill
as well so with that we will close the
public hearing on HB
371 and since we have uh some time I'm
going to turn uh
running of the committee over to uh
chairman Vice chairman Thomas for uh an
executive
session thank you Mr chair um I declare
uh executive session session open for
House Bill
614 and with that I'm looking for a
motion from representative Harington
involving the
amendment excuse me m Mr chairman can
can I have point of order
please go ahead um I am a little bit
confused again not again but I'm a
little bit confused about exactly who is
authorized to vote in this executive
session I see a number of new people who
are uh logged into this session uh I
don't know who is a substitute for who
and I would like that to ask the
chairman to clarify for us who is a
voting member in this executive session
and also what the rules are for uh sub
substitution well I can answer that if
you want um first of all earlier this
morning it was announced that
representative Ling was a uh substitute
for representative um white who wasn't
able to be here today and um as you know
uh representative hola has been assigned
to this committee since uh day one and
is still assigned to this committee so
we have a full committee here of the
only subtitute we have is representative
Ling who was uh duly appointed as a
substitute for today the rule involving
that was if the chair is notified uh or
if the chair notifies the day
before in a meeting or executive session
to the house um of the absence of the
member for the entire day then a suit
can be appointed which was in fact the
case so with that I have to contradict
that my understanding is that one needs
to be appointed an hour before not 24
hours before is that
correct I don't believe it is but even
if it were he was appointed you know
yesterday I mean as result of we
understand I understand that but what
what is the actual rule here when does a
person by what time does a person have
to be replaced an hour before the
hearing or 24 hours before
hearing I believe the leadership uh has
specified that a committee needs to
notify
leadership 24 hours in
advance that a replacement is needed on
a given day and Leadership will then
affect an appointment to uh replace the
member who cannot be there um I don't
know if there's an exact hour listed in
the rule I don't believe that there is
the only thing I think the rule deals
with is notification of leadership uh 24
hours in advance in order to get a
replacement in other words I don't think
leadership would accept it if you called
up an hour before you wanted to do an
exec session and said hey I need a
replacement that wouldn't be
acceptable okay and uh then Mr chair
chairman another followup to that um the
uh uh we had a replacement for
representative Platt when he was no
longer able to not able to attend he's
now attending so whoever replaced him
would not be part of this committee at
this point right no that's not correct
uh representative plat is attending as
um any representative can attend any
committee meeting uh he's not a voting
member uh the leadership has submitted a
letter reinstating him as a voting
member as of February 15 which is next
Monday so he's here to observe I'm
allowing him to participate because
um we want to keep his spirits up you
know Abol understand we want to keep him
involved absolutely I I was just
confused that I thought he was going to
be a voting member this time too he will
not be voting with us
and one final clarification from you Mr
chairman this is not on this topic but a
different topic um I think uh represent
McGee asked previously uh that as a
co-sponsor she she wanted to ask a
question and I remember you distinctly
saying in the beginning of our sessions
that uh a co-sponsor could in fact ask
questions if there is time available is
that your position at this point was no
time yes time permitting yes okay thank
you
very okay with that said uh again I'm
looking for a motion from representative
Harrington uh on the amendment 614 and
the amendment would be uh 2021 022 H so
moved that would be I I move that that
we adopt uh 2021 022 is an amendment to
HB 614 Mr chairman point of order
go ahead has the amendment been
circulated uh my understanding is that
it has over the
weekend is it the one that we had before
the last hearing on this
bill I believe so I need a firm answer
on that I I can I can answer that
question thank you um this is a new
Amendment
that was
circulated um on
Thursday uh
February what was last Thursday anyway
it was it was circulated last
Thursday um that would have been
February 4th it was sent to all the
committee members on February 4th and to
house committee services for
distribution to members of the
committee
has anyone seen it because I haven't
seen
it uh Mr chair the motion has been made
I'm looking for a second from my
representative point of
order um point of
order I I would I would request that if
it would be possible to take a short
break recess perhaps um to review the
amendment and have a caucus that would
be very
helpful well we did pass the amendment
uh around last week is there
a reason why you didn't get to it until
now um just to be clear it sounds like
there are quite a few folks who haven't
had a chance to review the amendment um
and it doesn't make sense for us to vote
on something that people haven't read uh
certainly we have received hundreds of
emails between Thursday and now I I
believe we all get the uh emails that go
to the whole St
committee I believe the amendment was
passed out with sufficient time to be
read so um I'm going to uh respectfully
decline that and proceed with the second
to the amendment from representative
nder yes I second the amend the motion
to
uh submit the uh I'm sorry hold
on adopt the amendment motion has been
seconded we're open for discussion on
adopting the amendment 2021
go ahead represent H thank you I just
wanted to uh point out that to again um
it'll say unapproved on it but we went
over this the last time that we talked
about amendments so this is the actual
Amendment it just says unapproved on it
that's correct the um OLS this year has
said that this is the official Amendment
even though it says unapproved on it
they're not going to have approved on it
until it's been
adopted M represent oam go ahead I see
your hand up for a question thank you is
it the case that the change
here Builds on the previous Amendment
and
only gets rid of that Free Rider issue
that we discussed at the
hearing so if if you are exempt you
cannot ask for money under the
program I'll let the representative V
address that question
yes thank you for that question that's
exactly what this amendment does it adds
a new section e that uh says that if a
town accepts its exemption from paying
the RPS that it cannot apply for Grants
from the renewable energy fund so it
deals with the free riter question that
represent representative ssuch talked
about um when we discussed this before
this executive session was recessed
thank you and and other than that it's
the same as the amendment not the same
as the original
Bill yes that is correct thank you
representative uh chisan you recognize
for a
question in executive session it has to
be a question can't just be a
statement it can be a statement too okay
um yeah I just wanted to say I feel like
even I appreciate um the intent of the
amendment to eliminate the Free Rider
situation I just know that that our
municipalities are dealing with a lot of
things that they have to think about and
I think that this just adds an
unnecessary layer of confusion and
effort for them to participate in this
program thank
you uh seeing no other questions I'm
going to ask the clerk to um call the
vote um Mr
chair it you're saying now members
cannot discuss what's in the bill we can
only ask questions because this isn't a
hearing this is an executive session so
if we have discussion points that we'd
like to raise before people put their
votes on the table shouldn't we be
allowed to do that well as I explained
to representative Christian she was
correct you can also make a statement as
well as a question I just got through
saying
that so yes you can you know you can you
if you have a discussion Point go
ahead okay well I mean I think um what I
had said in the last hearing I'd like to
reiterate here which is that this
basically guts the idea of there being a
a benefit to the state of New Hampshire
in having uh Energy Efficiency
subsidized through a an S you know
through a system benefit charge and
that's what it was designed for so we're
really undoing the ability of our towns
to be able to invest in Energy
Efficiency to lower their costs
permanently which is the whole reason
that we want to have funding for that
and it's a very as as and as the
testimony in the hearings showed us
that's a really good investment that's a
four to one you know rate of return and
So based on the evidence and also the
support for the bill um I mean the the
support not the support the opposition
to doing away with this money
um I don't see how we can do this in a I
don't see how we can responsibly take
this away I don't believe um uh this
bill covers that subject that you were
talking about so um but your comments
are
noted what what subject are you
referring to that it doesn't
representative Harrington I see you
recognized for a uh comment yeah I just
wanted to say that no one's taking
anything away from anybody here it just
gives the town the uh option to decide
whether they want to get involved in the
program or not I mean some towns uh have
enough resources they have an energy
committee they may even have a full-time
professional who works on uh trying to
cut their energy uses and save them
money a lot of the small towns don't
have anything like that and they just
assume say Hey you know let us keep our
money and uh we'll figure out and if we
decide we want to change in a few years
There's Nothing Stops us from saying we
want to go back in we'll startop paying
the extra fees and hopefully get
something for a project but there's a
lot of of times just aren't going to
take advantage of it and we're giv them
the option to say okay if you don't want
to play you don't have to pay we did
have a discussion than representative P
you recognize for a
comment let me put this down do this
thank you thank you Mr chairman um I
mean the fact that this thing is really
you know just
another uh slice in the the SBC funding
another cut another
bleed uh it's also it appears to be have
an opt out provision rather than an op
in I the the fact that as soon as this
bill passes all the subdivisions as far
as the way I read it no longer are going
to be uh paying this SBC
unless they um the majority vote of the
governing body elects to continue
payments am I correct in the way I'm
reading
this uh Representative no not exactly
this does not involve SBC that involves
R RPS so your comments are noted
representative um MC Williams you're not
you're recognized for a
comment uh thank you to the chair I I I
just want to say on the record that this
creates a huge discrepancy between
halves and Have Nots for the different
towns and municipalities here in New
Hampshire I think that this is
incredibly unfair to small towns and I
think that we're going to see the the
horrible repercussions of this for years
to come this is really concerning to
take away uh funding for the RPS and to
get rid of Energy Efficiency this is
really short-sighted I'm very
concerned thank you representative
representative oxam you recognize for a
comment
if I could come back I'm I must say
I'm I'm I'm still trying to get my mind
wrapped around this and I I don't think
I can
verbalize efficiently so if someone else
could go first and I'll come back
in okay thank you noted I see no other
hands raised we're moving to the vote
please no
where in that case I think I better I
better verbalize my question my hand is
raised oh sorry I just see your hand
raised so represent s please go ahead my
apologies thank you very much
uh uh even though I was my name was
mentioned I I was not involved in
negotiating this amendment just to
clarify this um and uh but I did make
the comment about uh not paying and is
is not is unfair if you're going to take
the use of the benefit
so actually I I am in favor of this
amendment and I will vote for it but I
will vote against the final bill because
I think it's a bad effort to try to gut
the RPS so um I just wanted to put that
on the record and and in my personal
opinion if the towns opt out because
they're not going to make use of this
benefit I have a strong feeling that
very few of them will make use of it
anyway so thank
you thank you representative uh your
comments are noted at this point i' like
to recognize chairman
Vose uh thank you Mr Vice chairman I
would like to um open the public hearing
on HB 309 and recess it until this
executive session is over thank
you representative mcke you recognize
for a
comment yes thank you Mr Vice chairman
um I'm sorry I miss spoke before and
said and translated uh SBC for RPS
um what is not listed in the bill is
whether or not towns would still be
selling reck which would still have a
free rider effect so I'm just wondering
if the bill is still ready for prime
time because this is a very significant
change um depending on how many people
adopt it based on their financial
circumstances uh to get the short-term
benefits while losing the long-term gain
so I I just have that question I don't
think I see anything in the language
here that speaks to rexs and how they
would be handled by somebody who decided
that their subdivision wanted to be
excluded from paying into the
RPS I'll let the representative Vose
answer that
question thank you uh representative for
the question this would have no effect
on a Town's ability to sell Rex it only
would affect a Town's ability to apply
for a grant from the renewable energy
fund representative uh Christian you
recognize for a
comment you um this time it's actually a
question so just clarifying last time we
spoke about this we said that the
default would be to opt out of the
program right for for
municipalities um so I guess my concern
is how will municipalities be notified
that this is going into effect and how
long will they have to decide whether to
opt back in I just I'm worried about
blindsiding um you know small towns who
as it was stated before don't have one
person who's who's dedicated to that
even in Manchester I think it might be
challenging um but just to make sure
that the municipalities have enough time
to really deliberate over whether they
want to stay in and get those
um get those benefits or popped
out thank you for the question
representative O's
comment uh I guess my my answer to that
question would be that towns would see
their electric bill go down by some
percentage um depending on how much they
used
and it would be up to them
to
uh
determine if they need to
a a vote of their governing body to
re-enter the program there would be no
notification according to the bill about
uh to the towns and cities and towns
about their being opted out from the
program that's a good question can I
follow up on that then so out just
qualifying every municipality from
participating in the system until they
explicitly opt in that's really
concerning to
me
yes thank you uh representative Celly
pitch you had your hand up yeah I just
wanted to uh I just wanted to say that I
believe that this bill will be better
off with an amendment than without an
amendment I think that uh the amendment
seeks
to adjust some differences and some
problems with the bill not all of them
but some of them so I think better off
with the
amendment thank you thank you I'm not
hearing any more different information
so I will ask representative oxenham to
say something
different thank you very much um I'm I'm
I I don't believe the question of
difference comes up in our discussions
in an executive session we're we're
trying to work our way through this this
um Amendment and the fact that it towns
my town in particular has been
discussing for years options and is now
coming up with a plan and is ready to go
forward well we think they're ready to
go forward but it's entirely possible
that they may not put it Forward before
such time as this is voted on and then
all of the work even you know with
trained professionals and Consultants
could be down the drain because the rugs
been pulled out from them that the
programs they thought they were going to
be involved in they're no longer
qualified for because somebody in
conquer has changed the
rules I I I find this um not not a good
uh Amendment and and not a good bill and
and I intend to oppose it and I hope
that others will also thank you uh
representative McGee you have some
comments thank you uh representative
Thomas I want I I would like to
reiterate something uh
that I I'm not sure is clear here the
change that was made was to address um
representative som's concern that people
would be gaining benefits from the
renewable portfolio standard program
without actually participating in it and
when I asked the question about whether
towns would still be able to
sell uh
Rex um they basically would be making
revenue from a policy that they're not
paying their share to participate in so
it's going to really destabilize and
um the I don't think this amendment
takes us to a place where we have
something that's basically a stable
policy that is my concern I feel like
it's being pushed through and it's not
it's not uh a suitable solution for
whatever it is that you're trying to
achieve you're saying that you'd like
the that you'd like towns to
save money um by opting out of something
that everyone pays
into and if we do that but we allow
towns who decide to still reap benefits
from that program it's going to become
very lopsided so I'm I'm asking you to
consider uh your actions with this
Bill thank you very much and uh again
for your comments involving the same
concerns I I see no other different
concerns coming up I am moving into the
vote right now asking the clerk to call
the role for the
vote uh okay this is on and the
amendment is 20
21022 we are in the voting mode okay on
the Amendment 21
22h the motion is ought to
pass adop to adopt the amendment I'm
sorry representative Thomas yes
representative Harrington
yes representative ner
yes representative Mna yes
representative Homa yes representative
brne
yes representative bernady
yes representative Kells yes
representative PL yes representative
Lang
yes represent of
sage
no representative Cali
pittz
yes representative
man
no representative oxenham
no Representative
Vincent representative Vincent's not
here I didn't call the roll this morning
because I got a half hour late okay I'll
say not
voting Representative mgee
no representative MC Williams
no representative Chan
no represent
pimel
no Representative pasel
no and chairman
those
yes Mr clerk I I did not see the image
of Mr Lang or representative Harrington
here I don't think they're allowed to
vote unless I see their
image I yes I did they seen them and
then they let go of their screen the
he's he's waving now okay I see I see
representative Lang how about
representative Harrington I didn't see
him if you look you'll see me because
I'm right there okay thank you very much
representative with 12 Y and eight Nays
and one not voting the amendment
passes
yes we have adopted Amendment uh 2021
022 for uh HB
614 I now uh ask for a motion from
representative
Harrington yeah I'm trying to get this
thing to work again here just be here we
go like seeing you I move that we um
pass um the bill as amended by 2021
022 to HB
614 thank you representative
n second motion has been made and
seconded uh we are now for HB 614 uh
ought to pass as amended open for
discussion representative
pimel uh thank you Mr chairman um
again I want to reiterate that that this
is going
to uh be to the detriment of the
RPS and I strongly object to
um the uh section D which basically
makes it an opt out Bill and not an
optin for towns opt out is not going to
to be easy it says it has to be passed
by the majority vote of the governing
body well in my town the governing body
is the entire town which means it has to
go to the town at uh town meeting day to
get out of
this I just really object to that I
think it it's ridiculous thank you thank
you representative pel uh before we go
to the next uh uh comment I just want to
remind everybody that this is an early
bill that needs to be tended to as soon
as possible uh representative um Lang uh
you have comments please I just want to
speak to that statement about governing
body the governing body is your select
board or your Town Council if you have
one the legislative body would be your
town meeting date and vote on that kind
of thing so just a clarification on that
issue as Town moderator the governing
board is always the select board or the
city council the legislative board is
your town uh entire town on a ballot
vote thank you representative Lang
representative samset you have a
comment uh yes thank you Mr Mr chairman
um um I I I've uh didn't consider at the
time uh the previous discussion the
impact on being able to sell directs
that municipalities can do that
represent McGee brought up so um that
basically just solidifies my opposition
against this bill the rest of New
England states are increasing their RPS
remember the RPS is our goal setting
mechanism to say how much renewable
energy we would like to have uh the
other states around us are going up with
their RPS and this this bill here would
tend to would tend to depress the RPS
and and under support it so I would
definitely oppose this
Bill thank you representative ssuch
representative Pim Mel you have another
comment
sorry put my hand down thank you um
representative
oxenham yes um as as the other states in
New England who share our regional GR
with us have moved uh aggressively to uh
raise their Energy Efficiency and their
renewable energy uh many of them now
having you know close to or more than
20% of their total energy coming from
those
sources
um we we've dis we we've touched on the
past but I don't believe our new members
are are really aware of what this means
for regional transmission Mission costs
this you know this small change that you
say someone might notice on their
electric
bill is we our our Peak demand our our
total demand is going up as as the other
states are is going down which means
that the proportion of the charges for
regional transmission that New Hampshire
will have to
pay could be increased by passing this
bill by millions of
dollars and I don't think that very
important issue has been discussed here
and I even though we need um rapid
decision because of second bills I think
we need someone from
Dees to speak to that because that is a
concern they have raised with us in the
past but we have not had addressed in
this session because we haven't been
able to get our orientation from the
dees that informs people about that very
important aspect which will be
dramatically affected by
this thank you representative
representative Harrington you recognize
for comment yeah I have to respectfully
disagree with the last speaker um the
portion of the Y electric bill the
transmission part is a pretty small
portion now I know it's been going up
over the past uh 10 or 15 years mostly
because we've spent billions of dollars
on transmission and that gets allocated
across all of New England now the fact
that we use more electricity in New
Hampshire uh is generally a good thing
because that means our economy is
thriving our unemployment rate even
during the pandemic is much lower than
the rest of uh the uh States in fact at
one point Massachusetts had the highest
unemployment rate in the United States
and as was one of the lowest so the use
of electric consumption is obviously we
don't want to be wasting electricity but
but just by saying we using more is a
bad thing no tell the people that got a
job that's such a bad thing that they
now are working so I have to disagree
with that and I think the amount you're
talking about here is very very small
amount when you're going to say uh
spreading it out over you know millions
of kilowatt hours how many more are you
going to pay for because New Hampshire
uses a fraction of a percent uh less or
more than some other state it just isn't
it's insignificant amount of money and
to Town it might be a substantial
savings especially if they use a lot of
electricity thank you representative uh
I'm hearing the same comments over again
I will take one more from uh
representative samich and um then we'll
move
on uh thank you Mr chairman uh I would
just briefly like to contradict
represented Harrington uh using a lot of
electricity doesn't is not a positive
thing using energy wisely is a positive
thing very wise and that's where Energy
Efficiency comes in in fact using a lot
of electricity or energy uh as the US
has done in the past history where they
have been one of the most wasteful
countries in energy does not make us a
better Society we need to be smart and
use that energy wisely that's where
that's where this RPS comes in and
that's where the Energy Efficiency comes
in thanks thank you restive uh
representative um rer the clerk are you
ready to take the vote please we're in
the voting mode on the a to pass for 614
yes I
am as amended on Bill 614 OTP as amended
I will call the role representative
Thomas yes representative Harrington yes
representative ner yes representative
Mna yes representative
Homa
yes representative bresney yes
representative bernady yes
representative kimbrells yes
representative close yes representative
Lang yes you representative
sage
no representative Cali pittz
no representative man no
Representative oxenham no Representative
Vincent here representative McGee
no representative MC Williams no
representative
Chan no representa
pel no Representative parall
no and chairman representative o
yes
with the vote 11 nine one not voting
motion passes as
amended I declare executive session
April 614 closed use your mic yeah I M
mik challenged uh executive session for
614 is hereby closed and I'm turning the
uh next proceedings over to Chairman
V so we'll now uh resume resume our
public hearing on HB
309 and I will call on the prime sponsor
of the legislation to uh introduce the
bill representative Harrington you're
recognized to introduce HB
309 thank you mrman this
is Mr
chairman point of
order who who's asking for a point of
order Peter samich yes I just want to
clarify uh we we have a minority and
majority report on this yes absolutely
okay so I I would suggest that uh if if
representative oxenham is willing to
write The Minority
Report we'll do good okay thank you
please have it to us by Thursday
afternoon at three o'clock thank
you okay representative Harrington
you're on uh yeah uh this bill is a
pretty straightforward it's fairly
simple it actually came up last year it
was from the governor's whatever they're
calling themselves now strategic
something or other office there um and
it was just to correct what was really a
mistake in the uh in the law I think
this might have been a compromise back a
long time ago but the capacity factor to
that should be used for estimating
purposes according to ISO New England is
about
13.5% now that can change so what we've
done in the bill is just say use
whatever ISO New England puts out
instead of saying it's a blanket 20%
Which I think to be in all honesty even
though this isn't usually the where I'm
coming from that would mean the
utilities were getting credit for you
solder that they weren't actually being
produced and they were buying less recks
because of that so yes will this have an
effect on electric rates very very small
and it would be increasing but it gives
you a more accurate picture of what
actually is being produced and we should
be using the best information we have
not a over-generous guess
pretty
straightforward thank you representative
Harrington any questions for
representative
Herrington seeing none I will call on
the next speaker for the bill which
would be Joseph kwasnik a member of the
public representing
himself
so Mr kwasnik yes than thank you Mr
chairman can you hear me yes we can hear
you be be sure to speak uh speak up
clearly thank you okay hopefully this
headset will make the difference from
this morning um yes yes great I am
submitting both written testimony and
oral testimony in support of House Bill
309 and the reason for doing that is to
um Echo what representative Harrington
is saying that this proposed legislative
change change is warranted as the as the
PV energy forecast referenc in the
legislation provides a more accurate
estimate of the capacity Factor rating
for PV installations than the current
20% in fact the PV energy forast results
have resulted in a lower capacity Factor
rating approximately 14% in recent years
this lower capacity Factor rating will
result in fewer class two renewable
energy credits to be distributed to each
electricity provider in New Hampshire
some total of that is they'll have to
come up with more wrecks um than they
have in the past so that completes my
testim and thank you for the
opportunity thank you any questions for
Mr
kwasnik seeing none I will call on the
next person who has signed in to testify
and that is meline mano a lobbyist for
clean energy New Hampshire and Miss Mano
the floor is
yours thank you chairman Vose uh and
thank you members for the opportunity to
testify on this bill clean energy New
Hampshire supports House Bill
309 um as a little bit of background two
years ago in 2019 uh there was a bill
pass Senate Bill 72 which would have
repealed um what we call the rec
sweeping credit which is the credit
given to all energy suppliers that have
a renewable portfolio standard
obligation for recks for which the
owners did not register to be eligible
to Market their own
recks so uh Senate Bill 72 would have
repealed that provision
and it was vetoed by the governor um
however in the governor's veto message
it said um that our focus should be to
fix the credit mechanism in the law not
repeal it currently so uh what that
reference is talking about is making
that change in the capacity factor used
to calculate the credit um as I
mentioned also in my written testimony
the Public Utilities Commission in their
last review of the RPS also recommended
making this change uh in the capacity
factor used to calculate the credit to
be clear clean energy New Hampshire
opposes the credit entirely because we
view renewable energy certificates as a
commodity owned by the Renewable Energy
System owner and uh we see this Rec
sweeping credit as The Taking of their
property without their knowledge or
compensation for that
property however um the capacity factor
used currently um of 20% is just
inaccurate for solar and almost the
entirety of the credit is solar it
actually makes up a very considerable
amount of the total obligation for solar
renewable energy certificates in the
RPS um in the last year that we have
information for the credit made up
0.479 4% of a 0.6% obligation so it's
it's quite a bit so using the 20%
capacity Factor artificially inflates
the credit and so the least we could do
is to actually use a realistic number
which is exactly what uh HB 309 proposes
to do so we support making this change
recommended in House Bill 309 and ask
you to vote out to pass on the bill
thank
you thank you Ms Mano are there any
questions for misss
Mano seeing none and having no other
people signed up to speak on this bill I
guess we can close the public hearing on
HB whoops representative c pittz a last
minute hand go ahead well I I I wanted
to ask a
question of Representative Harrington
and I guess I can't because he presented
and he can't ask answer questions is
that
correct no you can answer you can ask
questions he can't ask questions oh I
can ask a question yes yes of the last
witness no but I I wanted to
know why you would Advocate when you
said electric rates increasing why would
you advocate for electric rate to
increase can I answer that question Mr
chairman yes okay uh uh thanks for the
question I'm not advocating for an
increase in electric weights what I'm
saying is that's a result of this but
it's result of being of using a more
accurate number the 20% was some kind of
a I don't know exactly how it came up I
think it was you know is how one gets a
camel with a horse and all that stuff it
was a compromise that came up to uh push
the numbers artificially low it just
isn't accurate uh it's a simple thing is
that 20% we shouldn't be used because
it's not the right number and as the one
of the gentlemen spoke there he said
around 14% I I heard 13 and a half
whatever comes out of iso in the wi that
accurately reflects what we're getting
the 20% was artificially high so the
utilities will have to buy some
additional recks based on that which
means they'll put that into the rate so
there'll be a slight increase but it
just is an increase that we should have
had to begin with because that reflects
the reality of the
situation thank you very
welcome are there any uh further
questions for either Ms Mano or
representative
Harington seeing none we will close the
public
hearing on House Bill 309 and I will
report that we had 40 people who signed
in in support of this bill we had two
people who opposed it and one person who
was
neutral uh we had a few elected
officials who signed in on this bill uh
representative maputi from nashwa was
opposed to the bill uh representative
Thomas Elaine Thomas supported the bill
and
representative Paul elely opposed the
bill so those were the um elected
officials who signed in on that
bill so with that bill having been uh
the public hearing on that bill having
been closed and we still have uh some
time left before we um have to open the
public hearing on the next bill I would
like to open a public session on HB one
executive session rather on HB 119 and I
would like it like to
uh recognize for a
motion uh representative cam
brills yes thank you Mr chairman I would
like to make a motion to itl Bill
hb19 representative cam brils has moved
that we move itl on
hb19 chair recognizes representative
Bernardi I will second that
motion it has been moved and seconded
that we uh itl
hb19 is there any
discussion
representative
McGee un don't forget to unmute I just
realized um I would like to ask why we
are recommending
itl do you want to address that
representative cambril since you made
the motion yes thank you for the
question uh I just see this simply as I
do not feel that we the legislature
should be giving away this authority to
uh unelected bureaucrats when uh this is
what the people of New Hampshire elected
us to do is to be their voice so that's
that is why I am uh I am recommending
itl on this
bill representative
uh uh oxenham I guess is next thank you
um again I must protest going to an
executive session on on this bill ahead
of our ability to hear the
orientation from the Department of
Environmental Services which would
educate our new members and many of our
old members as to the reasons why
certain things are done in certain ways
and how they actually work in a
composite to affect public policy for
the public good in the state of New
Hampshire I think it's it's just wrong
to be
working on these bills I yes we could
have the public hearings in advance but
not to move to taking final
votes for
test thank you uh representative ssuch
is
recognized yes thank you Mr chairman um
I think um to to the reasoning why one
would itl this to say this should be a
part of the legislative
process I I think U that looks like a
little bit too much optimism of what the
legislature can actually do setting the
rates for the SBC is a very complicated
process as we heard and it's whether
they're unelected uh officials or
experts who know what they're doing is a
big difference uh I suggest that none of
us would say we know better what a
surgeon should do with our with our
injuries than than they do so let's get
a committee together to say what the
best treatment is we have experts who
know how to do this they're doing this
right now they've been doing it and to
put this in the lap of the legislature
which cannot deal with it in an timely
manner is quite irresponsible I think
thank
you thank you uh representative
man I'll on mute thank thank you Mr
chairman uh well I I agree with the
preceding um objections to this bill to
this
itl um first of all um I can't
imagine U anyone wanting to get into the
business of doing Energy Efficiency work
if the legislature uh which can change
every other year um is going to be
deciding whether or not to uh include
Energy Efficiency payments uh or funding
in the um systems benefit charge and I I
think the U the history of this bill is
uh this whole concept of uh supervision
by
the U legislature was based on a
completely
erroneous um and really fallacious uh
um attrib ution to uh the Constitution
basically the Constitution requires blah
blah blah you know people can only the
people or the the
representatives or authority derived
there from so can
um impose something like the
SBC
um
the last three words uh last four words
of that
Constitution Clause Article 28 do
justify completely justify the SBC being
uh decided by the organization called
the Public Utilities Commission so the
question is what is the
motive for this
um this insisting that the the uh that
the leg well never mind that um I just
wanted to say I think the effect of this
was just to be freeze our our ability to
do the Energy Efficiency work we need to
do now I've worked on uh some analysis
about the Energy Efficiency in a sense
we're doing such a poor job in this
state um Massachusetts has been doing
this work for 25 years and they've way
ahead of us and they've got a tremendous
amount of work done I think what people
don't understand is that once a house is
insulated say or improved it stays
improved for the rest of its until it
burns down or falls down the uh so
there's a revenue stream not a revenue
stream a savings
stream it's money we don't send to the
oil
industry to buy fuel we have a savings
stream from the first year you do an
Energy Efficiency program from the
second year from the third year and they
just keep going
massachusetts's first year 25 years ago
has been producing savings stream that
savings stream lasting 25 years what
they did 24 years ago is a saving stream
that's lasted 24 years and so on you all
add up uh those numbers up to what they
did this year give you a savings stream
a little short one of one year um that
that you add dolls up you got 325 you
don't have 25 you did the
325 in 25 years because of the
continuation what we're doing is we're
robbing ourselves
blind this is absolutely
stupid to do
this and I'll rest my case for
that so representative man I I'd like to
register my opinion on this I think the
question here is not does the
legislature want to get into the
business of setting the system benefits
charge the question here is who is
accountable for a mandated government
charge is it bureaucracy or is it the
legislature and I think some of us
believe that it is the legislature who
has to be held accountable to the public
for whether or not the system benefits
charge goes up or goes up or down the
legislature can be convinced that a
increase in the system benefits charge
is legitimate and I'm sure the
legislature will agree to that but at
some point somebody has to be held
accountable and we believe that many of
us believe that it's the legislature
that is the body that will be held
accountable so the legislature needs to
be have oversight over the system
benefice
charge okay who else has a comment here
thank you very much for that but the
fact is we do have oversight we can at
any time if we feel the systems benefits
charge is excessive if we feel something
is done wrong the legislature can step
in and complain about that and set it
come up with a bill saying you know the
maximum will be this or anything else
but that's prior to a problem the SBC
has been set very accurately and very
productively over the years and there's
no reason no reason has been
given for wanting to put for feeling
that the legislature actually has to do
anything in terms of supervising the
Public Utilities Commission in this very
good work that they do thank you uh
representative we are wasting tremendous
amounts of money the money
that Massachusetts has saved that I
Illustrated we're sending that to oil
companies the oil companies should be
thanking us for our
our failure to do Energy
Efficiency thank you representative man
representative Homa thank you chair I
just want to comment on something that
representative man just said saying that
if for some reason the PC has this
authority to set rates and the
legislature has the oversight to that
and if we see that there's any issues
with that we can step in and propose a
bill to um to change those rat then
we're right back to square one so the
authority ultimately lies with the
legislation or the legislature not with
the Pu thank
you thank you next up is representative
Cali
pittz been uh dealing
with Energy Efficiency since my landlord
told me at one point not my current
landlord that the on the inside of the
window was really
insulation
um and we've we've come from duct tape
and plastic to really knowing what
insulating a home is and what it would
save I truly believe and I and I sat I
sat in on many discussions because I've
been here long as Moses that we couldn't
do it as a legislature we didn't have
the expertise to sit down and go through
everything that is in that's entailed in
the SBC and how much it should be and
what so we as a legislature seeded that
authority to the
Pu and at this point I think that's the
place where it stays I don't know if
anybody I was on electric oversight and
all kinds of I don't know if anybody is
qualified
to gen those numbers and I and I I don't
think we are and what we
need uh I've sat here and heard
testimony that there were 25,000 people
on the waiting list now that's gone down
quite a bit I do believe but still more
is needed and
even new homes it's needed because new
homes are not always energy efficient
so I would say that this is a really
important program but it should not be
in the hands of the legislature because
then every two years it can change I
think we need some consistency we need
some stability and that's why we should
do this and do it properly thank
you thank you representative
chanos um I think I'm mainly just
echoing what other people have said but
I do believe that as wonderful as our
400 person legislature is in terms of
breadth of expertise um we don't have
the depth of expertise needed to do
something as specific as rate setting um
there's many many places in the
government where the legislature has
delegated rule making authority to um to
other other bodies um completely
appropriately and uh yeah I will not be
voting to itl this I feel like this is
an appropriate ation of
responsibility okay thank you uh
representative
oxenham yes if I may just turn to RSA
2119a for the moment where the policy of
New Hampshire is set out with regards to
uh state
agencies it shall be the policy of the
State of New Hampshire to prioritize
public health and Environmental Quality
while maximizing economic benefits
through the use of economical energy
energ efficiency measures including but
not limited to and then it goes through
the laundry list of all the different
Energy Efficiency measures that are
available to us then going on to say and
it shall be the policy of the state to
encourage municipalities to incorporate
such measures into their properties to
the greatest extent possible what Energy
Efficiency about is about saving money
why anyone would want to possibly not
save money but waste money I don't
understand why anyone would want to send
four billion dollars of our state's
money out of state we don't produce any
fossil fuels we have renewable energy
businesses in this state we have
renewable energy jobs and Energy
Efficiency jobs investing in those
measures grows our economy grows our
wealth
I cannot understand why anyone would
support this bill it hurts our jobs it
hurts our economy it hurts our
environment and it reduces our
wealth don't
support thank you Mr chairman I just
want to uh comment and uh build on what
uh representative oxman has said you
read the statute
uh statutory requirements about it being
the
legislator's responsibility to set
public policy we are capable of doing
that and Advising that and presenting
that position to the broader legislature
for its approval we don't have to make
technical decisions when we have
technical issues we can defer those to
technical bodies but we are the body to
make that policy and set the policy and
determine how much of whatever we're
going to do needs to be done so I I I
think this bill is totally in order and
totally coincident with that fundamental
philosophy thank you uh representative
McGee thank you Mr chairman um to to
that point to representative cell's
point I think that's the Crux of the
matter right the bill is about who who
should have the authority to determine
the system benefits charge and it's
getting a little confusing because we're
talking about iing a bill right so um
what I wanted to say about the argument
of whose hands it belongs in is we're
the ones that gave rate setting to the
Public Utilities Commission and now
we're saying we should take it back from
the Public Utilities Commission and I
think the point that we're trying to
make is that the
legislature tends to be a political body
which means that our perception of what
should go through and what should be
stopped changes frequently which is
why the Pu is not a bureaucratic agency
the Pu has a stronger Mission and
mandate than we do to keep politics out
of it and serve the masters of least
cost greatest benefit you know to the
most people they're less political than
we are in terms of how they Implement
their role in the rate setting process
and do everything above board in a in
public and adjudicative proceeding which
is not the same as us arbitrarily taking
a vote on yay or nay based on our
political parties which happens a lot so
I would I would ask that representative
cambrell understand that we're not
taking it out of the hands of a
bureaucratic body we're really putting
it in the hands of a Bure ratic Body by
lling the idea uh that set forth in 119
so I think we have different
perspectives on that clearly but rather
than just argue the benefits of Energy
Efficiency we should understand that we
gave this authority to the Public
Utilities Commission because that is all
they do and we don't do this so giving
it back to us seems to be uh setting us
back
backwards
uh thank you representative Bry uh thank
you Mr chairman I'd like to just build
on the analogy uh that Mr ssuch uh gave
with a patient going to the surgeon
instead of uh performing the surgery
themselves um when you do go to the
surgeon the surgeon doesn't just start
operating on you right there's there's a
communication there's um the surgeon
explains what's going to happen and then
ask for your approval or permission to
start you performing this surgery uh the
same thing happens with the Pu the Pu is
the professional and they will determine
what needs to happen and will'll explain
that and then the legislature can
confirm uh what needs to happen thank
you uh
rep representative McGee did you have
your hand no you put took it down okay
thank you all right representative Cali
pitz I I I guess I didn't understand the
last
um speaker because that would seem to me
like okay Public Utilities you do the
work you do the adjudication you do what
you're going to do now and then either
the legislature will rub rub a stamp or
negate what you're doing even though we
don't have the evidence and the proof
and the numbers that's what I heard can
you correct me if I heard that
wrong
I was just comparing it to going to a
surgeon I mean the surgeon is not going
to tell you every single detail of what
they're going to do but they will
explain the pros and cons and let you
make the decision so I assume the Pu
would do the
same I would just
say okay I'm not
gonna okay I have received an
email
from represent from Michael Fitzgerald
from I only need it when I'm active but
if I'm sitting walking slowly I can do
without
it I just I just muted him um I've
received an email from Michael
Fitzgerald at Dees he would like to
comment on the next bill that we're
going to be hearing which is HB
373 and he has to leave for another
meeting so we need to start the public
hearing on HB 373 promptly
so that we can uh recognize Mr
Fitzgerald as I think it's a courtesy
for us to allow him to speak on that
bill uh so that he can get to the other
meeting that he
has I I understand that so can wew the
vote I I'm I'm just explaining to the
committee right now why why I'm going to
cut off further discussion on this bill
so that we can take a vote okay so that
we can finish this executive session on
time and start the next public hearing
on time to give Mr Fitzgerald a chance
to speak and still make his subsequent
meeting so uh having said that I would
like to call on the clerk now to call
the role on the question before the
committee which is itl on
hb19 Mr clerk call the rooll on Bill
hb19 motion of itl Representative Thomas
yes representative
Harrington me get here so I can get back
in the picture I guess I'm yes I yes
itl representative ner yes
representative mner yes representative
Homa
yes representative brne yes
representative Bernard yes
representative Cal yes representative
Jose yes representative
Lang
yes representative
sage no representative Cali
pittz
no representative
man no
no Representative oxenham
no Representative Vincent not here
representative McGee
no representative MC Williams
no Representative
crean no Representative
pimel no and representative pasel no and
chairman V
yes the
itl stands 119 one not
voting so representative cam brills
you'll be responsible for producing A A
Min majority report will there be a
Minority Report representative
ssuch uh yes there will be I'll let you
know Mr
chairman you'll give me the uh assigned
writer yeah later I will okay all right
thank
you okay with that um
we'll close the executive session on
hb19 and we will take a six minute break
before we start
the uh public hearing on House Bill
373 after the introduction of the bill I
will call on Mike Fitzgerald to be the
first person to speak after the
introduction we'll see you back here
exactly at 4 CL seems like a waste of
six
minutes sometimes you just have to
[Music]
well I think this is our on
Mr chair you're
muted I can hear
myself doesn't look like I'm
muted
um well it does show that I'm muted
doesn't it
okay I guess uh now I hear an
echo what happened U representative Bry
can you
tell our Tech guys probably The Nearness
of the next laptop that's creating the
echo that usually can't be right next to
each other when you're got your mic on
it's just the room that needed to be
unmuted and represent V you can keep
your your device muted um the room is
unmuted now the room is
unmuted
okay my device is
muted
so are we okay now we can hear you okay
all right so are there any questions
that um representative I mean that
Michael Fitzgerald from Dees can answer
before he has to leave to go to another
appointment
uh representative
McGee thank you Mr chairman and thank
you um Mr Fitzgerald the question that I
have is if this bill passes whether it
would inhibit your department from doing
its
job uh well thank you for the question
and um uh Mr chair thank you for your
consideration and allowing me to uh to
respond um due to my uh next commitment
uh the uh
Department uh has previously
participated in these type of activities
um solely from the standpoint of being
able to inform our executive uh chief
executive the governor the governor's
office and staff and the legislature as
to what these Regional activities are
and how they might impact New Hampshire
an example would be the regional
greenhouse gas initiative where we
participated for several years we were
the last state to actually sign on and
we did not sign on until uh actually uh
after the first auction had begun um and
uh that was because we were unsure of
the impact on New Hampshire and uh what
our participation would mean we were
able to get a report get a study and get
information provided uh to then Governor
Lynch to recommend that um New
Hampshire's best interest would be
served by participating um because we
would be uh better off being in and
receiving the the funds as has been
expressed this committee many times so
our participation in these Regional
discussions although it's not directly
required by Statute or anything is just
uh simply to uh to better inform the
legislature as to what the potential
impacts would be um in the case of the
low carbon fuel there was some news
media uh about this last fall that uh
seemed to imply that we had spent uh
significant amount of funding after the
governor had directed the state not to
participate um that I just want to
clarify that uh some of that that um my
letter clarifies that that information
the uh amount expended was expended
between
2012 and now and that that was all
relative to our participation in these
ongoing discussions to determine what
the nature of the program was last fall
we were not able to recommend to the
governor that we that we should
participate because we did not believe
that the impacts had been uh com had
been
Quantified and uh we advised the
governor's office not to sign on to the
uh to
theou um so uh that's the role that
we've been playing this was recognized
in 2012 there was another bill to
prevent us from participating in lcfs
discussions at the time Senator Bradley
broker to compromise that allowed us to
participate in the discussions but not
to be able to bring any uh any program
forward and that's the current statute
as it exists now is that um uh we would
not bring any any uh any program forward
um or or attempt to sign New Hampshire
onto participation without the uh
appropriate legislative Authority which
is the way it stands currently for uh
for Reggie so that's uh and I I would
also just note that the expenses that
were um uh reported as in accordance
with the statute were expenses of Staff
uh staff time which um those expenses
and hours were attributed to this but
they were not over and above or in
addition to any any uh staff time
um they were uh staff that were
allocated to participate in this based
on uh the direction of Prior governors
uh to better understand these these
discussions and um uh we we did
participate U but the that those funds
would have been allocated and and used
uh in any case these were not
expenditures over and above our
budget thank you uh Mr Fitzgerald what
is your time constraint what time do you
need to leave uh I'm um 4:30 or so if if
I if I could leave by 415 that'd be fine
but I I'll I'll try to answer as many
questions as I as is possible
I okay uh representative Thomas do you
have a question for Mr Fitzgerald yes
thank you Mr chair thank you Mr
Fitzgerald for taking my question real
quick was your staff's
participation in in this um for the last
say couple three four or five years was
it voluntary or did the governor um
Express or insinuate that he would like
you to attend these
meetings uh prior Governors uh uh
Governor Hassen uh in particular um had
uh uh we again we we consult with the
governor's office all the time on these
type of activities that come up on a
regional basis um they had expressed an
interest and we we uh we were
participating we continued that we had
no specific direction from Governor
sonunu but we were able to advise him um
that based on the information that we
had and our participation in the
discussions two things one we had um uh
been able to to represent New
Hampshire's interests in the design and
development of program but two we were
not able to determine that um any impact
on New Hampshire would be either
positive or negative the way that we had
been in Reggie and so therefore um we
recommended we could not recommend to
the governor to sign on to theou signed
by the other state and as you'll notice
in our letter New Hampshire did not
ultimately sign on and the governor
ultimately determined that he would not
participate thank
you thank you uh representative oxam you
have a question for Mr
Fitzgerald I actually didn't think I was
next but um yes thank
you Mr Fitzgerald does it make sense to
you that a state which is part of a
regional electricity grid which is part
of a regional Capp trade
program which has many interests in
common with the states that surround it
should not participate and not discuss
issues of regional
concern and and if that is too personal
a question I I I apologize but I I
honestly I cannot understand anyone
putting forward this bill well thank
thank you um I I think that the uh the
reasonable answer to that is that um we
want to be aware of what's going on
around us I would draw some distinction
between the electricity grid this
program was a fuel program but there is
a regional fuel distribution system uh s
analogous to the electricity grid uh New
Hampshire does not have the opportunity
to to impact that um Regional fuel
distribution system overly much because
the amount of fuel we use is relatively
small uh again similar to the uh to the
electricity grid but we feel that being
at the table uh we're at least able to
protect our state's interests and
concerns as expressed by the governor uh
whoever the governor may be at the time
and that um uh we we we carry those into
those discussions and we we hope and
believe that uh that our opinion and and
our Governor's concerns are heard and
reflected in the development of the
program thank you
sir thank you uh representative ssuch
you have a question for Mr
Fitzgerald yes thank you Mr chairman uh
thank you Mr fitzgeral for taking my
question um first of all I want to say
that in the past I have made extensive
use of your staff on various issues that
I was less informed about and I always
got very good information and very good
solid backing for uh what they what
theyh supported and so my question goes
to this um in the future I mean if this
bill were to pass don't you think that
it would impact the kind of advice you
can give this committee and others of us
who go to you for advice if you're being
being cut out of the
discussions well again this is a
regional discussion and uh uh as I said
we would never take the step of trying
to uh commit New Hampshire to anything
without the legislature's involvement
that was how Reggie came about the
governor agreed that we should bring It
Forward we brought it forward and the
legislature agreed um uh our our
participation in these discussions I I
do believe is is of value to the to the
legislature
um so that they can better understand
whether or not they they think that um
uh we should be participating in these
things I will say since the governor's
announcement we have not been
participating in TCI discussions except
to a very limited extent um because uh
uh the governor uh determined that we
would not be part of that PCT um but if
we we do get some briefings we do
continue to to hear some discussion and
if something were to change in the
design of the program
where we felt it was necessary to advise
the governor that there would be an
impact to New
Hampshire a negative impact to not
participating I guess that's a double
negative but uh um we would we would
then so advise but it would be again a
decision of the governor as to whether
we brought it forward to the legislature
and um would be a decision of the
legislature as to whether or not to uh
to approve New Hampshire's
participation thank thank you
representative cie pittz you have a
question for Mr Fitzgerald yes Mr
Fitzgerald thank you for taking my
question I I'm gonna make a statement
first I just think this is a gag order
there's a song that's go that comes from
Hamilton in the room is it better to be
in the room and hear things firsthand or
to get your information either on
paper or without discussion and without
input do you consider that as good and
the second part of that question would
be does participating in these
particular events cost an exorbitant
amount of
money well as you can see uh we the
expenses you can see the expenses we did
report again those are Personnel
expenditures that would have been
incurred one way or another they're not
over and above our budget they weren't
additional um uh staff were allocated to
the uh to participate in these
discussions um based on uh the interest
of the governor's office um both prior
go Governors and and the uh uh the
current governor um we uh we were a we
were able to Pro properly advise him we
feel um I think one in answer to your
question um about being in or out being
in we are able to bring New Hampshire's
interest to the table we are able to uh
uh you know ensure that there's some
consideration ultimately our decision
May me to participate or not participate
um and whether or not those factors that
we bring forward but I do believe that
we've had an
outsized uh influence uh for instance in
Reggie and we've been able to negotiate
things that we think were important to
keep uh uh you know to uh uh keep the
program uh meeting the needs of the uh
of the citizens of New Hampshire I'm
continuing to receive the legislative
approval I think it's the same with this
if we're there we're able to to carry
New Hampshire's interests forward if not
they're not heard or
considered can I follow up followup very
quickly um it this bill specifically
designates Department of Environmental
Services shall not are there any other
departments or offices in the state of
New Hampshire that are designated to
participate in these
discussions uh we have been the primary
participant uh we if there's a need we
consult with the Department of
Transportation um and we have at times
um we've also discussed and consulted
with uh uh what was the governor's
office of energy now I believe it's OSI
um so um we we have been the primary
participant at the table um under Reggie
there's two participants for the state
there's the Pu and the state of New
Hampshire that are authorized to
participate in the program and
discussions and um uh in in this case uh
this is just an idea at this time it's
an initiative it's not hasn't been no
pact has been formed anou was proposed
we did not sign on to
theou um but uh um we believe our in the
state's interests were were at least
heard thank
you thank you um Mr Fitzgerald has a
expressed a desire to leave um anytime
uh between 4:15 and 4:30 so take that
into to consideration as you contemplate
questions uh representative um partiall
no representative
cran thank you Mr chair and thank you Mr
Fitzgerald for taking my questions I'll
be really quick um can you think of off
the top of your head a benefit to not
participating benefit
uh again we have not been involved in
the development discussion since last
fall since the governor's announcement
last fall so I'm not familiar with the
where the where the program is headed
but at the time it was a cap and invest
program um it seems Seems possible to me
that there would be some charge um
associated with fuel usage uh on a
regional basis and that um the uh return
and investment would be allocated to the
states so it's possible that it might
that this could be analogous to Reggie
but um again we're not party to those
discussions anymore and I I couldn't say
what the actual program design is is um
coming to look like at this point in
time we we've not continued our
participation since La the governor's
announcement last fall we did not sign
theou so the states have not invited us
to continue to
participate thank you uh representative
Harrington
um yeah uh thank you chairman uh uh Mike
just a quick question um you're saying
that as of right now effective for the
rest of this year if nothing happens you
will not spend any time or effort being
involved in this thing because once the
governor made a statement you basically
stepped out of it that is correct and if
you look at our expense allocation and
our testimony letter you'll see that it
declined dramatically um we may have a
few hours here and there participating
in calls that are open to us just to
again to to hear what the direction and
the thinking is and so on but um our
participation at this point is uh um
almost nothing thank
you thank you and I would like to thank
you uh Mr fitzell for making yourself
available to um answer questions and I
would like to also point out to the rest
of the committee that Mr fitzgeral and I
have been discussing a Time when we
could have Dees come in and make a
presentation to the committee it's uh
difficult to schedule such a time right
now but we're hoping that um maybe by
early March or certainly by early April
we'll be able to find such time so Mr D
Mr fitzgeral will be back with other
members of Dees to give us a full
committee presentation so thank you Mr
fitzgeral for being here thank you Mr
chairman for accommodating me and we
look forward to providing you with any
information that you might feel is
relevant thank you okay let's move on to
uh uh the next speaker on our list and
that would be
um Greg Moore from Americans for
Prosperity Mr Moore you're
on point of order Mr
chair we did not hear from the sponsor
of the bill because of Mr Fitzgerald's
need to go
first that's not correct we actually
heard an introduction from Janine nter
on the the contents of the bill and the
rationale for its
introduction I'm sorry if you missed
that maybe I represent um Greg Moore
you're uh recognized to speak we
did this bill was not introduced
properly Mr
chairman I didn't hear I didn't hear any
such
introduction so did you hear Janine n
speak representative Janine nter I I
think you were muted and I think she was
muted we thought you were just talking
in the room during the break yeah hear a
thing okay I was just informed that the
room was muted apparently by accident so
representative nder could you re
introduce the Bill thank you very
much take
two
I have to find My Notes because I gave
them to him
s you gave them back all right a little
background first in 2012 the New
Hampshire legislature passed a law that
New Hampshire shall not join implement
or participate in any state Regional or
national lowc carbon fuel standards
program or any similar program that
requires quotas Caps or mandates on any
fuels used for transportation industrial
purposes or Home Heating without seeking
prior legislative approval the
transportation climate initiative is a
regressive gas tax that
increases ta I'm sorry is a regressive
gas tax increase that harms those who
can least afford it like the elderly on
fixed incomes the Working Poor are those
who commute to work like my adult
children do they cannot afford to have
to pay more at the gas pump it's unfair
to place this burden on their backs it's
no secret that I despise tax increases
and it's never just for one thing it
causes increases to everything connected
to it nearly every product that we buy
at the store is delivered by trucks TCI
would drive up the cost of goods because
it will cost more to run the trucks that
deliver them the increase is then passed
along to the
consumers TCI would raise those taxes
for years to come however unlike in the
legislature where our constituents can
hold us accountable for tax increases
that hurt them in the wallet TCI shifts
the responsibility of raising gas taxes
to an unelected and unaccountable board
the public deserves the right to know
and hold responsible the people who are
taking money out of their pocket
Governor sonunu has confirmed that we
will not be joining the transportation
climate initiative but the TCI website
shows that New Hampshire is a
participant and the New Hampshire
Department of environment Services has
spent close to $50,000 I have the chart
since 2012 to study the proposals that
our state is banned from entering
because the law still allows them to do
so House Bill 373 will take out six
words and replace them with we shall not
participate to save Granite Staters some
of their hard-earned money it should be
the simplest Bill we bet all year I ask
you to support House Bill 373 and pull
the plug on TCI and stop having Dees
staff from wasting time and money on a
program in which the state will not be
participating okay thank you uh
representative ner and my apologies to
the committee for not realizing that the
M the room was
muted one of the uh many vagaries of
doing community committee meetings using
Zoom so are there any questions for
represent ative n representative ssuch
you're recognized for a
question thank you Mr chairman and thank
you represent nter for taking my
question uh I heard from you your
motivation for this bill and but I don't
see how this is anything about TCI TCI
is currently an initiative and not
really a a fleshed out
proposal and so to to against it at this
point makes no sense to me so my
question to you is uh why why should we
not even have a discussion why should we
not have information we don't have to
buy into it but we should be informed
what's going on the other states around
us together have a bigger influence on
New England than we do and we will be
dragged along unless we're at the table
why shouldn't we have discussions and
information
Exchange it will TCI will raise the gas
tax and it's going to keep going up and
you know how I feel about
taxes and um
I'm right lost my train of thought here
I'm sorry um oh they I have the chart of
how much money they spent I mean I'm
sure that they TCI has reports they
could read without using the resources
that could go to something else
follow up Mr chairman follow up well
again you referred T to CCI we shouldn't
be supporting it but no one's no one has
finalized that proposal it's like the
draft of a treaty that you you're saying
I'm not going to ratify even though it's
not completed wh why shouldn't we be at
the table until we have to make a
decision because it costs money to do
that and I ran as a fiscal conservative
to try and
lower um spending as much as
possible okay thank you uh
representative McGee is recognized for a
question thank you Mr chairman and thank
you representative NADA for taking my
question um I think us going back and
forth about which programs are pending
uh that might be affected by this
change uh
is is you know separate and distinct
from what this change actually does
because it's basically not saying New
Hampshire isn't going to participate in
any low carbon programs it's saying that
our Department of Environmental Services
is prevented from having any involvement
and can't do any planning and can't do
any discussions with any other states in
the region and my concern or my question
to you is to me the Department of
Environmental Services is a resource to
us because they have information that we
need and if we are telling them they can
no longer participate in securing that
information aren't we to go back to my
original question to Mike Fitzgerald
aren't we preventing them from doing
their job and and I and the one caveat I
just want to say I participated in the
emissions commission over the summer
with Senator Bradley and others and the
Department of Environmental Services
provided a really wonderful presentation
to us where they uh were able to give us
information we would not otherwise have
had about um how the state has worked on
lowering its emissions where we're at on
that trajectory and that we're going to
level off basically in 2021 without um
without additional um policies to affect
that that downward trajectory that we've
been on they are the people who provide
that information and a lot of what they
were giving us had to be separated from
what are other states doing what's
happening in the region what's New
Hampshire doing they can't do that if
they if they can't work with anybody
else if they're prevented from from
doing that work so I that's what I don't
understand is the words in this bill say
the Department of Environmental Services
shall not participate in discussions or
planning for any programs so it's not
specific to TCI it basically says
anything to do with us
addressing uh our environmental
responsibility on on emissions uh they
can no longer provide us with that
information because they they can't get
it they can't work on
it I just don't understand what the what
the impetus is because like they said
once the governor said we're not doing
TCI they're not working on it um so this
goes further this basically says it's a
gag rule so so is there a question there
representative mcge understand how
they're supposed to do their job with
this gag
rule that was a very long long question
I got lost in it somewhere but they're
spending money on a program that we're
not going to be a part of so why spend
the money well we're paying them to do a
job for us and this inhibits them from
doing the job that's the way I see it
remember we're not here to debate we're
here to ask questions remember I
understand I understand and it's the
same question that I asked at the
beginning is the Department of
Environmental Services going to be
inhibited from doing their job which we
pay them to do by not being able to ask
questions or participate okay that
question was asked in and answered thank
you so uh next up is uh representative
cran Mr chairman I did not hear anyone
answer that question that's why I'm
posing it
again I did not hear anyone answer I
heard you asked that question of Mike
Fitzgerald when he was here and he
answered
it okay so why ask it again I didn't
hear him representative cran you're
recognized for a
question thank you Mr chair and thank
you representative not for taking my
question um so understanding
that your concern is that we are
spending um we might be spending money
that we don't have or don't want to
spend are there any concerns that not
being uh participating in these
discussions or planning of programs
might actually cost us money in the long
run if things are happening that we're
not aware of that we need to uh catch up
with or or that we're going to be
impacted
by I'm going to to um defer your
question to um the next speaker that's
coming on if you don't
mind okay uh
representative Cali pittz you're
recognized for a question yeah I think
my question is going to be referred but
I have another question for
representative ner representative ner
why didn't you say that no Department
shall not par shall not participate in
discussions
why Target Dees because we know that
there are probably other people in the
administration that could do this so it
seems to me that um Dees is targeted
could you tell me
why because those are the figures that I
have on how much they they have spent I
don't have the figures from other
departments if they're out there then I
will address it in another
bill may I follow up follow up what does
it
cost for people to listen and gain
knowledge just like sitting here what
does it cost me to listen and gain
knowledge I I don't understand that is
that what we're saying that it costs too
much to
listen that's a legitimate question
because it seems to me that they cannot
participate or commit the state to
anything but they can listen and gain
knowledge of what's going on around us
and maybe what we should be doing okay
you've asked the question can uh
representative n respond you're asking
what it costs it well in 2012 it cost
$914 127 and 2013 $182 57 and 2014
$533 20152 $
42153 2017
$3,251 2018 it was
$3,555 2019 they spent
8,980 43 and then in 2020
$455 N3 that adds up to 4
7,747
198 to listen to a a program that we're
not going to be a part
of okay uh representative crean you have
another
question I do thank you chair um I was
just wondering with those numbers can
you give any insight as to why um in
some years it was only like $100 and in
other years it jumped to 3,000 what what
was the difference
there that would be a question for Mr
Fitzgerald I suspect it it has to do
with how often the
TCI U committee was meeting and how
often de Dees uh listen to into those
meetings but Mr fitzgeral would know for
sure uh representative Jackie KY pittz
you have another question I'm sorry no I
I I'm gonna go back to Mr Fitzgerald's
statement where he said that's not money
that they would not have spent anyway
because that's money they a portion to
people so they have to account where the
people are spending that money and it's
money that would have been spent I just
wanted to clarify that that's what's his
testimony okay thank you all right so
seeing no further questions for
representative representative PL you
have a question thank you Mr chair to
representative n may I this uh
representative
n um can you build I'm sorry I can't
hear you very
well get closer to the microphone please
in in this in the bill
373 uh line
three shall not participate in
discussions or planning of such
programs is it your intention that
thees could not
discuss any information they received
from other
states in DCS
meetings no I'm just watching the
wallets follow follow
so the way I'm reading this if it
doesn't need any clarification they are
not to participate in the programs
discussions or plannings with the
program but they can still receive
information into DCS and discuss it
internally is that
correct I believe
so thank you what it say thank you
okay seeing no further questions from
the committee we'll move on to our next
speaker and I'd like to call on Greg
Moore from Americans for Prosperity New
Hampshire Mr Moore you're
on thank you Mr chairman can you hear me
we can thank you excellent always always
a good idea to test before you just
leave empty amounts of dead air uh for
the for the record my name is Greg Moore
I am the state director with Americans
for Prosperity here in New Hampshire and
uh if okay with the Indulgence of the
chair would it be okay if I gave a
little bit of the history involved with
this particular
program yes that's fine thank you uh so
the history of this program dates back
to 2009 when three Commissioners uh our
commissioners of of then commissioners
of
Transportation uh the Public Utility
Commission and DEP Department of uh
Environmental Services signed an MOA a
memorandum of agreement to begin moving
forward on a program relative to low
carbon fuel standards uh to seek to
reduce Transportation
emissions now at at the time that that's
what was about low car carbon fuel
standards which mostly were focused on U
Auto and and and gas standards things
such as California emission styles are
actual blends of gasoline that was the
initial intent of moving
forward and now in 2012 when I was
serving as the chief of staff of the
House of Representatives uh there was a
there was legislation brought forward
which is now seen before you which is
21023 that was House Bill 1487 back then
uh the speaker and the majority leader
were on the bill so obviously I had a a
keen interest in it and uh that
basically uh took the approach and and
the the the view that the legislature
should be the policymaking body not the
executive branch unlike Congress who
likes to Outsource policym to to the
executive branch here in New Hampshire
the legislature historically has been
the organization and the entity driving
policy so uh that back in 2012 and and
as Mr fitzerald pointed out the the
Senate made a change to to ensure that
Dees could continue to have the
opportunity to uh to discuss those plans
to make sure that that we could have a
chance to voice any concerns we we might
have well fast forward seven years and
now the low carbon fuel standards
morphed into a regional cap and trade
plan functionally it would work like a
secondary gas tax gas and Diesel tax
administered by a third party in a man
manner similar to Reggie however an
important distinction for Reggie between
Reggie and the transportation climate
initiative or TCI would have the ability
to add or eliminate credits without
authorization from the participating
States meaning it functionally would
have no direct oversight by the
legislature this means a TCI could
increase or decrease a secondary tax uh
with no votes by the general court
whereas with Reggie
uh as as many of this committee know
when when the number of credits is going
to be increased or reduced it requires
approval of the various particip
participating States um and using using
Reggie's I mean using tci's own numbers
uh between 2022 so next year and 203 uh
and
2032 so over that 10 year period vehicle
emissions will drop by 19% just by cars
getting better mileage and switch over
to electric vehicles uh during the
initial roll out of TCA TCI back in
December of
2019 uh the planning effort suggested
that TCI would further reduce those
emissions by between 1 and 6% for a
total uh emission reduction in the
transportation sector of 20 to 25% when
you add in the 19% that was already
coming down the pike now TCI estimated
uh that that would translate into a gas
price increase of between 5 and 17 cents
a gallon G however uh a detailed study
by tus University that came out last
year suggested a just a 3% reduction by
of it TCI as a uh or an overall
reduction of about 22% would result in a
24 Cent per gallon increase in the price
of gas so we are talking about a
substantial hit at the pump and and by
the way that's by Design uh since the
stated goal is to reduce the use of
gasoline and Diesel by make by making it
uneconomical and so last month three
states Massachusetts Connecticut and
Rhode Island announced that they were
signing anou uh at admissions reduction
Target of 7% or 26% overall when you add
the 19% in which is more than double the
3% figure that the tough study use um
and and moreover thatou is actually
concrete mou it's it's not a um it's not
a a hypothetical it is a a fairly
concrete mou uh I have spent a fair
amount of time listening in to the the
TCI discussions one thing I'll say about
them they are incredibly transparent
they are open uh and those discussions
are open for anyone to participate in
and uh I've read through theou for this
from the the states the three states
south of us have signed and uh and that
that is going to have a substantial
impact uh going to that uh 7% reduction
of Emissions on the price of gas and
diesel in those States come
2022 now uh a couple things to keep in
mind
is that is that um you know at the at
the very least I think representative n
is concerned about the actual impact at
the pump is a significant one however
it's also important to understand that
when a state like State like New
Hampshire starts using those resources
to go and engage in these planning
efforts those are resources that are not
used elsewhere um as a former director
at DHHS I've had a fair amount of
experience of uh understanding at when
you allocate staff to a goal those there
are things that that staff can no longer
otherwise do so Dees cannot otherwise do
a number of other things if its staff is
going to be heavily focused on something
like the planning and implementation of
of a program like TCI so for those
reasons we support House Bill 373 uh
this is an issue that again I've had a
long history with and I'd be happy to
answer any questions from the
committee thank you Mr Moore we do have
some questions first up is um
representative
ssuch thank you Mr chairman and thank
you Mr Moore for taking my question uh
Mr Moore um did you help and assist in
drafting this
bill uh did I help and assist in
drafting this legislation I I did have
conversations with representative ner um
at the at the early when when she first
brought it to me
yes okay followup Mr chairman followup
and uh your organization Americans for
Prosperity uh Nationwide is well known
as a lobbyist group for Big Oil isn't
that correct no that's not
accurate how would you describe your
organization our our organization is is
a uh Grassroots uh focused citizen
organization in New Hampshire we have
over 51,000 individuals who who to take
action with our organization and uh and
and we are we are uh definitely focus on
a whole host of issues uh energy being a
very very very small one relative to the
focus of a whole host of other areas
including uh tax policy spending worker
Freedom uh Criminal Justice Reform and
issues like that okay thank you very
much thank you uh representative pintel
you're recognized for a
question uh thank you very much Mr
chairman um
so uh Mr Moore you stated that the uh
the talks at TCI are very open and that
uh anyone can listen in to what's going
on and I guess my question is why do we
not want Dees to listen in too if it's
so
open thank you for the question uh again
there's an opportunity cost uh the time
and energy that is used used and
utilized to put focus on it on these
planning efforts is time where the staff
cannot otherwise engage in other uh ways
of assisting New Hampshire residents of
resolving other issues they have before
the department the you again is not it's
not an there is not an infinite amount
of of time available uh staff staff
resources are limited and when you take
resources away from from one area to put
it in another that other area is is
lessened by that so without question uh
again as someone who who's worked in the
executive branch here in the state of
New Hampshire I have seen it firsthand
uh if you if you the more tasks you give
folks either either other tasks are not
going to be done as well or other tasks
are not going to be
done follow thank you followup so why
are you listening
in because because the uh the impact of
of TCI would be substan
on the uh the motorists of New Hampshire
it would have a a huge impact at the
pump and and an impact that would
continue to go up year year-over year
the the stated goal of TCI is that they
want to make the price of gas and Diesel
uneconomical to to get people to shift
their their habits to other modes of
transportation whether that be public
transit or other other areas but
fundamentally um their goal is is to
change the marketplace and and the way
they Envision doing that is through is
through making uh the use of gas and
Diesel
uneconomical thank you Mr Moore okay
thank you uh next up is representative
Cali
pittz don't forget to
unmute Mr Moore I want to thank you for
your information which I gather you have
have gleaned from extensive
listening um I wonder can
you because what I I think has been
implied can you give me one
instance where Dees has neglected to
Performance duties because that's what
it sounds like I I representative Nas
Figures were pretty quick with me but I
think they around $60,000 or so if I
quick added them up my head but maybe
less can you give me an instance where
you believe that funds have been
misdirected representative C pittz that
question doesn't relate to the substance
of the bill it certainly does Mr chair I
beg to differ with you because what I'm
hearing is that because we spend money
on this program or on learning about
this program we can't spend money doing
that program and that's what was said
and I think that was the reason given by
Mrs Miss ner and I Mrs N and I think
that was the reason that I just heard
from Mr Moore so I want to know that
because if if he believes that funds are
being misdirected because we're spending
too much time learn giving information
or seeking information then I think
perhaps we ought to know about that and
I well if he said that then why AR you
asking the question again because I want
to know if he can give me an instance
where that's if this is an allegation I
want to know if he can give me an
instance all right I'll allow it go
ahead Mr Moore representative CIP pitz
thanks for the question uh the the the
answer is as I mentioned it's it's a
matter of overall resource allocation
and and if you're asking for a specific
instance in the in the uh air division
of Dees I certainly I certainly would
would encourage people to talk to people
about the Shoreland protection division
that's a whole separate question but I I
suspect that it's different Personnel
from Shoreland protection and then over
at air but uh at at as far as a specific
instance I don't but I do know that
there is a that there is a finite amount
of work that you can ask a finite amount
of staff to do and those staffers uh
when they are diverted to one area they
cannot do other work that doesn't mean
necessarily that that someone
necessarily was left without any
Services what it means is they they
could have perhaps gotten better or
quicker services to turnaround times on
permits for example who knows how long
perhaps it might they might have moved
faster had had more resources been
dedicated towards that but but in a
management position at a large state
agency like Dees is you are constantly
focused on the allocation of the time
resources of your staff it is a critical
component to having any sort of
successful uh successful effort and when
you're when you're coming and dealing
with as many legislative mandates as you
as the folks in this committee give
these these uh these individuals they
cannot continue to do everything and and
not have something suffer for lack of
resources okay thank you uh we have four
more people who have signed up to speak
so I would just remind everyone of that
and it is currently 9 minutes before 5
and the speaker has asked us to exit the
building at 5:00 so keep that in mind as
you ask your questions representative
McGee you're recognized for a question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you Mr
Moore for taking my question um you just
represented tci's Mission as making gas
uneconomical and when I heard about the
TCI Regional initiative what I heard was
that they were looking at the uh
Transportation sector as the next large
sector that they wanted to address in
terms of lowering emissions and for some
of us we're still looking at the
environmental impacts and cost of us not
participating and also not addressing
what is happening because of those
admissions so I I I want to know if you
can answer for us since you presented
this from your perspective if you can
actually tell us anymore about that
perspective because you you said that
that America Americans for for
Prosperity as a Grassroots organization
but how are you
funded uh we are funded by over 100,000
donors um a number here in in New
Hampshire probably about 1500 here in
New Hampshire uh and that I understand
that that's not gerain of the
legislation I would I would like to
correct one thing I I hope that I didn't
give the impression that it is their
mission to make gas and Diesel
uneconomical uh but it is their intent
and I I understand that's an important
distinction between a mission and an
intent but they but they they they don't
they don't uh mince words about that
they they realize that that the way to
get there or they believe the way to get
there is not through mandates in fact
that's how where they began they began
the process of doing lowc carbon fuel
standards of actually doing mandates and
they felt as though a better a better
vehicle would be to would be to make uh
gas and Diesel less economical as a more
effective strategy of actually reducing
emissions than uh than than doing things
that they had initially proposed like
having all the states in the region Pass
California Miss Mission standards like
changing the fuel Blends and they felt
it was a better a better vehicle or
better tool to accomplish that
accomplish that does that answer your
question representative I just yeah what
what what you said made me think of one
other thing I could ask you so is what
you're saying that they're trying to go
directly to a market Solution by taking
the external
costs and putting them into the price of
the product because that's what I see it
as when I look what would think that if
it were a true cap and trade program the
the issue one of the issues with um with
TCI that's very different from the
regional greenhouse gas initiative is
that TCI actually has what they call a
circuit breaker meaning that if the
price of gasoline were to increase too
much um that they would just add more
credits so or if they felt like but they
felt like the price of gasoline hadn't
gone up enough they would they would
reduce the number of credits so in other
words clearly they have a target for how
much they want to increase the price of
gasoline in their head and they would
they would execute execute um with that
goal in mind that's not Market related
that that that's command and control and
and I think that that's an important
distinction uh between that and the
regional greenhouse gas initiative
whereas whereas with Reggie when you
want to reduce Reggie credits Reg comes
before the the participating States and
say and says vote on this whereas TCI
would be able to change a number of
credits uh without without any any
involvement of of the legislature or or
either of the states whoever is
authorized within the state to make that
decision um and as as a legislature with
with Reggie none of that would take
place with TCI okay and I would very
much like I would I would remind members
that we're not here to debate we're here
to ask questions and
debating about the climate
Transportation climate initiative is not
the subject of the bill the subject of
the bill is much more narrow than that
so um I would also remind members that
if we
uh stay in this meeting room Beyond five
o'clock we're imposing on the staff of
the uh legislative office building who
have lives and would like to go home at
a reasonable hour so with that said
uh representative crean you're
authorized to ask a
question Mr chair and thank you Mr Moore
for taking my question um getting back
to this issue of being germine I see
this bill as sort of inappropriately
micromanaging how Dees is spending their
time can you give me any other examples
where we've forbid agency staff from
participating in particular meetings or
topics um in the interest of telling
them how they need to spend their time
to achieve their goals so I appreciate
your comment but remember we're here to
ask questions not to deliver our
opinions I I was asking if there were
any other examples of places where we're
telling Dees that they can't weigh in on
a particular Topic in the interest of
making them more
efficient so so first of all
representative thank you for the
question and if I if I might do a quick
aside I want to give my best to
representative PL it's great to see him
on on the camera so great to see you
representative uh and to to answer the
question I I will say I have worked both
in the legislative and in the executive
branch of government and the answer is
constantly uh the legislature does
micromanage if you if you're sitting in
the executive's perspective uh if you're
in the in the agencies you you feel a
constant pressure of micromanagement
that's taking place uh by the
legislature
when you're in a legislative perspective
you're you're simply ex executing your
priorities so it really depends on Whose
seat you're sitting in uh as to how what
your perspective on that I I agree with
the legislator's perspective I think
it's better that elected people actually
make the decisions and set the policy
and I understand that the executive
branch will always view that as
micromanagement but I actually view it
as a good thing and I that's someone who
been on both sides of the
fence thank you for that uh response
uh representative man you recognized no
representative man put his hand down so
I guess we're done um uh with
representative Mo I'd like to call on
the next speaker who is Paul Nikolai who
represents the granite state taxpayers
Mr Nicoli you're
on don't forget to unmute yourself okay
so did that work yes we can hear you now
thank you Mr chairman chman and members
of the committee I'm Paul Nicolai and
I'm from Grandam I'm here today as a
Granite State taxpayer board member I
and the granite state taxpayers are here
to request that you recommend that HB
373 ought to pass we don't have to
debate climate change or global warming
to talk about this bill the bill ought
to pass to prevent a waste of New
Hampshire taxpayer money regardless of
your position on global change or global
climate change or global warming it is
in fact a Global issue New Hampshire's
contribution to global warming is
minuscule New Hampshire's contribution
to any proposed solution will also be
minuscule that's because New Hampshire
is thankfully minuscule Mr fitgerald
even said he effectively confirmed this
when he said that we participate in the
discussions but nowhere did you hear
that the result of TCI or any other
program was changed Ed because of New
Hampshire's position and if you think
about that it makes sense they have 98%
of the problem they're going to
contribute 98% of the solution whatever
we're going to do is an afterthought if
in fact tomorrow New Hampshire emitted
zero carbon nobody would notice
including the environment
so whether we're at the table or not the
result of what happens in these
deliberations is going to be the same we
can read about it in the newspapers we
can get the press releases we can see
all the documents these are after all
public agencies the public has as much
access to what they do as we have to
what we're doing here today so given
that it's a far more effective use of
our tax dollars to not divert staff into
discussions and debates where we will
have no effect we should rather have
them work on things that we can affect
in New Hampshire and that is for the
benefit of New Hampshire people so it's
far more effective to use our tax
dollars to Simply analyze the result of
these multi-year debates and then decide
whether we want to join the program or
not for that reason you should recommend
that HB 373 ought to pass and I thank
you for your
time thank you are there any questions
for Mr
Nikolai did you provide written
testimony Mr Nikolai I did not
uh could you we'd appreciate it if you
could I will do that thank you we would
appreciate
that all right seeing no questions for
Mr Nikolai I will call on the next
speaker who is Joseph kwasnik Mr kwasnik
you're
on go ahead yes Mr chairman can you hear
me I can
okay thank you uh just a couple of
points one is um I actually participated
in the development of Reggie back in the
back in its formative days so I do bring
that perspective of uh all the states
that participate in Reggie which
included all the New England states
including New Hampshire I found that um
those participants from the states and
other organizations actually had quite
an effect on um on shaping this the uh
the uh the development of Reggie
including New Hampshire even though
we're a small state it had an
outstanding um uh influence on how
Reggie was developed so uh the previous
speakers comment about why we even try
we should be trying but let me just take
a step back um New Hampshire is a import
of Transportation fuels from overseas
and from domestic producers in other
parts of the United States and as such
as engaged in Regional and national uh
fuel markets and uh as New England
earned from the regional greenhouse gas
initiative any Regional program such as
Reggie or a low carbon fuel standard
will likely significantly affect the
price characteristics and availability
of Transportation fuels imported into
New England whether we participate or
not now enacting House Bill 373 which
would prohibit the dees from
participating in the development of a
low carbon fuel standard would likely
leave New Hampshire with no ability to
influence the development of regional
low carbon fuel standard but for all
incense and purposes subject to all of
the impacts of such a program and none
of its potential economic benefits
surely not a good outcome for New
Hampshire and its energy consuming
citizens let New Hampshire Dees uh take
a seat at the table thank you appreciate
the time uh to provide this uh testimony
I've also provided written testimony
which is in the record now thank
you thank you Mr kwasnik any questions
for Mr
kwasnik seeing none we'll move to our
final speaker of the day and remind
everyone that it is now 3
5:00 and uh there are committee staffers
in the building here who would like to
go home so with that I'd like to um
authorize uh Mr John Gage to make brief
comments you have two minutes Mr Gage hi
thank you well I'm for Prosperity too I
disagree with uh the state coordinator
of Americans Prosperity though and how
to get there and um I'm also a New
Hampshire taxpayer um
and my ma my biggest concern for my
family's future is carbon pollution and
I think that our Environmental Group in
New Hampshire the dees should be
involved in state Regional and federal
discussions um on how to reduce carbon
pollution um I don't see TCI anywhere in
the bill
or uh the um amendment that what it's
amending um what I read is that this
affects all low carbon emission
standards at the state Regional and
federal level um basically putting
blinders on our
Dees in any discussions about reducing
carbon pollution um that are going on at
any level um I don't you know this just
seems like we're trying to stay ignorant
and removing ourselves from discussions
that um um our legislators should be
aware of we should be paying attention
to what's going on at the regional and
federal level and we should have the
experts in our state um participating in
discussions about reducing carbon so
that we can make good decisions at our
at our state level
um you know it the the taxpayers
association fellow um basically said we
should just free ride we're a small part
of the problem so why should we worry
about our pollution 30 seconds it's
everybody else's pollution that's the
problem well when everybody thinks the
same way nobody solves the problem um I
believe the correct way to address the
problem at the global level is to put a
price on it on carbon at the federal
level and return the money back to
households um and we can use border
adjustments to push that carbon price
around the world what we can do at the
state level is to prepare for a price on
carbon
um many groups say will have a price of
$100 per Time by 2030 time is
up thank you appreciate that did you uh
submit written testimony on this bill I
did not but I shall thank you okay thank
you very much we appreciate your
contribution here this afternoon and we
appreciate I appreciate the committee's
hard work today in U getting through
another five bills getting us much
closer to our goal goal of getting
through the entire 32 bills uh on the
calendar so thank you all we uh our work
is not done this week we will be right
back here on Friday to hear another six
bills uh including a couple of really um
hot button items such as HB 315 about
Community power so we'll see you then
and thanks again have a good uh midweek
take care representative V can we get
the signin for and against blue sheets
oh sorry thank you for that reminder so
for House Bill 373 we had 17 people who
signed in in support and 74 who signed
in in opposition and we
had
um representative Mana py signed in as
an elected official in opposition to the
bill uh representative Tony leus signed
in and supported the bill representative
maren money signed in and supported the
bill
um and I no there was one other John P
pich puchek sorry uh signed in and
support of the bill and Susan Dumis
signed in and support of the bill Kevin
Craig signed in and supported the bill
as well and did Chris TR signed in and
support of the bill as well so all
represent res
atives um and then Vanessa
shien so signed in and support of the
bill
um as well so those are all the blue
sheet sign-ins for House Bill
373 so I'll close the public hearing on
373 and B you all uh farewell speaking I
just have your attention for one minute
I just wanted to add a little bit of
information about the capacity factor
for solar I calculated for my solar for
one year I got
13.7% capacity factor which is pretty
close to what we were talking about and
incidentally I'm getting energy recks uh
I've sold I think six of them this past
year between $22 and $38 per
megawatt excellent okay thank you very
much and uh everybody have a good
midweek and we'll see you back here on
Friday representative cran did you have
a question I don't want to keep you I
just um was wondering if you had any
sense of um subsequent committee
meetings that are being scheduled just
to help me work out my work schedule to
make sure I can be here okay so yes
we're having uh full day of committee
work session or committee sessions on
Friday the 12th and again on Friday the
19th and then again on Monday the 22nd
thank you very much okay thank you